what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the Andrew Tate watch party pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in let's get started
um a couple announcements before we
start the show the first is we have two
clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily
um the second thing is guys if you want
to know our events blessing can you make
sure our Google form is in the chat and
also in the description
um also guys make sure you like the
video that's the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams
um yeah and how many likes to open up
the chat today blessing
uh one thousand a thousand likes to open
up the chat but till then make sure you
sign up for our five dollar membership
Guys these memberships are so important
to supporting the channel um right now
we're trying to save for a kick out cam
um and we also want to set up a third
studio in here we're gonna sign talents
soon at jpt
um so you're gonna have updates on that
in the next couple of weeks
but let's get started so today we have a
lovely panel um why don't we go around
everyone say your name your age um your
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself starting with the one and only
the the
Troublemaker trouble maker
extraordinaire you know
um denalva welcome to the show thank you
it feels good to be back I kind of have
missed your time a little bit but not
really but kind of uh obviously you did
miss me relax yourself she's gonna be
first on the kick out cam
one of her friends got kicked out you
know yeah yeah well she was she was
behaved that day she did well I always
behave anyways even though people love
to hate me they hate to love me but it's
the novel guys you already know uh I am
30 my relationship status
is mysterious
uh fun fact I braid my own hair
oh wow you did that yourself wow it
looks good yeah I'm impressed go ahead
oh hi my name is Kamara Esther I'm 21.
um relationship
I don't want to talk about that today
but yeah um that's about that it's is it
like a situationship it's not a
situationship it's like you know what
I just don't want to talk about it yeah
it's all right I do have a boyfriend
yeah okay that's it okay boyfriend go
ahead hi guys is your favorite pastor's
child she's back my name is cintish but
most people know me as brown and bougie
I am 23. fun fact about me
um I always repeat the same thing I'm a
pasta's child that's the only
interesting thing to say so yeah
hey I'm Nikki I am 22 years old my
status is I'm single single Pringle
um and the fun fact about me
I like to think I have many talents okay
name one I dance okay cool what kind of
dance
um I've grown up doing many different
styles of dance I've done contemporary
I've done ballet I've done Jazz I've
done commercial okay you see you know it
all yeah yeah
go ahead
it's me the notorious MLD I'm 37 years
old I'm single uh first time in here in
London and fun fact I didn't know that
none of these apartments or houses in
London don't have air conditioning yeah
we sweated insane absolutely insane this
would never happen in America this is
why never even even cold states have air
conditioning this is why they're
stabbing each other in the streets
because there's no air conditioning
so you know would you guys actually a
quick question would you guys consider
where I live the hood
I kind of used to be yes yes yes yes
what you ain't been to South London no
this used to be a bit of a hood but then
gentrification means that it's okay now
have you seen the market outside
this is the get it yeah
I get I get mixed because sometimes I
call it the hood I say I live in the
hood and then people are like that's not
the hood There's real hoods and I'm like
well there's more I don't know maybe
I'll take you to Peckham I was gonna say
that I mean I don't want to go
listen you should go that'll be a nice
experience for you I would it yeah be
culture it's fun it's not dangerous but
this is like it's just like Hood light
but it's still the hood yeah I don't
think it's the hood it's the ghetto the
hood is like where there's violence but
the Getters just wears like just not
that developed except this apartment but
um yeah it's like it's like a nice
apartment
like honestly the on the way here this
place makes Miami look safe
yeah it does it really does yeah
apparently the other side of London's
nicer West London yeah
so um today we're talking about the
notorious
you know they do call me you know I'm
not going to say who Insider called me
the female Andrew Tate you know so so um
question do you guys know who Andrew
Tate is yes or no of course yeah
yeah and what are your opinions Danelle
but why don't you start being that the
novel was actually on a panel we we
started off as arch nemesis but then you
know we've come together and she came on
a panel with Andrew Tate yes uh okay do
you know what I've been getting a lot
these questions a lot because I saw a
video well two videos where he was being
physically abusive towards women right
and that kind of made me be you know
lose a lot of it with the one in bed
yeah and there was another one as well
and I'm thinking okay even if it's for
fun for a joke this this that for me I
don't condone those sort of things as a
woman so on that level she's asking him
to do it even on that level as a man you
respect yourself those are the things
that you shouldn't be doing I asked a
lot of my great friends
like choke me like he's supposed to that
was not joking that was a different
extreme sort of level I know because I
recognize certain things so for me I
have no experience from experience in
not in a good way so the reenactment for
me I think is something that shouldn't
be done shouldn't be publicized I
shouldn't be monetized there's no fun
behind it I think it's quite toxic so on
that level my respect for what he stands
for of not for what he stands but but
for how he speaks and presents himself
I'm like you're a bit dodgy at least own
up to your demons before you start
talking like you're so righteous that's
it but it's cool it's cool outside of
the bedroom fun that he did well he's
cool on the surface he's inside I guess
we need to kind of find out a little bit
more about who is he okay all right what
do you have a strong opinion on Tate
um I don't really know him that much
just from like little clips that I've
seen he just like talks down on women
from my perspective I don't really like
him like that but like I don't know but
like what happened with his whole
situation him going to jail I felt like
it was a little bit unfair because it
was not like a lot of evidence on it so
yeah I don't know I just feel like he
deserves a fair chance like yeah do you
think he's getting an unfair trial now
um because there's not a lot of evidence
yeah yeah there's no evidence yeah I
feel like it's an unfair trial because
if you don't if you can't say what's if
you can't show any like evidence of what
someone done then you can't judge that
person for it it's not fair but I think
because of his past as well because of
all the things he said everyone's like
yeah that's who he is he's doing that
that's you know what I mean yeah it's
not just that's why I have to say anyway
okay cool what about you for me I have
mixed um opinions when it comes to
Andrew Tate on the one hand that I agree
with his whole movement to kind of
um build strong men but on the other
hand I just feel like he got too
addicted to the out and he got too
addicted to that outrage marketing and
started to see a lot of outrageous
things which is now catching up with him
and he's finding it hard to you know
back himself now that he's being
cornered there's a reason why it says in
the Bible in James 1 19 you should be
slow to speak because when you think
about what you're saying in the future
no one can ping you against no one can
hold something against you by saying
remember when you said this about women
remember when you said that so I think
you just got too excited or got too
loose and got too addicted to the
outrage marketing and the algorithm you
know constantly promoting him because he
said something outrageous just that in
that and now he's kind of falling
against him so I just feel like he had
the right ideas but if he handle it in a
more mature way and thought about things
that he was saying he wouldn't be in
this position right now do you think he
could have gotten this big if he didn't
do the outrage he would have definitely
not wouldn't have gotten this big
um but it's the same thing with you
you're quite a big person you're
basically the female Andrew Tate but the
reason why you've been able to sustain
it and you haven't found yourself where
you've been cornered like Andrew
Taylor's because I feel like you're very
clever when it comes to saying things in
a way that won't get you you know people
to crucify you um him on the other hand
I feel like he got too addicted to that
and I just feel like you don't have to
fall into that trap of have to having to
say outrageous things so what was like
super outrageous
um so the video that you mentioned I'm
just finding out about this
um what else that he mentioned he
mentioned how he likes to
um s traffic woman I'm believing I don't
think no he never said that yeah he's
not stupid he would never go on on
public record be like yeah I like to
well there's evidence over there I
remember watching an interview with um
Candice Owens and she mentioned how
there was a woman who basically admitted
to joining his little s trafficking I
mean obviously it can't they agreed to
it I will put that but um yeah but it's
only like it's not sex trafficking if
you can leave yeah it was a he ran a cam
Studio business outside out of London
for a while but he wasn't like hey hey
do you want to come get sex trafficked
so what exactly what is it that he was
doing like if he could explain in like
detail what was he doing with women well
he he basically
um he he had a cam business and he would
date some of them and so the issue was
like they're trying to say like they
couldn't leave because they were in love
with him he was a pimp and that's
another problem and this is him maybe
but it's like it's like okay you're
telling me you were trafficked if if
you're you're living in a mansion he
takes some luxury shot like I'm just
thinking if I went home to my dad and I
was like Dad I have this new boyfriend
he had me do cam work I lived in a
mansion He took me luxury shopping but I
am the victim I'm like how are you a
victim but then that's where you are if
you were living in a mansion but then
that's why I feel like what else was
Andrew Tate expecting like if you get a
woman in the house and you're not
committing to any of them and you're
taking them luxury shopping but you're
not really you already know how women
are women are the type of person if you
even whistle at them they will scream
rape but now sorry great but now you
have this whole household it's just like
it wasn't a smart move maybe at the time
it was entertaining to him and women do
this [__] all the time they'll go on
dates with multiple men and accept
resources from them and they get in no
trouble yeah but Andrew Tate is the same
person that says men don't do this and
don't fall into that trap but yeah he's
done it and I was falling back against
it what did he do he's the type of
person I'm sure he's the type of person
that will tell men like don't go for
this woman who knows how to open a
Lamborghini door gets excited by luxury
things and now you're the same man
that's accepting these things these are
dumb he knows that he's dealing with
dumb girls and probably girls that are
with him because they just want clout
and attention and now you're confused to
why they've all gone against you in the
media I don't I don't think they're
against it like I think the reason I
don't think he was trying to marry them
I think he was trying to make money yeah
yeah I mean you can do that at the end
of the day if you want to make money but
now it's kind of going against him
because this is what always happens in
these little Playboy Mansions where you
have so many women women end up lying
women end up using it against you and
this is another problem I have with
Andrew Tate not to stretch it is his um
his encouragement for men to not get
married married and to fall into this
like lifestyle of just having different
women if people don't get married the
family structure will fall apart so the
same man that is in defense of the
family structure is the same person
that's encouraging things that's going
to make it fall apart but why don't we
put it on the women to be more worth
marrying like a hundred years ago you
know you're considered a [__] like an
absolute [__] if you didn't wait till
you were married you know what percent
of women wait till they're married today
five percent yeah five percent are like
traditional wife material and out of the
five percent like what percent are like
actually believe in submitting to a man
so it's like so how how are we gonna
blame Tate when it's like the women
today aren't worth marrying yeah but I
feel like you can say that but someone
like Tate can't say something like that
if you're dealing with these women
behind the scenes and entertaining their
games he's not marrying them but he's
entertaining they look what I don't want
to call it prostitution but whatever it
is to do and it kind of is what about if
you accept a date from a guy you don't
like which 50 of women have done at some
point in their life they've accepted a
date for a free meal are they now
indebted to that man they're not it to
that man but it's like so what about
like do they deserve can he do anything
now I just feel like Tate seems like
he's someone who's able to recognize a
trick or a little gold digger and yet he
continued to deal with them and it's
just like what else was you expecting so
that's my only point it's like what else
was you expecting so I feel like with T
he has the great he has good values but
even with having good values and the
right Vision you have to go about it the
right way in a smart way and think long
term rather than speaking so loosely out
your mouth and I just wish she went
about things in a more smart way and he
would have been able to sustain this
mission that he has to build a strong
stronger man and I totally believe in
that aspect of him but I just feel like
he got too excited and carried away and
now you know his beard is overgrown and
his hair is kind of isn't it what do you
think
um me personally
I haven't heard much of I've heard the
things about him negative things but I
haven't looked into anything about him
just because when I see something
negative about a person I'm not really
going to want to look into that because
I don't want negativity in my life I
don't need to like dig deeper into any
of that so I haven't gone out my way to
look at anything about him I've just
heard things I've seen a couple Clips on
like
um tick-talking things
um so I'm pretty excited for this little
video right now okay so I can actually
follow it
I'm excited so I can actually like
gather my opinion on him and see things
about him because I actually generally
don't really know anything cool cool uh
what about you what is your opinion I
just I just think Andrew Tate is a
overall net positive for men because for
the last decade Plus
everywhere a man goes on television on
movies in music and in video games and
social media they're just [__] on
men non-stop I went back to America
recently and I watched television and I
watched the commercials and everything
is clearly geared to financially
extorting women under the guise of like
female empowerment and I just can't
believe that they fell for the [__] like
especially when you have all these
American women like saying like we're
better than men we're better than men
yet we're at press at the same time
Andrew Tate's only mistake that he made
was he trusted American woman and got it
locked out for six months at [__]
prison so that's the one big mistake he
made but other than that you know I
think that this whole situation
um to be optimistic about it it's really
an eye-opening situation for a lot of
men because there are like hundreds of
millions of men watching this case and
being like yo I trusted this [__]
hoes and now I'm locked up in a Romanian
prison and uh you know it's not and if
that happened to him he's got money
power status what happens to the average
guy that's what he was saying today on
the on the valuetainment interview he
was saying what happened what happens to
like you know Bob the plumber or like
you know Joe the electrician like it's
really awful to see this but also like
as as much as Nativity and garbage that
he's gone through look at how this
despite
the massive unfair social media
cancellation that he's gone through look
at how he has still been ever been able
to overcome this while on house arrest
he was tweeting from prison and still
pissing people off and red pilling
people harder so yeah I mean you know
he's he is I mean if they try to kill
him too all they're going to do is make
a massive martyr out of him right so you
know I just I want nothing but the best
for the guy I think he's going to get
out okay and if they do slap him with
something you know it's just going to be
people seeing like a massive Injustice
in the world and that's just going to
piss off the masses more and wake more
people up to the treachery of government
the elites and all this [__] so you
think that there's no smoke without fire
is that something that is really in your
life because I will say something yeah
I've noticed that usually men that are
in a position of high test or in
whatever type of career whether he's
fighting whether it's you know a
military guy whatever the case is and
you become really powerful usually you
kind of attract the certain toxic sides
of the masculine World whether it's
going to be involvement with drugs
whether it's going to be involvement
with prostitution where it's going to be
involvement with guns whatever right
he's gone down the e-pimp root okay
which for me I'll tell you right now
with the type of profile that he has the
type of people that he will be with the
even in fact being in Romania there is
no smoke without fire I'm not saying
that he is guilty but I'm just saying
listen don't paint somebody to be an
angel just because you like what he says
because I know for a fact by
understanding his profile seeing certain
little hints he's got a very dark past
and he's catching up with him now he's
cleaned up his image fantastic that's
great well done but there's stuff
there's a skeleton skeletons in the
closet that perhaps are starting to
catch up with there is were there
skeletons in everyone's closet it
depends
you got steel tits in your closet too
everybody got skilled and and his past
is not catching up with him these are
recent women that put him in jail who
they have on documentation on WhatsApp
coordinating this and saying how are we
going to [__] get false allegations
against this man how are we going to put
this man in prison how can we lie cry
and manipulate the authorities social
media the mainstream media in order to
put this man in prison and raise
ourselves up those women are pieces of
[__] in every sense of the world and
there's videos of them luxury shopping
like like being so they're saying they
were they were forced to be there and
there's videos of them luxury shopping
while they're there it's like okay we're
in a world where they can just make one
accusation another in prison for six
months yeah and I just say something
um again going back to the Andrew Tate
thing again he has amazing ideas but
this is why uh what I why I felt like
his whole idea of forget marriage don't
get married and just have million
different girlfriends it's just led to
his downfall and I just wanted to speak
out and say like men don't fall into
this trap or thinking that having you
know hoes is like you know life no like
when you just have one woman and you
settle down with that person you can
avoid a lot of problems but I'll tell
you the problem is women don't want to
settle down it's not it's yes they no
they don't because here's the thing okay
men want young women to marry they want
like they would prefer like the ideal is
a young virgin right when women are
young virgins they don't choose to
settle down when women have the most
power in the marketplace the most Beauty
and the most youth they choose
non-monogamy women choose to get married
in their 30s here the average first
marriage in the UK is 31 do men is a 31
year old bride ideal for most men no but
I feel like someone like Andrew Tate
could have found that 20 year old virgin
it's not hard especially he has because
he hasn't this he's married he is
married yeah and actually I'm going to
correct you on that he doesn't say go
out there and womanize and stuff he says
if you find a good woman hold on to her
okay you know if you find a good woman
keeper and I he does also say that like
endlessly chasing hoes is a waste of
time because hoes are hoes there are no
value you know you're going to grow old
and you're going to be some old man in
the club like chasing hoes but he
contradicted himself in the end don't
you think no he's not because he has a
wife and children
he has the very thing you say he's
anti-agance but didn't he have hoes too
that where are all these women coming
from I'm confused something because
every single one of them lying let me
add something to what you said it's like
because Andrew is a very famous person
so he's just like in the media everyone
is in his business every guy or most
percent of guys out there when you have
money to just [__] around sorry they
just yeah they just F around even broke
guys do it yeah it's like um those guys
he actually caught to those apartments
they had a choice to say no but he's
spending money on them a lot of girls go
for that do you know what I mean like so
that does not make him a bad person it's
just because he's famous then people are
like in his business all this this but
like do not mean and does he chase women
or do the women chase them have you ever
seen a very like attractive successful
guy the women come to them they don't
have to do [__] like have you seen like
a National athletes there are women that
buy hotels at every game trying to get
them to cheat on their wives like that
is their full goal there's like it'll be
like the hottest 22 year olds you've
ever seen in your life sitting on the
sideline saying we're down for a three
like this is the thing that the guys get
thrown at them every single home
I used to work at the Amway arena in
Orlando right for the Orlando Magic
awful basketball team and these chicks
would wait outside the arena
for these players to be walking to their
cars walking to the bus or whatever and
try to get these like third and fourth
Stringer dudes because the league
minimum in the NBA at the time was
almost 400 000 a year and these girls
are trying to get baby daddy's status
from these dudes you know what I mean so
they're a lot then let's be real you
girls know there are a lot of predatory
hoes out there yeah yeah come on and
you're here in London and that's my
first time here and I could just tell
you because that's a thing around the
world you know so I think what he's
trying to tell is the same thing I tell
my message is that when a guy learns
game it's not to go out there and date a
bunch of women although you can but
ultimately
is to identify a woman that's good for
you and a woman that's bad for you so
when you know the woman's bad for you
it's pumping dump or you know when a
woman's good for you and she shows
herself be a value you take care of her
you make sure she's solid if she needs
stuff you take care of her after she's
proved her worthiness how is the guy
supposed to know the difference if he
hasn't had experience yeah and that's
the problem is like a lot of girls like
like you've seen it right I'm sure you
guys all know a girl where her boyfriend
has no idea she was a hoe two years ago
right like yeah she's she's smiling yeah
yeah yeah and and so because the guys
that are young and naive they have no
idea like women just have so much more
power when they're young because any any
of us can open our Instagram we have you
know a million messages where it's like
a young guy he has to work and earn that
and the problem is it's just such an
unfair Dynamic where women can actually
be predatory and kind of pull one over
on a guy like a lot of guys want to get
married young but the problem is the
women when we have all the power this is
what we choose to do I have a question
um I actually love Andrew T I just want
to test you guys a little bit um
I just feel like with um this is why men
don't trust women
do you have a lot of questions I want to
like hear from you guys opinion but I
feel like with Andrew Tate okay say this
say for example your son came to you and
said to you um Dad I'm in jail because I
slept with this girl and she lied on me
are you now gonna say I feel so much
sympathy for you or are you gonna tell
your son actually you're in the wrong
for not noticing the difference between
a trick and a good woman why did you
sleep with her and that's my problem I
feel like a lot of people are having
sympathy foreign what about a girl that
gets graped she gets graped you're in
the wrong you didn't know the difference
between a Grapist and a normal guy yeah
but no no no answer answer which one
sorry repeat the question if your
daughter gets raped do you not and are
you gonna come to her when she comes to
you and say do you not know the
difference between a Grapist and a
normal guy no I'm not going to say but
so why why is it when it's men
with men someone like Andrew Tate he has
more power and he goes on a platform and
he preaches learn the difference between
the good woman and then that woman now
the whole downfall of his platform is
him choosing to deal with women who
weren't really so what if the woman's a
dating coach
so if she's a dating coach and gives
dating advice and then gets graped or is
it on her now because she didn't know
the difference I just I don't really
care if that's what you think I just
hope you have the same energy for women
and that's my point is like women don't
really feel Sympathy For Men I feel
sympathy for women but not men do you
know what the problem is I think that
people nowadays they're just not
selective enough both on the women
silent on the men's side even the men
that have got all these Bugattis and
money and they can have any girl that
they want they are still not selective I
hang out with some people yeah and I go
to some of these places that there's
powerful people that I'm looking at
these men and what they're doing and I'm
disgusted I'm like ew all that power and
all that money for you to just give it
away to any old thing out there that is
right to open her legs but I think he's
selective otherwise you're getting the
problem is men can't be that is I think
think about what I said okay no think
about think about 90 of women have been
at Birth Control at some point in their
life remember the ideal woman if we're
gonna go back to like what men
biologically want is a young virgin in
right 95 percent of women have been on
or 90 of women have been on birth
control 90 um the average partner count
and this is including older women so
it's probably lower when you look at
younger women is between five to eight
men which historically would have been
completely Haram that's a lie
okay this is just what the numbers I
know that's what everyone says when I
say that way one out of three women has
had an abortion one out of three women
have an STD so it's like this is even if
you become a one percent guy they don't
expect virgins because they're not
really there and even if they find one
they don't know if she's telling the
truth yeah but this is not in virginity
selective is in substance the sort of
substance of women
you're looking at Women's you're looking
at Women's standards but like this is
what men value they value Purity they
value youth that's what no no no I'll
tell you this one and they're still
banging big things a big thing a very
top thing that men value above all thing
is sexual Purity we do not want to
imagine the woman we love taking a shot
on the face face or getting dominated by
any other dude or you know being a part
of a gang bang or whatever goes on those
sororities we don't want to deal with
that but it's not our ideal you would do
it to other women that's what is
contradicting to happen though so the
average guy the average guy hold on hold
on the average guy which you girls most
likely ignore doesn't do that
ignore so but then guess what who gets
the coverage is the top G's that can get
anything so most guys want to be like
that baby you want to understand they're
adapting to the market most guys are
young and they start they they start off
really sweet and what they're doing is
they're looking for a young wife that
wants to get married or try to treat her
well and they find out that when they
treat girls well they don't get laid but
we can say the same thing for women I
think the reason why women and listen
the thing is with if women no wrong
wrong wrong no no because you're gonna
say something with women like do the
same thing that's what you said and
that's wrong because if women did the
same thing we would have more to offer
but the average modern woman doesn't
have much to offer two men in terms of
what men value if women did so much they
would stay pure for their husbands we
don't we would know how to cook we don't
I think the average girl buried young we
don't I think they don't they don't have
a concept of like healthy boundaries
that a guy naturally knows like not
talking or keeping communication with
men you've slept with in the past that's
like a big No-No for guys like because
we we know that that dude is just a
predator just sitting around waiting for
his chance to get another taste
I understand that one modern women today
are just like trash basically but
sometimes not all of them not all of
them they are good there are good women
out there yeah there are good women out
there but the mainstream is showing that
women
but I think the problem is historically
none of the like 95 of women would be
disqualified that's that's a crazy when
you think about it like in terms of the
last Thousand Years 95 of women today
would be disqualified do you know what
you said earlier you said how would a
man know which girl to pick if she
hasn't if he is not experienced it goes
the same wave to a woman how would she
know what kind of man is a certain
manner
okay the same way is Mom then and this
is the thing these women women are dumb
oh God
think about it when women are in charge
of her own mate selection so so the last
hundred years what's different is women
are now in charge of mate selection that
has never happened in all of history
it's always been the families and the
fathers so now that women have more
control the most control ever of made
selection what has happened are made
choices are terrible when we have the
most power to choose entertainers
rappers like it's it's it even if it's
not like a worldwide celebrity like so
many women date rappers in their 20s
entertainers in their 20s basketball
players and it's like these men are not
monogamous they're not typically like
the traditional husbands but I feel like
for me personally the problem with these
type of conversations where people say
like women modern women are falling off
and so on and so forth is that they
don't really talk about why women are
falling off women are falling off is
because men fell off men were becoming
weak dads were not in the home no more
men who's kicking the dads out of the
homes
the number two reasons I can't remember
what they were but it was like when that
started to happen which was like the 70s
and 80s Rachel if you're in the town let
me know what they were but it's it's Bae
was like emotional like just not being
happy emotional differences yeah it was
one of the top two women get divorced
for stupid reasons and listen listen
listen so you girls that are you're mad
you girls can all agree that the Modern
Men right now you really don't like them
right
so the panel right here is pretty
unanimously across they don't like what
these guys are depends on the modern man
you're going for because like there's
some good guys out there and then
depends on what you like the kind of
places you go to the kind of people you
mingle with yeah that's the kind of man
you're gonna make if you like hanging on
the hood going clubbers every single
time you're gonna meet a stupid guy no
offense some of them are good
I want to add on to my point real quick
the point I'm trying to say is this
right so you guys are dissatisfied with
the state of the modern man it seems
unanimously the majority of these men
are raised by women
and what motivates me
sex
so if if the quality of men like
decreased maybe it's because the reward
at the end like what does the guy think
about it most guys want a genetic Legacy
right and so let's let's say they find
the good woman to start a family with
they have no guarantee she won't leave
because divorce is legal and so what's
at the end of this for him uh can I just
say something in a virgin get out of
here good luck
um when we think about why men will
leave in the homes and why a lot of
women were left they were kicked let me
just tell you something before women
kick them out there was a lot of
societal problems that actually caused
this to happen there's a lot of
catalysts that are nothing to do with
women if anything is to do with men
there was a cold war which brought
Vietnam War how many men went there to
die there was the the drugs epidemics in
the USA with a lot of crackheads most of
the druggies would be men there's a lot
of things that happen in society that
men meant that men actually started to
fall off and women have no choice but to
then be like you need to during what era
in the 70s then we mentioned the 70s
here as well what percent what percent
of men fell off are you saying a lot of
men there's an epidemic to the person do
you think okay let me think for uh the
war in Vietnam a lot of men went there
and a lot of men died okay so that's
something that's a way that was already
there was all men just want to make the
correction no females were drafted yeah
yeah no understand that same thing with
before that even World War II there was
like already
I'm blaming the fact that there was a
lot of men that were taken out of the
home not kicked out of the Home taken
out of the home and that created a kind
of like a a snowball effect that didn't
cause the situation trust me the
majority of the divorces were from women
the majority of the single parent homes
were from divorce I'm not gonna lie I
would I would divorce my man if he
became a crackhead and treated me like
crapping wasn't getting any help because
at the end of the day this is my
children are a priority propaganda like
it's all in the media in the UK it was
the wind brush period no because
feminism started in the UK so that's not
correct so it was both there was a wave
of propaganda that basically painted out
dads to be abusers deadbeats drug
addicts when that wasn't the majority
like in the majority of the case that
wasn't true it wasn't a significant part
of the population of men and and they
basically like propagated to women that
your only options in a husband or an
idiot an abuser and I can't remember
what the third one is but it's all over
the media it's just not true yeah well
that's the propaganda they're feeding
you because history once you know the
fats you understand that even when men
went to war in World War II the women
had to do the jobs that men were doing
before women had to take up certain
roles in society that they would never
have to think about before not a high
percentage no it was still only during
the go because that's that's wrong and
that that's why okay and we it's a lot
of times this stuff gets repeated and
it's not correct the majority of women
still didn't work even during that era
how many times
so I get it that the women had to work
in the factories how many women stormed
the beach of Normandy
yeah it would have been the men okay and
the whole point is no you helped out in
the world but you didn't risk dying
exactly and
that made the decisions for war and I
keep saying it all the time who makes it
no it wasn't a woman who votes them into
office women no no before that wasn't
women that's when that's after the 20s
that's when women got the um the right
to vote was in the 20s that's when you
see the family start structure start to
degradate and the thing is politicians
cater to women we are the number one
voting block is single women and so so
what happens is the more power women
have the more we voted for politicians
that pushed policies that took the data
out of the home when when women win they
win for themselves no it's true when
women when women win we win for
ourselves when men win everybody wins
because men have like an innate it's
like something innate in them where they
want to protect women
so I agree with denilva when she says
that war is a manned thing but you know
also historically speaking the United
States was dragged into World War II
when the Japanese parole uh when they
bombed Pearl Harbor we had no choice but
to respond because at that time we were
just selling Munich to the Allies we
were really just funding our side of the
war but then we got dragged into it you
know it's like you get sucker punched in
a bar you gotta you're not gonna sit
there and take it because the whole
[__] bar is gonna look you like your
[__] we had to respond to Japan and
then you know we had battle windway
Hiroshima Nagasaki and all that of
course but it all starts again with the
involvement by even just funding or
giving any sort of munition I'm just
saying war is a masculine thing hard
power isn't it was money that we were
involved for money masculine thing can I
just say at the end of the day the women
were voting for those politicians so
were the men no no no no no it's not 50
50 because women make up 55 percent of
the population so it's not 50 50. women
are in at an advantage when it comes to
voting okay but not all of them vote
yeah but more vote then let's not talk
about the immigrants I don't vote no but
more of women vote than men and and even
if you talk like that like I've spoke
you can I've spoken to these politicians
like they'll say um and I've spoken to
politicians in the UK and in the U.S and
they'll both tell you that like women is
who they're catering to to win elections
but they still look mostly means
nowadays how many female presidents have
you had in the USA yeah
thankfully zero yeah thank God I'm just
saying because women women
this is another one no okay actually
this is actually another thing that and
this is the thing we repeat this stuff
and it's just not true like like because
you're saying oh when women get into
Power women have been in power there
have been women in power in the last 500
years and the thing is when women get
into Power they're actually more likely
to wage war than men if you look at it
as a percentage
look at Hillary Clinton
Wikipedia is no good for stats you know
can I just mention one thing because I
know this topic will drag I think for me
the problem that I have with this
conversation about modern women is that
a lot of people especially the red pill
Community they love to say women are
falling off women not this woman on that
but they never talk about why like you
guys act as though women just woke up
one day and decided let me just go
against men
decided to get weaker you don't
acknowledge the fact that men decided to
take um crack you don't acknowledge the
fact that men you know just well
actually fall in love with some places
Force the man you don't acknowledge the
fact that father's Leicester home yes it
was propaganda but who told the men to
actually fall for that propaganda so
that's not me that's what propaganda is
propaganda is to deceive you can I have
a question for you propaganda is
targeted at women it's not targeted at
men because women are more swayed by
Propaganda than men by and I have a
question for the both of you so this
whole fall of the modern women are full
of women in general do you genuinely
feel like it's just because women woke
up one day and decided let me go against
men no or do you feel like a men have a
positively no and if they do when are we
going to start speaking I think I think
when women I think when women get
everything they don't treat men well I
think because when women got more power
and more influence they did not treat
men well and they would rather be on
their own than be with a guy that they
don't deem as quality men really treat
women that great before
that it comes from somewhere no what do
you say that again men never really
treated women that well I mean again
that's propaganda like this whole idea
that like women were horrible like you
can read right like I've read writings
from wives at the time you know 95 of
women like they they were
they didn't even want the right to vote
at the time 95 were against it yeah
because these women would talk about it
they would say that it's because we like
we want to submit to our husband like to
become one in marriage like it wasn't
like these women were so unhappy in
marriage let me just clarify something
about the red Bill Community too so the
majority of the men that are in the red
kill Community I'm a leader as well
right we hold men to a way higher
extreme and you you see the highlight
reels of people like Myron Gaines and
stuff yelling at like oh is it one
o'clock in the morning in Miami but the
majority of the content creators we are
not just sitting there trying to
demonize women we are actually holding
men to an extreme if you if you watch my
show I do a free consultation Friday
show listen to these calls that I call
that I talk to these men I hold these
guys to a high level of accountability
because the modern man is also a loser
the Modern Woman is also we are all in
this giant Cesspool of loser dumb and
everybody needs to get their [__] act
together oh I like that I have one
question for Paul you said that 95 of
women didn't want to vote if nine sorry
if 95 of women didn't want to vote how
did 55 of women make up the vote no no
55 of women today oh today back then the
majority of women did not write them and
just so you know didn't want to vote how
are women the cause of why there was War
and why there was political issues no I
said when women get power that's what
they vote for yeah so the reason the
reason that women got the right to vote
at least in the US actually don't know
the exact like reason here but in the US
it was actually um the deciding vote was
a guy um you know it's funny he voted
he's like the original simp because he
voted for women to get the vote because
his mom told him to no
his mom I don't remember his name but
his mom was an anti-suffragette so she
was oh no she was a suffragette yeah
yeah and so she like told him to do it
and he wasn't going to in his writings
then he decided to because his mom told
him that's not what they teach you in
school so just my question so they don't
it's it's very much I just finished uni
and we've learned all about this this is
news to me as well I studied the
software jet school history and they
didn't talk about that but going back to
your question if only five percent of
the women voted how come one
how come women are now the course to why
there's political issues and the family
structure and everything I mean you
could you could argue that it's like the
issue is that like men like shouldn't
have given women that power I mean you
could argue that but I'm saying like
when women got power that's what they
voted for so once we both got power like
this is what women voted for but in uni
we learned that women's votes back in
the day weren't the real votes they got
forced to put their votes up that made
sense the votes that they put out
weren't their choices or their husbands
choices yeah so because technically
that's not really fast no but think
about it it's because these are
Christian nations and so like this is
another thing like the and this it goes
back to the the feminists will always
argue and this is the problem is they
put a lot of like a lot of the people
that fund these schools like they're
they're just feminists so they're like
these feminist organizations that pump
money into the schools so basically like
conspiracy theory and one of the no you
can look it up you can look up who like
look up the donors for your school and
um the issue was what they would do is
they there's this narrative that like
women their opinions aren't their real
opinions because they were married and
so like then it's like we can't even
decide what's true because you don't
even believe what they're saying and the
big reason that all that I'm sorry but
sorry I'm just gonna say one more thing
and the reason was because remember
these are Christian nations and they
believe two becomes one flesh in
marriage and that like it's a patriarchy
so we submit to the man so if that's
submitted to the man when it comes to
vote would you now like admit that maybe
this whole downfall of the family is the
man's um problem because like you said
the women took their vote from what
their men told them to vote or their
husbands told them to vote so what you
mentioned about that I said I said it
was because women I said because men had
um like back then yes because like men
voted for them to get the right to vote
but now it's like women vote for
themselves it's not based on the man but
isn't that because of men giving them
the right to vote back in the day like
you mentioned right
you could well you could argue it either
way right it's like if men voted for if
if men made up the majority of the vote
and they voted for us to like something
very immoral for us I don't think they
would say well you know the top men
they're to blame I I just want to I want
a clarification so you you believe that
men are the ones that are tearing apart
the family unit I think that if you are
the head of something me personally I'm
a Christian I feel like I'm going to put
men in on Earth to be in charge and if
the like this girl and if um you know
the world is falling apart is because
the the structure like the top of the
pyramid isn't you know playing its part
isn't strong enough not even the top the
bottom because men are supposed to be
the foundation right so my thing is the
reason why I'm questioning you guys is
I'm challenging you guys to kind of
understand like and see that maybe Men
played a part in this role because
sometimes the conversation can seem so
like this is why I always say the red
pill communities almost like the the
female version
male feminist male feminist because it's
like you guys are almost like don't care
to see the other side and don't care to
see that maybe men did play a role
because men were the ones who were
telling their women what to vote or men
did actually decide you know what let's
give women the vote everything is always
just women woke up one day and just
decided let's go against a man and
that's it a man didn't play a role men
his inability to be masculine to be
strong to you know always falling into
propaganda not reading their Bibles not
taking their faith seriously that didn't
play well do you know who took care do
you know who took prayer out of church
in America who it was a woman really she
was the one complaining that prayer
should be taken out of churches in
America oh wow so people don't pray in
American churches yeah so but okay let
me add because here's my perspective on
things when it comes to I don't think
that men are sitting around
um trying to uh just blame everything on
women but I will say this if you look at
every great feminist movement and you
track back who's funding it and what's
the real cause of it it's usually always
down to money or votes they're usually
pandering for one of those two things
and the thing is this too
um when you talk about looking back at
the feminist movement history like that
it was never about empowering women
financially it was never about uh you
know women were so oppressed what it
really was about was dividing men and
women and then honestly if you look at
everything it's really set up to
financially extort women if you took up
all of the student loan debt in America
that women owed owed right they they own
all that if you sold all the Bitcoin and
all the ethereum in the world right now
it still wouldn't cover that balance
okay there's a lot of student room debt
and if you look at the decisions women
are making when it comes to college
education women are the ones lining up
getting the most worthless degrees and
having hundreds of thousands of dollars
in debt so you have this entire machine
that is geared towards financially
extorting women and lying to them and
saying you're going to be more happy
with a Birkin bag you're going to be
more happy with Chanel glasses you're
going to be more happy with all this
consumerism being a mother is a
oppressive being a good wife and having
a man taking care of you that is going
to be a detriment to you and a lot of
these women go through the 20s they're
like got their degree they do all the
[__] that the society tells them they
should do right and then they're like 30
and they're like [__] I'm lonely and I
have a stressful job and I have a
hundred thousand dollars in debt and
they're waking up to this now and that's
what the whole thing about is all about
money it's not like a conspiracy theory
the reptiles the the Jews the [__]
Flying Spaghetti Monster whatever it's
all about money that's all it is all
about and women unfortunately have taken
the bait hook line and singer because
are you guys familiar with the company
Old Spice
[Music]
Pearl knows okay so Old Spice used to be
like this dirty old beige bottle that
your grandfather kept and like put it on
himself before he went drinking with the
boys right and Old Spice was crashing in
value and what they did Old Spice
realized that the majority of consumer
products were purchased by women in the
household goods body wash and whatnot so
they changed their marketing from
targeting men
to targeting women and they made a
gigantic turnaround with the entire
company Terry Crews used to do the
commercials these have like these
outrageous commercials about Old Spice
completely saved the brand why because
they turned around and targeted females
other companies saw that you know look
most people they're not original if they
see something working they're going to
copy it right and so all these companies
they started switching everything around
and just taking the shortcut and
targeting women for the consumer base
Why They Don't Care About Women they
want to [__] take money from you
that's another thing that's why you have
this whole body positivity movement with
the body positivity movement is is just
telling you over consume when you over
consume you get fat that's your body
saying like you're taking in too much
like we have enough calories to operate
the system now we're storing excess fat
this body positivity movement is just
another way to tell women like yeah get
300 pounds get 400 pounds why because
they want you to keep consuming keep
consuming keep consuming it's all about
money that's it and the question is is
it on the women for getting fat or is it
like on the men for for telling them
that well how many guys and you have six
different things
but the difference but the difference is
women are bailed out and and they have a
whole movement to support their fatness
where men are just men just get money
not really they're just what do you they
get money for what they just get money
money equals ghosts men get billed out
by having some cash in a little nice you
know the numbers just don't line up it's
like 10 percent of men I think it goes
both ways though it's like women value a
lot of more things like the kind of
things women value are different from
what men value women care about like
Beauty they care about like um lesser
Beauty the way they look surgeries and
that men don't care about that so women
put a lot of effort in doing that
because it makes them happy not makes
them stupid because they want to do it
it's just like let's say if a woman was
selling something that a man wants let's
say someone has like uh some woman is a
pimp or something yeah and then she has
like loads of girls men would actually
come to that so that you know what I
mean like men would um definitely
patronize that person more than a woman
would you like do you get my point it's
like it's different business lines so
don't be saying that only women are
patronized women are being told what to
do they're just stupid they're doing no
because that's what they're values
we're more evenly you easily influenced
and the thing is do we take it okay
we're either equals or we're not equal I
think so so I'm saying if women if women
the premise of feminism is that women
are equals and if we think that we're
equals then we got to take
accountability for what we vote for and
what we choose but we never do that we
still find a way to blame the men and
whenever you say hey be accountable for
your choices is and even this question
is it on the woman for getting fat or
the men telling her the marketing to her
to get fat it's like we'll still say
well it's on both well no we're either
equals and we're adults or we're not
yeah because then it's like how can you
be superior to me as a man you're like
okay I'm woman I'm better than you but I
don't know how to regulate my body
weight and understand when someone's
[__] manipulating me like well you
got to find a balance yeah and I think
too like women just are more like they
enjoy shopping and they enjoy blowing
money they do like a guy listen how many
how many of you guys have gone to a
guy's house and you've seen like a sofa
a mattress and a TV and you're like how
the [__] does this guy live like this
you know what I was thinking about that
show them women are making 80 of
consumer buying decisions that women are
leading the house
because it's like the women are making
all the financial decisions in the house
women love shopping can I say something
then women love shopping may I just say
then oh my God the poor modern man like
I said early he's a [__] what and he's
a [__] because he's raised by one no
he's a [__] because he's just one
because not every single mother
at least this man he coaches like the
like I would right you coach Matt I run
yeah right I coached thousands of men so
he he knows more than you do about like
what like type of homes these men come
from okay that's fantastic but a lot of
the one that deals with men on a more
personal level because I'm a woman and I
know how most of these modern men act
and can I just say more than what he
will know because they don't try to chat
him up so listen I've talked listen
you're wrong with all due respect my
love tell me okay I talked to thousands
of men for thou tens of thousands of
hours and I understand intimately what
the problem is and a lot of things this
too one thing a lot of these single moms
do is they will guilt trip and turn
these Sons into like a de facto husband
where the sun is now helping paying the
rent the sun is like helping like he
becomes they're like husband placement
holder that happens a lot if you watch
that movie The Joker right there's a
scene at the end when he when he kills
his mother and a lot of these guys for
the Intel community and stuff like you
know I wish like that's what that's how
I feel my mom was oppressing me and
stuff like that so I mean when you're
just trying to say that this is entirely
man's fault you're wrong and it's also
wrong when we say it's entirely women's
fault because listen because because
it's the truth because here's the thing
if women want all the rights and
responsibilities that men have they also
must have the accountability that comes
with the responsibility because you
cannot have responsibility without
accountability and that's why I love
exactly what you said because you
acknowledge the fact that it's both of
our faults rather than just being the
typical red pill who just says is
women's full is women's full and another
thing I wanted to mention is that
something out though whenever we bring
up a problem about women the gut
reaction is always to say [__] when
we always are talking about men and men
no but I'm saying but we have so many
conversations there's been 50 years of
media talking about men's issues I don't
want no scrub and you know the you know
yeah
like many [__] is normal like we have so
many and you don't see the men come in
and
there's a shift too you got okay you
didn't know what you're you're like in
your 30s how old are you 30. yeah so you
remember this you remember the song I
forgot who's saying it but she would say
the boy is mine yeah remember that now
you have yourself like I don't need no
man [__] this guy you know
what as well hold on I do agree men's
songs have gone sempier do you know why
I get uh no no no no Drake has changed
even Drake is thinking he's a gangster
serenade
I don't know hotline bling that's the
same song
no Drake is a simp I'm not gonna lie
there you go there we go not all
um music nowadays is but made by Sims a
lot of these men what's that song like
won't you stay with that guy would get
taken to an alley in the 80s now what is
he singing back in the day
I avoid that [__] like the playing I
don't know
need women's with their songs easy thing
outside used to like it's raining
they're singing But the difference is
women used to be worth serenading
no that's a Debbie
I'm probably a pearl they don't read you
in their songs they just have like you
half naked and they say that you're
basically worthless you're just you're
good for one night but who's dressing
half naked
no but there's less
just question and I need raise your hand
are there more [__] today than there
were 50 years ago raise your hand if you
think yeah everything's different no no
no yes okay come on thank you yeah so so
is it is it really like can we blame
them for treating us like [__] when
there are more [__] to treat them like
can I say something effort let me look
this is the problem I have right if a
dog constantly tells his daughter you're
a whole you're a [__] you're a [__]
you're ugly you're ugly you're ugly
guess what's gonna happen she's gonna
continue to think that for sure it's the
same thing with these rappers when they
continue to call women hoes hoes hoes
bbbs tricks tricks tricks women are
gonna actually start to believe that
this is what they like or this is what
they want and this is what I mean by
this this lack of acknowledgment when it
comes to whether men are going wrong in
this type of conversation but we
acknowledge it all the time in media and
music like it even in general
conversation like it's okay he knocked
her up who's the accountability on him
and we have so many phrases that just
like literally absolve women of any
accountability and so it's like whenever
men have a movement like women feel the
need to police how they speak about
women but well I feel like sorry can I
just quickly say something what I feel
like is what's because I used to really
be this like red pill type of thing but
now that I'm looking deep into it what
I'm scared of is that Society is going
to turn into what the feminist movement
is turning into which is just putting
the blame on women women the way we used
to put the blame on men men men when are
we just going to stop pause and try to
find like a middle ground between each
other because I genuinely feel like this
is what is turning into you know there's
no middle ground with the way the laws
are if the idea is hey let's come to a
compromise and get married I think most
men are for that but the problem is
women have voted for these systems that
actively oppress men and we can see it
with the Tate interview because top one
percent guy that can afford the best
lawyers in the world is in a prison
because the women metooed him and so so
the difference is I'll tell you the
difference the difference men have no
power right now yeah I will I will push
back on that and it is in the Romanian
justice system which is Romania's
notoriously corrupt so like I do but I
understand what you're saying but at the
same time like you know there is
objective truth in the sense that
when it comes to
divorce and breaking up the families
78 of the women are doing this and so
let's just theoretically say
the men
are at fault for the divorces
why aren't women better at choosing good
guys
teach them how to who kicked the father
out the home they did women a woman is
not just going to decide I don't want a
husband the husband has to do something
and that's the part of the conversation
that no one is acknowledging that's kind
of annoying like a woman's not just
gonna decide I'm gonna kick you out the
man has to be being very useless for him
so then why is she choosing a bad guy
because maybe she didn't even have a dad
because her dad wasn't even in the home
to teach a house
okay okay cool cool cool so who kicked
her dad out of the house can I tell you
you kicked himself can I have something
can I add something can I add something
because we keep talking I I whenever we
have these conversations I can argue for
both men and women very easily but if
we're going to learn anything from
Andrew Tate and one of the things that
he does say that I stand for the most
and I'm like yeah you know what you're G
for seeing this it's the Matrix right
and the Matrix is we that day is just
like a figurative term to explain the
people that are running this whole thing
the whole machine that actually
influences the whole world on every
level from media to energy Industries to
politics to everything and those people
at the top are men the world is actually
run by men as much as we're trying to
run away from that that is the fact that
women have a lot of power in a man's
world because we have the sexuality side
of things but it's mental in this
machine I agree with you and they use
women as a tool in my opinion because
they know that dumb women they we know
that women can be easily Pro like
populated yeah and manipulated because
we agreed so okay so and so it goes back
to the point of saying man them but
start getting smarter since we are
supposed to be the weaker beings that
percentage of men are are like what
percentage of men are making those
decisions versus women being manipulated
it's funny I say manipulated like the
women don't choose this like well it's
like in our language right women be
manipulated
like if we're gonna go it's men versus
women I agree with you it is a small
percentage of men running things and
they use women as a tool but I'm saying
more women are being used as a tool than
men running things
very very small percentage of men that's
like less than one percent you're
correct but yeah yeah so I agree with
her no but the bottom line is this and
this is men and women both need to get
their heads out of their asses and
realize that the elites are doing this
to tear us apart and rather than put us
together and guess what that's why
there's like 76 genders in America you
know why oh more people to [__] hate
each other oh you're a Caesar well I
mean he him I hate those [__] Caesars
don't you hate them that's all it is
it's all it's all listen get blacks and
whites to hate each other get Asians and
Latinos at each other get Indians to
[__] hate people who don't own
7-Elevens whatever the [__] case is
they're trying and succeeding in divide
and conquer okay we do have to start the
video though how long have we been going
is that an hour yeah no I was like all
right I'm so sorry guys that was hot
that was hot though before you're
finished can I add something just like
you saying that the women are being
manipulated just to put a question out
there it's like you saying the undertale
invited his women he then he's like he's
manipulating them how about sorry how
about you say the women the money
playing him because if I see let's just
say Drake comes to me today and say he
wants to speak to me which I'm know
might not happen why would you think
maybe if I don't like Drake I'll
probably I might actually just say yes
I'll go with him because I want his
money that's me money playing his money
played me are you saying that I'm not
making money we're both manipulating
each other so don't make it look like
the woman is the one who's stupid why
can't the man be stupid because I'm the
trade obviously he's got in trouble
right now and he's been like the stupid
one right now no offense so you say it's
like the women [__] him up like I came
over do you know what I mean it's just
how it is like we both manipulate each
other we both get what we want so it
doesn't have to be like women women all
the time men for falling for you you're
also like stupid and The Pimps made the
decisions
no that's a great point Sorry it goes
that way no that's a great point and the
women are manipulating the men on camera
like the women that's what they have to
do as cam girls you get men to send you
money and they're usually lonely men but
I really need to start this video so
we're gonna we're gonna start it um
we're gonna try to do like five ten
minutes at a time and then I'll pause
everyone can give their thoughts
um guys if you get to a thousand likes
in the chat blessing will open it up for
a certain amount of time what what super
chats are we reading over how many
dollars blessing
uh 20. okay
um go ahead we'll do it
um in like 20 minutes we'll read supers
okay go ahead
you know
before you watch this exclusive
interview with Andrew Tate there are a
few things you need to know Andrew is
taking a massive risk agreeing to do
this 5 hour and 20 minute interview
because he is still under house arrest
and under investigation which means
anything he says can and will be held
against him now what did we talk about
in this interview we talked about his
experience in jail with Tristan untold
stories religion how this impacted his
life how emotional was it was he scared
you're going to see a side of him you've
never seen before we definitely talked
about BBC BBC is not going to like this
interview for many reasons you'll see
why it's a total of 15 hours that we
spend with Andrew and Tristan at his
compound so a lot was covered having
said that there's about 45 minutes of
this interview that will be censored due
to the topic of discussion being around
his investigation and Romania so if you
want to see that 45 minute portion you
will need to text the word Tate to 3
10340-1132 or click on a link below to
subscribe to an email for that to be
sent to you after his investigation or
indictment is public having said that
brace for impact you're about to be
valuetamed by the one and only Andrew
Tate I'm winning too well I'm scared by
the incompetence where's that guy from
[Music]
if this guy is so innocent how can they
get you to go to the dungeon for 92 days
how can they put you on house arrest how
can they do all this stuff
[Music]
they could do this to you
to anyone they do to you or you or me or
any man watching this any man watching
this I wake up instinctually at 5am
because that's when they read your house
I wake up at like 4 59 I just [__]
shoot up empires have fallen so many
times
because they thought they can get away
with murder and then eventually people
said listen stop you're not gonna do
this to me anymore we're not We're Not
Gonna Take a sense
when I destroyed the BBC my brother was
celebrating I knew
you know you don't beat the British
Broadcasting Corporation to make fools
of them like this without some new
[__] this is where their argument
has leaks in it
I'm genuinely looking for guidance here
am I supposed to roll over and [__]
lose
you sincerely don't know I sincerely
have decided that the best thing I can
do is stay true to my faith and stay
true to God and tell the truth and fight
foreign
since the last time we sat down with
Andrew Tate last time we sat down with
him you were the most Google man on
Earth today effective last two days you
are now the most Googled woman on earth
correct according to your Twitter
profile correct and uh we wanted to make
sure after the BBC interview you made
certain requests you said you want
moving forward there to be a fifty
thousand dollar fee when people sit down
to do an interview so we wanted to make
sure the ESG score for this interview
would be very high we got you 50 000
Target gift card I appreciate it very
much people in America will appreciate
that and then you also said cookies so
Adam got you something amazing to make
sure we match that and then dear brother
as well we did bring a Bud Light but
unfortunately Vinnie finished it on the
way here Vinnie
[Music]
yeah so we respect that so but anyways
look A lot's obviously changed from last
time to this time last time we sat down
was around nine months ago yeah
you had at the time been de-platformed
from every social media platform we came
out here we sat down we spoke The Matrix
was attacking you you were saying Matrix
attacking me Matrix attacking me from
then on a musk buys Twitter in October
he then reinstates you in one day I
believe you get a million followers on
Twitter you're upwards of a seven
million today every other account's
taken down I think even Tristan was
taken down off of Instagram uh and then
you know the arrest comes the lover boy
all these articles and vice releases the
hit piece uh on you guys you know
they're saying what they're saying and
I'm sure we're going to get some
comments on that the initial 30-day
lockup was extended twice 92 days in the
dungeon uh we had a chance to speak with
one of your lawyers Tina uh glandian on
February 24th was a great conversation
we had with her then eventually you're
released you and your brother come out
and you specifically make it clear that
you did 7417 push-ups correct very
impressive you receive letter from
thousands of fans you read the Quran on
a daily basis at no point was any
charges uh anything official charge it
was all allegedly allegedly allegedly
yeah and while you were away a new star
was born Dylan Mulvaney which I'm sure
you're familiar with from there on a lot
of comments were made uh comments of
people that supported your comments of
people that didn't support you Logan
Paul said by 2023 he will not have a
sliver of relevance is what he said KSI
said Andrew Tate snitched on himself
after getting ratioed by Greta thonberg
Destiny said Andrew Tate has been
arrested for rape charges in a country
he specifically lives in to avoid rape
charges because he was beefing with a
autistic child on the internet I think
he's referencing the great brother Matt
Bernstein advocated to get you kicked
off of Instagram and he's part of the
blue pill Community a big famous makeup
artist Ethan Klein said that and that's
why I call him Andrew the human
trafficker he sent me a season this is
threatened to sue me for defamation for
saying he's a human trafficker what else
am I supposed to call someone that buys
and sells human beings after their will
take the human trafficker NBC in January
2023 said Andrew Tate said he broke a
woman's jaw and that his business was a
scam ahead of Romanian charges Rolling
Stone said meet Andrew Tate ex-kickboxer
red killing the angry young men of
America these are people that didn't
support you now these are the people
that supported you talk across and he
comes out and he says on full send
podcast first of all he's really smart
the spirit that animates Andrew Tate is
very clear and very obvious and it's not
a malicious Spirit at all Andrew Tate's
core messages respect for yourself act
like you're worth something achieve
something do something get the [__] off
the couch put down the porn go do
something with your life that's the
greatest message that anyone could give
it tells you everything about the people
in charge who say who say that's
threatening what is that threatening the
same people who live on the keto island
with Epstein and the same people that
were friends with Harvey Weinstein were
claiming to protect women by rebuking
Tate that's Taco Carlson Pierce Morgan
who originally when he went on it was
very combative correct it was a very
good interview entertaining but I was it
was also interesting to see him trying
to push you and then he flips and he
says this is getting ridiculous Romanian
authorities must either charge him and
his brother if they have actual evidence
of crimes or release them musk obviously
supported by releasing restoring your
account like this Jake Shields said
people are freaking out about young boys
looking up to Andrew Tate but totally
fine with young girls looking up to
cardi B and the Kardashians and
obviously Aiden Ross Red Bull Community
Joe Rogan I can go on and on and on
about a lot of things that's being said
we watched the BBC interview
and we'll talk about BBC here in a
minute because I have some questions on
that as well but the first thing I want
to ask you is you know nine months where
we were at then September to where we
are today A lot's changed how do you
feel whatever everything that's going on
and tell us a little bit about your
current state today yeah there's a very
strange sense of Terror that comes from
knowing exactly what's going to happen
to you there's a strange sense of calm
that comes from it also but in the
middle of the night when you can't sleep
sometimes you feel happy knowing what
they're trying to do to you and
sometimes you feel terrified knowing
what they're trying to do to you I think
I'm very happy every single podcast I
did previous to this I hammered the
point home and I made it very clear that
they had the intention of trying to put
me in jail I said there's three lives
they try and cancel you and slander you
and destroy your name they don't just
want you to disappear from the internet
they want to disappear from the internet
in a cloud of Shame they have to shame
you which is why they chose the crimes
they did for me and it's why they
usually choose the crimes they choose
because it's heinous they want to shame
you and they want you to Disappear With
Your Head facing the ground and never
pop up again obviously they attempted to
cancel me I became more famous than ever
before I even said to you on your
podcast and I said on other podcasts I
said I think they made a mistake I think
when you have power and you overuse it
you what happens is a rebellion that's
how a revolution starts when you have
power you have to be very very careful
with how you use that power the second
you overuse it there's a revolution
right and we're in Romania so they know
all about that that's exactly what
happens and I I said at the time I think
I was a mistake I think they made a big
mistake canceling me the way they did
and then the second time the second life
which I described as they try and put
you in jail for no reason here we are in
the current scenario I knew it was going
to happen and the third one is they put
a bullet in your head so we're gonna
have to see how the second life plays
out and yeah I mean when this is all
over and I win the court case I get the
not guilty I won't be smiling I'll be
walking out the courtroom with my head
on this level
that's the kind of life I'm living now
I'm gonna be thinking oh okay so their
second attempt failed now what like do I
want to fly private anymore
do I want to go that place anymore you
start to think about these things like
do I want to do these things law
billionaires dying in plane crashes is
strange
so
it's scary regardless of how it plays
out and I guess you just have to go with
the punches and and see where it lands
and God has a plan for for me and for
all of us and we're just going to see
how it ends up full disclosure you don't
have any Suicidal Thoughts I want to
make it very clear and I make it clear
on absolutely every single podcast I
would never kill myself I don't care
what they say I don't care what video
they show you never under any
circumstance would I kill myself it's
Haram never I don't care if they put me
in back in the dungeon solitary
confinement by myself for the rest of my
human years I would never kill myself
ever ever so if that ever happens God
forbid do not believe whatever garbage
they tell you the chances of me killing
myself is precisely zero and you had
this complete level of certainty that
this is exactly how it would play out
you've said this on um Team podcast that
this is what how this is their this is
their agenda they have to damage my
influence they have to damage my
influence they can't sit there and let
me be influential because I'm saying
things that they don't like me saying
and there are people sitting around
going he's saying things counter to our
message and counter to our narrative get
rid of it and they have a pretty
standard a nice Playbook and this is
probably one of the first times in
history with our Playbook just isn't
working cancel it we're still around oh
well I'm in the news to say he touches
chicks well No One Believes it oh all
the comments are on his side everyone's
calling us Liars okay then do it again
then do it again make up a new girl then
do it again find someone else and they
keep attacking me with the same weapons
but the bullets are bouncing off and
that doesn't give me a sense of calm
that doesn't make me think hahaha I'm
Invincible it makes me think oh it makes
me think oh because human life is cheap
at the top it's very cheap does it make
you want to sit on the sidelines and be
quiet and just kind of live a life with
your family your kids does it make you
want to do that maybe maybe all these
attention is actually not a good thing
it's interesting because sometimes I
analyze myself and think why don't I
just do that why don't I just disappear
you know I don't need money I don't need
vain why don't I just disappear and then
you have to I was saying this to my
brother
and he was like well Genghis Khan didn't
need Vienna some people are just wired
that way like Vienna's a long way from
Kathmandu
and sometimes it's just uh the way it is
I apologize to capital of Mongolia
that's just the way some people are if I
see Injustice and if I see things which
I believe to be false I feel like I am
obligated to say the truth I can't
explain why even at my own detriment
what am I doing this for like it's it's
to the detriment of my life and I've had
these conversations at length of the
people close to me and and we're all
saying the same thing it's always been
the same way Humanity has always been
the same way there's been a select fault
small Few Good Men up against evil and
evil always outnumbers you evil always
has more money than you they always have
more power and more influence than you
if you look at if you play any video
game when you get to the end boss he
always has more life than you he always
has more hit points but you're the good
guy and it's kind of like it's it's
never been any different at any point in
human history there's been the good guys
up against the forces of evil whatever
they were of the time and you've always
been outnumbered and you've always been
supposed to lose so you consider
yourself the good guy in this situation
I think that truth is instilled by God
in all of us and I think if you tell the
truth you're a good person so who do you
think is the bad guy you know everyone
uses they them them they're after me
who's they who's the bad guy well
instead of saying who I will say what I
will start by saying is what they do and
what they do is they control information
and we now live in Information Society
and by controlling information they
control how people think and act and
react to things that's all they have to
do they have to control information and
they have to be very selective with what
they allow you to talk about what they
allow you to discuss and what they don't
and once they can do that they can keep
you bickering about garbage and they can
control the sensitive information and
then they run the world so
having all the information controlled
and having this hard barrier on what can
be discussed
that's how they can purport absolute
fallacies I think now it's been a couple
years we can probably talk about it they
psiopt the world into believing they
should be afraid of the common cold they
sign up the world into this
and if you think about how difficult
that would be to do how difficult would
it be to sign off the entire population
of Earth well what you do is you just
lie on repeat and you don't allow anyone
to say anything counter to it without
hurting them the same way I've been hurt
and you just sigh up on them it's
actually amazing because now I use that
exact same psyop on people I love it I
love it so when I sit with someone who's
not matrix-minded when I sit with
someone who is Matrix mine they're going
to BBC walked in here I'm like do you
all have your vaccinations
this is actually 100 social distancing
please and they look at me like I'm
crazy how am I crazy two years ago you
were telling me to do this now when I
repeat your own worldview to you I'm
crazy well if I'm crazy guess what
you're a [__] liar because you lied
the whole time so either you're a liar
or I'm not you know how could I be nuts
put your [__] mask on if I ever talk
to any of these clowns again they're
going to be fully masked up and I refuse
I don't care if you've had two Brewster
Jabs no I want all six all six
injections I want paperwork or gifts
I'm scared of covet it's dangerous I
believe the mainstream media I'm scared
this word you keep using psyop I've
never heard that's what it's short for
psychological operations correct break
that down what exactly is a sign up yeah
a psyop is is the Matrix as a whole wow
it's like psychological psychological
operations are constant they constantly
decide how they want you to think and
what they can do to make you believe
that right there's a whole bunch of them
they do but it starts with tolerance
that's what I don't like about this
whole guise of Tolerance it's not that
I'm an intolerant person it's not I'm a
bad person it's not that I want to hurt
other people but when they keep pushing
tolerance what they're trying to say is
have no standards or barriers or
parameters for anything that's what they
want you have to be tolerant tolerant of
what tolerant of having your shop set on
fire tolerant of your kids being taught
things you don't want tolerant of crime
tolerant of your house being broken the
tolerant of one you're not allowed any
hard barrier any hard parameters as a
man anymore that's why they push
tolerance that's the beginning of it
that's the first stage once you accept
absolute tolerance well then it's the
end isn't it I'm tolerant of everything
I'll eat the bugs tolerate everything
I'll tolerate everything I'm tolerant
sure so when I say things like I'm
intolerant certain things and people
think that's bad no you need to have
standards and parameters and that's one
of the reasons they also attacked me I
say that men should be allowed to have
standards and parameters in a
relationship and in their lives we
should be allowed to decide who we just
want to marry and we should have
standards for her they have standards
for us we should allow ourselves to have
standards for her we should have
standards in what we'll accept from a
government and standards and what we'll
accept from a police force we should
have standards as men but they're trying
to erode all of that because once that's
gone then your brain is completely empty
and then once your brain's empty they
can just plug in the slave program and
then then it's over right you're tall
you're a tolerant person you're a
tolerant person good you're a good slave
slaves are exceptionally tolerant so the
shirt you wear is what escaped the slave
mind resist the slave resist the slave
Minds exactly it's a better word resist
resist but I want to do this before we
get into because we got we got five
hours ago we got plenty of time to get
into a lot of different topics so one I
do want to talk about BBC uh the
handling of the interview I want to get
your thoughts on it I know there's been
reactions but I want to go a little bit
deeper into it because I want to compare
how your start with the interview with
BBC starter versus Phillip Schofield
which was versus musk I got all the
first questions we'll cover that I want
to talk about media I want to talk about
your evolution of your faith atheist
Christian Muslim and then some of the
things that's going on with politics
right now you know maybe a little bit of
Romania you know Trump will cover what
you're talking about with different
things it's funny you're saying uh
Monopoly on power Monopoly on power if
you abuse it now YouTube's turning
around and saying hey you can talk about
the election we're no longer going to
give the strike so that doesn't work
forever first thing I want to talk about
I think the audience would like to know
for you and Tristan 92 days in the
dungeon you know you're in jail your
your experience in there we keep hearing
about it we read about it but what was
it like for you guys being in there so
I'll start by saying and I have to make
this clear that the staff in the jail
were except really nice to me
um
they were very apologetic the vibe was
apologetic nobody was really treating me
like a criminal there were a few guys
who were icy cold I guess you could call
them they'd like to think of themselves
as professional but they were just
inhuman
but over time they warmed up and I was
exceptionally nice also to all the staff
jail was terrible I'm going to start by
saying jail was terrible and I was
miserable inside of the jail cell it's a
good thing depression isn't real because
I would have been depressed but
I think in life that you get what you
give and I want to feel happier so I
tried my very best to make people happy
so when the old lady would bring me my
food I would sit and say oh this is the
best food I've ever had I've never had
food disco did you cook this I thought
yesterday was the best but you managed
to surpass it again how'd you do it
what's the magic ingredient and I ended
up making friends with them like I had
grandmas in there the old ladies cooking
the food and by trying to make people
happy and smile all the time I start to
feel a lot happier
but it's kind of scary and I think the
scariest thing about jail was the
uncertainty of it all they would have
said to me you're in jail for 92 days or
even five years you've got five years
cool I do my time but when you're nabbed
and thrown in a Cell without charge
you're like how long is this my life is
this it now is this the end of the story
I'm just in this cell and I was picked
up on 29th of December
I went through this quick court case
like I said I'm inside of the
jurisdiction of Romania so to be very
careful with what I say because the case
is ongoing and we're in Romania and I
can't leave Romania but obviously
Romanian court is in Romanian by law so
you're marched into this room everyone
speaks a language you don't understand
for 15 minutes and then you're marched
off to jail look what even happened what
what even happened to me and they said
oh here's the paper that explains this
like that's in Romanian
and they said oh don't worry you'll get
a translation to English by law I was
like okay that's fine but because I was
picked up on the 29th of December and
there's New Year's Eve and holidays that
it was two weeks before I even knew why
I wasn't
because I'm in jail I no one told me how
crazy it is it that he was in jail for
two weeks without even knowing what he
was in jail for can you imagine if that
was you I think that's immoral yeah it's
excellent it's terrible it's very
immoral but a lot of countries like that
like dude if you ever if you want to see
like a really terrifying situation
Google what the Japanese police do in
Immigration detention centers it is
terrifying
they just torture you
no really like there was this one
African guy he was resisting arrest or
whatever so he was resisting but they
were just like torturing this guy like a
lot as much as like a lot of people give
you know the Western World a lot of [__]
um at least our justice system is not
nearly as corrupt as a lot of these
other places you know in Japan you know
what the conviction rate is for
criminals or for crime in general in
Japan is do you know it is right take a
guess percentage-wise uh 80
99.9 no
99.9 to the extent that they will
incriminate people and they will bully
people who are even innocent
to
take the crime upon themselves
wow a lot of these other countries are
really barbaric with their things and no
this is no no disrespect to J Madden but
like there's footage out there like how
they're like like torture people and
these immigration centers one one I
believe she's I forget where they were
but one woman was just detained to the
point that she died in the Detention
Center and they asked the Japanese
government like what's the deal you're
like what sorry
as well do you know the story of the
young guy that went to North Korea oh
yeah North Korea
because from ripping like a poster or
something
when I saw him like like crying when he
got oh that was so sad and he actually
died as well got him to the UK I would
sorry the U.S it was like already dead
and it just makes you wonder like if
Andrew Tate had to wait two weeks
imagine that Average Joe like what he
has to encounter and that's the thing
that's like that's what we're trying to
say like when we're talking about these
rights and stuff like you know these
people that are pro-censorship that are
pro these sensorious manners that are
like you know they they're just like
they're pro-banning people they're Pro
all these things eventually the more
power you hand over to the authorities
eventually that power will be used on
you it's only a matter of time you know
it's up to us to keep like a balanced
perspective on things I have a question
for the both of you do you actually
think that Angie T has a chance winning
against the Matrix and be honest
and what do you mean when you when you
say winning against the Matrix what do
you mean like the entire global system
so basically like Andrew Tate said like
the last option is a bullet in his head
do you think that he can somehow Escape
that yes of course he can the same way
that there's been Revolutions in the
world like look at Cuba for example if
Ford against the USA just in its
backyard and it survived what what the
way that I believe that what Andrew take
needs to do now is he needs to really
Champion for institutional change in
certain things like prison reform for
example he needs to deal with real real
real Global issues that everybody is
really interested in where it doesn't
matter who you are whether you like him
or not you know that what he's saying is
true and it's for better change so it's
no longer we shouldn't be he shouldn't
be associating himself with men and
women anymore he needs to talk on a
societal and Global level that's what
will save him I'll say this I I think
there's a lot of people that watch this
kind of stuff and they get very black
pill and black pill is like a a
hopelessness like there's we're all
inevitably doomed you know what I mean
so that's how you feel right I feel
that's how I feel towards him I feel
like he's powerless and that's what the
elites want you to think but the reality
is right look at what happened I'll I'll
code name it like when the global cough
situation happened right we can't say
that word because you know God sorry
Susan
um but like when the global cough
situation happened right
people started organizing and fighting
back and eventually guess like the
French were doing it the Italians were
doing it the Chinese were doing it
everybody started fighting back again
the Australians were notoriously tearing
people apart right there's that one dude
who like knocked out three police
officers I got the hero uh who are just
like part of this draconian lockdowns
and all of a sudden Putin invades
Ukraine
covered scared yeah again to the
question do you guys feel like
um he will escape I I think normally he
wouldn't but I think he will because
there will be such an uproar if they do
anything yeah and that's why like I
think because he's been so vocal about I
will not kill myself like the next thing
they're gonna do I think it's gonna be
very tough for them to do that I think
they might get him on some money
laundering type chart like that that's
my only I don't think they'll be able to
pin them for human trafficking but I
think they like they said they always
take people down with this like money
laundering or something that's how they
got Al Capone do you know we have a
question but I want to I want to
reiterate on that point because you said
you felt a certain level of hopelessness
that's exactly what they want you to
feel but we have an equivalent amount of
power when we rise up collectively
regardless of our race regardless of our
gender which whatever the [__] 79
genders you are right regardless of your
economic status your religion when we
collectively get together and we have
you United non-conformance that no we
say like you know United non-compliance
excuse me when we collectively say no
[__] off we're not gonna be a part of
this
that's what's happening right now in the
states with the whole Dylan Mulvaney
situation people are like no okay we've
we've participated in your delusion to a
certain extent but we're drawing a very
hard Line in the Sand where you want to
chop off the genitals of miners you know
can I tell you something just did the
reason why although
there'll be a massive up rule for Tate
do you know what the danger is for Tate
who is your enemy there's no face to
your enemy yeah what are you gonna
complain about what what are people
going to to revolt against there's you
can't go against the police because the
police they what did not have nothing to
do with it government has no
responsibility for it the Matrix is who
until it starts calling out the real
people that are putting him in this
situation he doesn't really have nobody
can gonna rise up for off for him at all
because there's no face there's who are
you going to go against we're going to
stop using social media yeah he does
know that but the biggest problem is not
about him speaking about who's the
problem the biggest problem with him
is he's empowering the number one threat
to the organizations which is men he's
telling spent stop looking at porn stop
doing drugs stop being [__] simp stop
being fat get out there and be
disciplined get out there and make some
money get out there be a respectable man
and we are I think everybody here in
this panel can agree that the modern man
is not what he used to be 30 40 years
ago right we all couldn't unanimously
agree right and when he's coming out
here and he's telling these people a
message of do better level up that's the
real reason they're after the red pill
Community not because they were saying
this [__] about women and even if it's
because we're saying [__] about women
the reason that they are attacking is
because
women are the ones that these system are
able to pull the most money out of so
they want to protect them and act like
they're protecting women but if you look
at the stats too
at what point in history are women the
most miserable
ever it's right now because you can
actually afford to be able to gather the
data because I'm sure that if you go to
other periods maybe women were also not
as happy for don't forget that they have
logical advances
one out of three women are happier today
having an abortion and an STD that's
like a happier life well abortion nobody
looks forward to herpes yeah I'm not
gonna lie I'm not gonna lie but back
then people were dying left right in
center of syphilis they all had diseases
that's an STD yeah and so then that's
what I'm saying how many people then
also had them the only difference is
that people are not recording them like
they record them 95 95 of women were
married 85 percent of women were virgins
on their wedding day yeah even even if
they were lying let's double the amount
of women that and say 30 like even if
you said 30 percent of women were not
virgins on their wedding day that's
still two out of three women that
weren't sleeping around women are not
happier with promiscuity we're more
likely to we're more likely to be
depressed we're more likely to I can't
remember all this yeah like we're not
happy if you look at Tick Tock look at
all these girls how many times do you
see a guy crying on Tick Tock he's like
I'm 30 and I've been used by so many
women
I mean the red pill movement then it's
the same pandemic and all of these
things come from men saying that girls
have been taking the mick out of my face
using me for money using and abusing me
and now look at me I'm gonna cry and I'm
gonna Champion men say shut up [__] go
to the kitchen sure I've never seen a
guy cry I've never seen a guy crying
but you say that now you speak to a lot
of men about these things I've never
seen a guy cry on social media about
women taking advantage like actually
crying do you know why you exist and why
you're so big because men are crying
through you my sister that's why they'll
just never be the face to say ah do you
know what women have used me and I feel
upset about it talk about things that
are true denalda and it's like we always
want to shame like we want to shame the
red pill movement for talking about
reality and and you know they're okay
yes like men are not what they were 100
years ago but everyone knows that
there's no there's no gut reaction to
say but women there's no gut reaction
like we cannot have a conversation about
women without saying but men and I'm
telling you I've done hundreds of these
shows if I ever say anything about women
then then I'm a woman hater then I'm a
sexist but if like even the guys they
have so they have complete shows
dedicating to telling men that they
ain't [__] and they never go viral it's
my entire business model he literally
I've seen Myron [__] on guys I've seen
you [__] on guys I saw Kevin Samuel [__]
on guys that doesn't go viral why do the
women being told they ain't [__] go
viral because nobody does it yep can I
say one thing so obviously we all agreed
that what it would take for Andrew Tate
to escape the bullet is just a
revolution do you actually think it's
possible for there to be a resolution
because what I've realized about the
internet is that they will have a hype
or uproar about something and then they
will die in a week so going back to the
questions you guys actually think
agutate has a chance to escape the
village nah I think he I think Andrews
hate is so stubborn that he would rather
take the bullet than take the L yeah
good like money laundering charge or
something but I I don't think he'll so
is that like any evidence against him at
all I'm so confused
um I mean they basically would say that
like the women there's some all right
the last 100 years they've expanded the
definition of sexual assault abuse human
trafficking like all that stuff so like
a hundred years ago the only way you
could be graped is if someone literally
pulled you off the street and whatever
now we have they kind of blur the lines
because they expand the definition and
so they'll say oh a woman's grape diff
like like she not like they just kind of
we don't even know what it is and the
big reason behind that too is you know
why and same with abuse sorry go ahead
there's money putting people in prison
there's your money you know the United
States has the most people in prison in
the entire world yep it's crazy you know
that because there's big money into
prison that's why they're expanding you
know you could like look at a woman and
be like did you make this coffee like
that and she's like this guy's abusing
me at work you know yeah that's true and
so but and
and forgot who asked the question but do
you think it was your question like I
think they they could like they're
saying that because he made women follow
and you know made right can you make
someone fall in love with you like you
know I think all in love with me I think
a lot of side chicks would like would
say you can't make someone do that even
even the genie from Aladdin couldn't do
that remember yeah but allegedly they're
saying he would like make women fall in
love with him well it's funny because
like he was controlling so absolutely a
moment ago yes they were talking about
how women can be easily manipulated by
pretty images and wanting to spend money
well then that's exactly all he did yeah
but but at the same time do they have
the same energy for the women that were
manipulating men to get money this isn't
this and this is the crazy thing this is
not National who's doing it more listen
who's manipulating people to fall in
love more men or women women but not
quite but let me go back I'll give you
like the man did what women do what
fifty percent of women say they've gone
on a date for a free meal okay yeah 50.
wait 50 of women admit to this and it's
not national news nobody gives a [__]
but when a guy manipulates women for
money it's national news it's the the
Tinder swindler who's heard of him yeah
yeah but I'm saying that happens women
do that all the time it's common through
campsites
but it goes back it goes back to the
theme that we do not have empathy for
men in society we don't funny enough to
go to like prove um the example that
Paul was given I was watching an
interview of Candace Owens talking about
how I may be wrong but basically she had
an assistant and obviously Andrew Tate
met up with the assistant and asked her
do you want to join my little thing that
he does and she said no so she
completely left him so Candice owens's
argument is that what women do is that
one they can't when they can't get their
way with Andrew Tate what they do is to
flip the story even though Andrew Tate
clearly gives the swimming an
opportunity to say yes or no so that
what that assistant she had the
opportunity to say yes or no and it's
probably the same thing with these other
women these women probably said yes but
then when they don't get their way with
Andrew Tate that's when they go when
they say Andrew take they disagitated
that all the things that they agreed to
now my problem with Andrew Tate is the
fact that like why did he think this was
ever a good idea and it's also like he's
he talks about men not being manipulated
by women but yeah he's the one that's
like being manipulated by this woman and
is now in jail by the swimming so should
we really have been listening
to manipulate men he's not manipulating
the women like the women like like the
women aren't manipulating him they're
committing a crime yeah like it's like I
don't I don't think that's the same
thing a woman committing a crime
can we just stop for a second how are we
not as a [__] society
looking at situation that's happened to
Andrew Tate and demonizing these two
[__] that [__] put this man in
prison for six months he's not been free
one day this entire year how much have
you done this year I've done a lot this
man has gone to prison and then he is
lucky enough to get on house arrest do
you even know these girls names do you
know what so you don't know
why wait wait wait why see how are we
even you're so ready to turn around and
turn on men but the reality is look how
quickly you dismissed that question no
no this is my how are we you didn't even
have a reaction you didn't call them
[__] do you know what those girls
they literally the scum of the earth
agree that these women are the scum of
the Earth but we have to actually talk
about the fact that let me just make it
clear I love Andrew T I just want to
start now you do but um what I don't
understand is that Andrew takes whole
brand well some of it was just this is
how not to get manipulated by women now
he's down down for is because women
manipulated they committed a crime
that's not the same no you committed a
crime no but she had the same energy for
a guy that rapes a woman what I'm trying
to think
she's making she's making a good point
she's making a good point she's making a
good point what I'm trying to make is
the king of teaching people how to not
manipulate not be manipulated by women
was in the end manipulated because at
the end of the day these women may have
made it seem like Andrew Tate I'm in
love with you but they had a plan a
manipulation plan to take him down it's
like power but it was probably it was
because probably because look when okay
there was a time where I made a million
dollars in one month right and I was
just like you know what
[__] anyone who's gonna say anything to
me I'm the [__] man no one's gonna
tell me [__] I'm the [__] man and I
was just prideful out of my [__] eyes
and eventually I lost that million
dollars okay why
because I was Bryant I was blinded by
Pride you're a Christian right pride
comes before what for the form Andrew
Tate just got a little too prideful and
that's exactly what I want to say like I
actually I I'm so against Andrew Tate
and his braveness and him going against
but in every situation there's Parts
where you can sit here and say this is
where Andrew Tate went wrong and he went
wrong when he allowed women to
manipulate him he went wrong when he
decided to choose this lifestyle of
women one woman rather than settling
with this wife that I'm just finding out
he had and he went wrong with pride like
this is the whole point of how I agree
for for on the record I agree with you
if no one mentions these things then is
this real yeah I just don't think it's
manipulation No Cry may I ask you a
question may I ask you a question
nobody I'm asking do you have the same
energy for women that have crimes
committed against them okay let me ask
you a question the case is not finished
yet is it no okay so whatever it is that
you found out whatever evidence is out
here is things that can be just thrown
in the wind is whatever the real case
itself there's a lot more evidence that
nobody can even have access to in the
public eye like I said I'm not gonna lie
to you there is no smoke without fire
Okay so until we know exactly what the
evidence they actually hold against him
then we can't talk absolutely we're
absolutely is smoke without fire you
know okay there absolutely a smoker okay
there have been thousands of cases in
the U.S where there's a lot of smoke and
no fire there's a guy in the U.S who a
woman said he he raped her right and he
was kicked out of school and then do you
know what they found she was pulling him
back to the dorm she was kissing him and
then she said that he raped her yeah
like this happens all the time there's
often smoke with no fire
no wait wait wait let me just why there
is a bit of a bit of smoke there because
then when you're an e-pimp for product
retention a lot of the time you'll do
unlawful things to make sure that your
hoes don't walk out the door and start
losing your money because at the end of
the day when you're in that business you
know what's right it was um guiding you
or what's motivating you greed okay so
when your hoes want to walk out the door
it's not going to be simple oh babe okay
we had a great time it was fun while it
lasted off you go and I'm about to lose
an extra five bags and a night and no
thank you and the reason why I keep
mentioning where Andrew Tate went wrong
is because I want the other young men to
kind of learn from Andrew Tate when it
comes to Pride and dealing with all of
these tricks they're learning and not
make those same mistakes because I
cannot be I'll be so real I feel like
the red pill is going out bad they are
literally like losing their lives for
the same thing that they're preaching
for example Kevin Samuels his whole
brand was okay a woman you're gonna die
alone and in your 30s how did he end up
dying alone in his 30s listen first of
all I want to say this manipulated
what's happened like the red pill
Community you guys need to read no no no
no no no no no no no no listen more
strategically listen first of all the
red pill Community was not
spurred out of nowhere it's a collection
of a bunch of dudes angry at being done
wrong by these [__] listen why are
you acting like the model woman is not
treacherous she is she is the what the
red pill movement is is a response to
Modern female treachery and I will say
this in regards to Kevin Samuels I'm
pretty sure the [__] CIA killed him
anytime you hear somebody anytime
somebody said they die of a heart attack
like come on well and that woman um like
that woman said she'd marry him like
they wasn't they were like together it
wasn't like he died he literally died
with the girl he was seeing yeah he died
like he wanted to be married
I just personally feel like the red pill
community in general I love what you
guys are doing but I want you guys to
tread more lightly because I want this
visit to last a little bit longer
because what you guys are doing it's not
going anywhere Community is not going
anywhere this is honestly why like men
don't like women in our in their space
and I actually understand it as a woman
in the space because what women do no
because you know I really I really I
really do understand that because what
the guys will do is they'll be having a
conversation the way that men have
conversations in a masculine way and
they don't communicate the same way
females do and then women will come in
and say no communicate like me say it
the way I want when you're not a man you
don't they don't communicate like women
and that's it's always like women will
always come in and say the correct way
to do things when guys do things in
emasculine a masculine way is in a
feminine way and you see this and it's a
very like feminist like subculture that
you see in society like for example
they'll say oh they need to emote like
Express their emotions like women but
they're not women they're men and this
is why and this is why I feel like
Society is going wrong because men and
women are not working as a team the
reason why the president has a first
lady is because the first lady helps him
when it comes to okay this is how you
write a speech this is how you address
this is how first lady doesn't do that
assist the whole point no she doesn't in
the Bible
we gotta add some food okay no no no you
gotta add some facts to real this first
lady yeah the first lady
at the end of the day what a woman
provides to the table is she assists the
man and she helps a man the reason why
maybe Andrew Tate went wrong is because
he didn't have woman to actually sit him
down and tell him maybe this is how you
should communicate no he did he had a
wife at the time no but look how where
he ended up I like it and it goes back
to the thing interesting
that's not biblical you're like what
you're saying is not biblical like the
men need to listen to the women no women
listen to men men are superior that's in
the Bible what I'm trying to say in the
Bible it says a woman should be a helper
a helper is not someone who's Superior
someone that just helps but in your
sentence what you said is that women
shouldn't enter involve themselves in
the conversation because basically what
they say no I'm saying this is no no
that's not what I said I I said that
women the reason that men get frustrated
when women come into these spaces is
because women think like we always think
we're right and that's the problem is
like even in this situation you're
saying well Tate would have known he was
right if he just had a good woman beside
him when women are not like we are not
Superior when it comes to reason if
anything like if we're we're more we
just spent a whole hour talking about
how women are manipulated and propagated
the woman is not going to help him in
the city listen and then to add on to
where Pearl says okay like the only
perspective you really need to know
about women is like women think they run
the world like that alone gives you an
idea of the perspective of the female
point of view yeah you get what I'm
saying no I want you I pause there for a
reason I want you to internalize what I
said repeat what you said sorry
women hold a lot of power listen no
women think they run the world no like
the average are you kidding me Beyonce
song who runs the world Beyonce she's
she's a bit nuts and I'm not gonna lie
can I just say something quickly Pearl
on a rare occasion I will agree with you
on this one
do you know why do you know why people
call me masculine because I finally
understood that the way men speak tends
to be much more logical and direct so
when you are when you're able to take
that and to listen to the facts without
adding emotion then we'll get much
further in the conversation I will say
as much as I tend to stand up for the
girls on this occasion it is true a lot
of the time women are not able to
express themselves in a way that is
logical straightforward structured and
it makes sense because your brain is not
logical structured I think it just comes
from a lack of war or the time of the
month I think it comes down to a lack of
exposure to masculine energy so that's
why again for me I'm so lucky that I
studied a subject that is largely going
to be you know ruled by masculine energy
and I've got a lot of guy friends and
that's the reason why when I sit and
have these conversations I'm not feeling
sorry for women I'm not feeling you you
know upset I'm just saying the reality
of things is there's a lot of messed up
stuff going on Andrew Tate addresses a
lot of that problem a lot of those
problems his only problem in terms of
how he addresses things is that it comes
too aggressive he just needs to tone it
down a little too aggressive because
it's West now because he's too
aggressive for women for children listen
listen it's too aggressive for women
because listen I'm a man and there are
literally a billion plus men that agree
with Andrew D how many dudes that sit
around like well I like Andrew Tate but
he's just a little doomy no no no no no
no but for society because remember
Andrew Tate is not there to influence
but you can see this is where we're
doing it again but the women's way is
the right way I wouldn't say the women
you are but you didn't that's that's the
whole point once you see this stuff you
can't unsee it the women's way is always
considered right men need to be
emotional like women men need to speak
like women but they're not women
of the aggression for example you don't
need to sit down and say F this is
might not have said it but but it's
implied because yeah because have you
ever been like okay I used to sell
Plumbing like I used to sell Plumbing
like um a plumbing tech company so we
would go to these like a plumbers which
is a really like male dominated field
and we would give these presentations
about like the technology and plumbing
right and it was like the most probably
male dominated like room like most masks
because those guys are like they're
rough you know what I mean and the thing
is I could not believe how they spoke to
each other I thought they were so mean
yeah you don't understand that no and I
was just like but men even change the
way they speak about you every time you
speak to a guy they speak to you a
little bit differently than they do to
them that's why a lot of times women
have never heard men speak like this man
that's why we went it's not every
conversation with by the way I'm only
speaking to men because if you're trying
to speak to an enticing Society because
that's more General that's your
self-centered female nature discussion
and women you can't just cater to the
speech that men understand and think
it's okay because you're speaking to
women too he is not speaking to women
women are listening but Andrew Tate and
his marketing team are like all right
guys like we need to focus on diversity
inclusion he's like [__] this I want to
speak to young men I want to get these
people to sign up for the real world I
want them to join the war room because
women can't join the War Room okay and I
want a male-centric
here's the thing okay
you're missing what you're saying right
now you're saying that he should change
the way he speaks women and that's what
Pearl's trying to say is like you're not
understanding that his message is
directed towards men but you're fine but
you're so female-centric you're like how
dare he not cater to women he's like I
didn't he didn't want to [__] cater
to women it's interesting it made me
realize how self-centered I guess women
we're just very self-centered in our
nature and at first I was kind of
triggered me when I first heard it
because I'm like no I think of other
people but I noticed sticks on these
panels I would ask a question and the
women would always tell some per it
would be like a general question and the
women would tell like some 10 minute
personal story go into all these details
and the men would give me a
straightforward answer we just speak
differently yeah can I add something to
what she said
saying why did he um why did he get
called why did it happen to him so let's
say if I was a lady me personally I
would be like oh if I'm talking to my
girls about oh try not to get Graves
like tell them don't do this don't go to
certain places and then behind the top
like it ends up happening to me
coincidentally it's just something bad
to happen and I get graped it's like why
would I end up saying so because I'm
saying telling other people I'm
educating other people don't go to the
same places and happens to me that don't
make me stupid just like Andrew's hey
the fact that he's saying those kind of
things to those people that does not
mean that he can't that same thing
cannot happen to him do you get what I
mean yeah that makes any sense
don't say he's an expert no one is
perfect he's a human being she's right
you can't say someone is perfect people
it's a social media platform that's his
business he's selling that on there he
would say anything
not perfect it's not perfect but then
it's a social media platform whatever
sells my business whatever is putting me
out there you think I'm not gonna say
it's like on this place right now people
can sit and what [__] because they know
they're gonna go viral then they're
saying that not because they actually
you know how many people taste it but
you cannot say he's an expert he's a
human being so that happened to him it
was just it just sort of happened to
that person let me just end it just
happened to him he's just unlucky but
that does not mean it cannot happen to
someone else do you get my point yeah
he's he's I don't know guys listen it's
it's disingenuous listen it's it's
disingenuous to demand Perfection from
the speaker of a message of truth I
never said Perfection I do not expect
Perfection from um Andrew take at all
but you are kind of like he got finessed
by these girls
I've never once said Perfection that did
not come out of my mouth
I'm not saying Andrew Tate is a
perfectionist what I'm trying to say is
for example if like I'm a footballer and
I make money off of teaching people how
to be footballer and how to grow Pro and
then I lose due to my lack of football
scores that's going to undermine
everything that I've done yeah but what
football team is undefeated all the time
I disagree because I I've had like one
of the best coaches I ever had didn't
play because the point is is what
they're saying true and this is like a
way that women like typically attack
will attack people personally because
they'll say well you're this you're this
here this year that you're not this
isn't good enough and I'm not saying you
I'm not saying you personally don't take
that personal but but this is what women
do they'll attack the messenger when
instead of asking is the message true
like because if someone teaches me how
to serve a volleyball right or they make
certain substitutions in a game it's
still true regardless of who's saying it
100 everything that's coming out of
everything's mouth is true I'm not
saying it's not true I've said a million
times I support Andrew Tate what I'm
doing is just bringing out and
highlighting the irony of how this man
he's always teaching young boys this is
how to not get manipulated by men has
now been milit by Men by women has now
been manipulated by women
okay but so okay so like what if a boxer
what if a boxer is he's like this is how
you dodge punches and you dodge punches
like this but he gets punched once is he
is an idiot is everything he says
[__] there's a difference between
being punched once and being punched
numerous time and I feel like what we're
seeing so wait okay being knocked down
numerous times no he's just knocked down
one time when he had the entire world
formulating This Global structure to
take him out
these two girls were just a vesicle of
that but there have been people around
the world that wanted Facebook banned
him out of nowhere for nothing Instagram
banned him out of nowhere for Nothing
YouTube banned him out of nowhere from
nothing Twitter banned him out of
nowhere for nothing for nothing well
because what what okay so the terms of
service must you uh be partaking on to
participate on these platforms correct
yeah yeah yeah yeah just terms of
service so Community guidance Community
guidelines first Facebook terms of
service right what community guidelines
did he violate no to be honest I got
it's about
how dare something to say I'm the
solution I'm the female on the other
side I can give you boys of water in
your mouth to be quiet okay but who what
what did he no seriously what did he
break
uh probably I don't know like I hateful
ideology that's what I got no he didn't
break anything and they all came
together and unfairly took them out
there was a whole it was a collaboration
of all these companies
coming down to take him down and then
these girls also were part of that [__]
I wouldn't be surprised these girls are
paid by the [__] CIA
I need I need I need to read super chats
um okay guys
um let's read super chats we're doing
over twenty dollars so David Baker woman
second from the left who claims to be
trying to find the middle ground has
consistently and without fail pivoted
towards blaming men for every single
issue raised so far on this panel she's
being intellectually dishonest Leon vrp
shout out to the girls this well-mounted
deep discussion is refreshing open your
mind and hear the other out you'll
probably learn something we all search
for Truth uh Leon a vrp and the olden
days honor was everything the false
allegations to whoever Rises to the top
are inherently anti-masculine today we
use each other for personal gain um
choose to stand on the right side
gentlemen Nicholas be decent uh thank
you for the 50 Super Chat we really
appreciate it this is all for a kick out
cam we'll kick out denalva if we get a
500 Super Chat get put 500 in the [__]
out gladly walk out I'll support my
sister
a key lesson to understand is that hate
always comes from below when one speaks
the truth um and means something uh one
always gets attacked this is relatable
for many in the red pill space influence
equals hate and guys What You're Gonna
Keep noticing is all these blue pill
channels will keep on attacking us
personally but they can never attack
what we're saying they'll dig into our
past they're saying X Y and Z but they
can never attack the message that is the
worst part player is boring if more
women would act like ladies there would
be more men that would act like
gentlemen you are the gatekeeper Dr
David Baker the decline of relationships
was a universal across the developed
World regardless of whether the country
fought in World War II or Vietnam
disgusting way to blame men for women
failing to hold up there and uh Leon
thank you for the 50 um Euro Super Chat
John I love you man what doesn't kill
you makes you stronger looking forward
to the future and I will always stand
with you this is the the go-to guy to
level up in life um cheers everybody
wonderful evening and guys that's the
thing MLD really does care about men and
it's actually unfortunate the attack
campaign they've just done against I am
enduring I am enduring through this I am
the master endurer he will endure
um uh Cheyenne um this is for mld's
describe destruction of a nameless
blue-haired feminist
but let me refresh it one second
uh wmld in the chat okay
um okay now let's let's continue though
guys all super chats from this point on
over what amount 25
what do you want to do over
say 30 over 30. and 500 kicks off to
Nova yeah 500 to kick off denalva and if
you uh get me an extra 1 000 subscribers
I'll admit that I'm wrong
[Laughter]
video
I can't play it English why I'm in jail
I had no idea can they do that by law
you get it on the piece of paper in
English but there's translation it's
holiday we need to find a translator
that is a delay and you speak zero
Romania zero so they said oh yeah human
trafficking what do you mean human
trafficking who when
things before I finally got PC super and
then I realized what garbage truly was I
mean it was garbage I was like this is
complete garbage yeah
so um yeah I have endless stories from
jail it was it was certainly
I don't think jail teaches you much new
what it does is confirm everything you
already know it confirms everything you
know about the reality of the outside
world that you need to be physically
strong so that you're not attacked by
others and mentally strong so you're not
attacked by yourself you need to you
learn who's on your side and who isn't
you learn who's a coward and who's not
you learn who's an opportunist and who
isn't your circle you certainly learn a
lot about the people around you when you
go to a jail cell that's for sure but I
remember it was New Year's Eve
when I was first picked up in the 29th
of December I was very sure I'd be on 24
hours so there's no way they're going to
keep me for for what like this there's
not this doesn't make sense
so finally New Year's Eve rolls around
and uh I'm sitting in the in the jail
cell by myself and in Romanian jail you
don't leave the room it's not like an
American jail where there's a yard or
anything you're stuck in the room it's
three by four and that's your existence
you just stay there are you by yourself
at the beginning I was by myself
um and you're stuck in this room and I'm
sitting there
it's New Year's Eve and there's a very
faint speaker
maybe wait on the hallway the guards
must have been having a little party for
New Year's Eve and there's this awful
song it's called it's called the ketchup
song I don't know if you know what it is
I don't want to sing it but it goes but
hey uh-huh
[Music]
and I I know it's New Year's Eve because
the fireworks start going off
and I'm looking up my tiny window and I
can just hear the very long distance on
the end of the hallway hey uh-huh
this can't be it this can't be the end
of my life even the Cockroaches all over
the walls didn't celebrate there's maybe
15 cockroaches on the walls right and
when when it struck 12 when the
fireworks went off I kind of like well
who's my friends in here the Cockroaches
I looked at them even they didn't move
it's like well that's New Year's it's
funny because before that a couple days
before that me and Tristan were
discussing do we want to do New Year's
in Dubai do we want to go cour Cheval
shall we go Miami we're all arguing oh
that will be boring now that's too far
we got all these grander plans oh
finally we decided to go to Dubai
we were in Czech Republic at the time
and we decided to go to Dubai and I said
let's stop in Romania so I can repack a
suitcase that's it that's the only
reason that's the only reason so jet
left Prague landed in Romania my jet was
still on the runway
came here overnight to pack a suitcase
spent the night spoke to Greta with the
pizza box and it's 5 a.m to go before I
flew back to Dubai so that was my the
infamous Greta pizza box situation write
a pizza box how much you think there's
anything linked to Greta is there
anything uh because the timing of it
yeah I don't think she specifically said
of course but
there are certainly people within the
Matrix machine that you can't attack
without catching flak4 there are certain
they're certainly protected people it's
absolutely not really a club and you're
either in the club or you're outside the
club she's certainly in the club right
so if you're if you are if you say
certain things about certain people or
you get a beef with x amount of people
or you discredit a certain person
they're going to try very hard to teach
you a lesson for doing that and you can
see very clearly who's in the club and
who isn't by the the Phillip Schofield
situation
this is a man
a man but he's in the club all of the
media headlines after two days are let's
have compassion feel sorry for him his
mother's upset they've attacked me for
14 months day after day after day and
they relentlessly attacked me nobody
talks about my mental health nobody
gives a [__] how I feel I did I didn't
do any of the things he did he's
actually done things I haven't done
anything but when you're in the club
you're protected by the media when
you're not in the club you're attacked
by the media and that's how it simply
Works you're either on our side or
you're not but to join their side you
have to sell your soul your sanity has a
price you have to your sanity is for
sale you have to sell it you have to
come along with your sanity you take out
your mind and say here you go take my
sanity I'll take 35 million yes that is
a woman yes
it's insane and the reason these people
join these clubs is because they know
they're doing bad things and they feel
they need protection the reason I stand
up and argue against all this [__] is
because I know I have I don't have
skeletons in my closet you think I'd be
on the internet talking like I talk and
fighting The Matrix might skeletons in
my closet because I was actually a bad
person I've been investigated as deeply
as a person can be investigated by
multiple federal agencies for 14 months
I was locked into jail cell and 2 000
people I know was called my barber my
old housekeeper from when I lived in
England nine years ago my my Gardener I
used to have in another country I lived
in everybody was called and people were
offered bribes effectively the media are
calling girls saying if you have a bad
story to tell about Andrew we can pay
you thirty thousand dollars if you have
a bad story that's a bribe that's a
bribe and they still couldn't find
anyone still I've been investigated to a
deeper level than 99.9 percent of people
you cross on the street and they're
saying I'm guilty and I'm a bad person
you put you go get 20 men off the street
and put them through what I've been
through you'll find more crimes than
you've ever found with me absolute clown
world it's insane and if I was part of
the club none of this would be happening
the media would be on my side they
wouldn't hit me this hard they wouldn't
be lying about me all I had to do was
sell my soul and sell my sanity and I
refused and they're trying to punish me
for it that's what's happening it's
funny you say this
um when uh we watched the BBC interview
with musk right and he goes up and the
guy opens up the question with why did
you agree to do this interview he says
well I don't know what's the name of the
BBC and he's trying to mock them and all
this stuff and there's a part of it
where you know he calls him out for the
mistakes they made and if you go to the
bottom of the interview on BBC you'll
see comment sections saying why'd you
cut that out because musk puts it on
Twitter but they didn't put it in the
interview then you watch the interview
with the uh uh with you the first
question they asked you was uh uh what's
the first question hey you've been
accused of serious crime rape or
something like that uh you know right
off the bat they ask that question of
you and then you see the interview Lucy
Williamson I believe her first question
was you're facing some very serious
allegations have you raped anybody
that's the open
that they
actually put up the first one they take
it down the second video they put up
that's 12 minutes like the Highlight one
they turn uh the comment section is open
there's 80 000 plus comments there then
you look at Philip Schofield and you
just brought a Phillip Schofield for
people that don't know who Phyllis
Schofield do you mind explaining to
people who he is yeah he was a TV
presenter in England he was very famous
he ran the morning show and he was
grooming children for a very long time
and all the staff knew about it and the
people who worked on the show with them
were being groomed by him and everybody
knew and it was all a big ha ha joke and
now he's come out saying oh please don't
pick on me I feel sad and the media is
saying I'll leave the guy alone he he is
when you go look up his Wikipedia it
says he rose to prominence as children's
BBC continuity presented from 85 to 87
Dan went on to do programs on BBC and
ITV for going live this morning dancing
on ice All-Star Mr and Mrs thecube and
bunch of other things and they interview
him okay while he's going through the
mass uh uh you know after 27 years of
being married this one guy that he
groomed since 10 years old his name is
uh McGreevy I want to say something
McGreevy uh that he's uh going through
the process Matthew McGreevy they met at
10 years old at a theater group at 15
years old Philip follows him on Twitter
while the kid is 15 he follows them on
Twitter the guy celebrates it long story
short Ruth Langsford they work together
with she follows a complaint then right
after finally complained the McGreevy
gets fired then he has to take a break
then he comes out after 27 years telling
his wife you know and I'm gay I'm coming
out of the closet he's got two daughters
but there's a part of it where Matthew
calls his wife and says hey your husband
and I had an affair together when I was
19 the first time in 20 and all nobody
knows if it was before not the
interesting thing about him is his
brother Timothy Schofield I don't know
if you know about his brother oh what
the one who's in jail for being a
pedophile what's convicted of 11 sexual
offenses involving a child between
October 2016 and 2019 including two
sexual activity with a child here's how
the interview started first question the
guy asked him he says you've had quite a
week how are you open question first is
the question to ask you on the opening
right and then he turns around and says
the media's interest in the affair was
motivated partly because of my homo
because of homo homophobia alleging that
an affair with a much younger woman
would have not generated such a scandal
so he gets protected and he says all
those people who write those all right
write those stuff today everything that
there's actually a person on the other
end right this is proven by the way this
is the part where even when somebody's
watching you and saying why did taking
him to court maybe he did something why
they're taking Trump to court maybe he
did something why are they taking this
gun he must have done something there
must have been something there right
it's stuff like this BBC does it BBC are
watching this right I want to kind of
remind you of your mission statement
that show up on your website we're going
to put the link below to your mission
statement you can go find it here's what
your mission statement is BBC this is
why you've lost some credibility the
last couple years to act in public
interest serving all audiences through
the provision of impartial keyword
impartial high quality and distinctive
output and services which inform educate
and entertain you say you inform educate
you entertain yet you conceal misinform
and your content is quite frankly boring
you're cherry picking on people that
you're talking to so a message like that
gets the average person to say
everything with you is allegedly
everything he did is proven his brother
is proven yet let's leave him alone poor
guy let's target him this is where their
argument has leaks in it somebody like
you can tear it up absolutely Philip is
part of the club and I'm not and and
this is the thing I'm a mentally
resilient person right 14 months they've
attacked me I'm not going to sit and
complain about that because that's not
how I operate as a man 14 months they'd
complained about me if you'd look in if
you type Romania human trafficking you
type in any of these things my name
comes up my face I'm a bad person I've
lost all my bank accounts I've lost all
my social media accounts I've been
vilified all across the Matrix in every
single possible way they print my face
every single day with something negative
next to a date nobody gives a [__] about
my mental health right because I'm the
enemy and what's scary about this is
Lucy Williamson herself she was begging
me for an interview the BBC were begging
me for an interview I don't need any of
these people the only reason I even sat
down with the BBC is because they were
begging me I can go and just say my own
words and get plenty of views right but
the whole time I was in jail they're
begging me for an interview can we speak
to him on the phone maybe he can give an
interview from jail can we have an
interview please please please please
please and I was saying why do I want to
talk to the BBC and the BBC was saying
no we don't want to do a hit piece we
want to come across we're going to be
this is what they're telling this is
what they're telling me we want to be
impartial we believe there's a side of
the story that hasn't been told we're
really interesting and we're really
interested in some of the
or let's say
what's the word I don't want to get this
wrong inconsistencies in the Romanian
justice system we're very interested in
his side of the story there's been
enough hit pieces we want to tell the
other side we want to hear Andrew take
story and I said no on repeat then they
sent me a list of questions I didn't
even ask for a list of questions that's
not who I am I don't have to script I
never ask those two questions they sent
me a list of questions here's what we're
going to ask it's about his mental
health it's about the Romanian justice
system it's about the fact he hasn't
been charged his Liberty's been deprived
all this stuff and I thought well that's
kind of interesting maybe it's a bit
interesting and the Matrix is obviously
printing lies about me and these are
some interesting questions from the
Matrix for the first time ever okay they
walk in here all smiles and happy all
smiley faces try to take me off guard I
already had my list of questions right
it's all going to be nice and easy I sit
down and they instantly attack me they
put the cameras on First and they attack
me expecting me to stutter and make a
fool of myself
it's it's kind of like they tried to
Sucker Punch me I'm in the club and
they're my friend shaking my hand and
they tried to hit me and knock me out
yeah people will do this and enter it's
it it just happened to me it's [__]
disgusting yeah it's not like in good
faith like they come in with a whole
narrative they want to push and that's
that's all they see like they don't ask
you questions in good faith that
happened to me
um when I went on freaking like
trigonometry where they told me it was
like a general interview about your life
and then like they're grilling me the
whole time about Fuentes and I'm just
like I I'm like I thought this was a
general interview
this is why you have to
stay ready yeah yeah and then what he's
talking about too is like he he goes
into it and saying like these people are
genuinely evil and I think a lot of
people need to realize like there are
like just shitty evil people out there
and as a good person you typically
project your goodness onto other people
you project your good faith and your
good heart onto people who have a very
nefarious agenda set aside for you and
also and evil I don't think evil people
like they look like how you think yeah
like because it's typically people that
are really weak and so they especially
with like the media like what the lady
that was interviewing him like that
didn't go in good faith like does she
look like a sweetheart bless her yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah another thing I
want to say is like when if people watch
this and still don't believe in God then
I don't know for you because like in the
Bible especially in the Book of
Revelations which is the last book and
it talks about the full of like Humanity
it talks about how they will be like a
consistent fight against everything
that's good and everything that tomorrow
and everything that it's that makes
sense and you see that right now this is
um Andrew Tate is just a fraction of an
example of someone who's good and has
the right ideas which is just to make
strong men and yet they're fighting so
hard against they even Andrew Tate said
himself like the only reason why he
started to believe in God is when he
started to see the wickedness in this
world that's when he understood like you
can only fight against something if you
know it exists so guys I encourage you
guys to believe in God and like I wish I
could just sit down and just like
dissect all of this and show you guys
guys this is the scripture which really
shows this is happening right now but
obviously we don't have time but like if
you watch these things and you don't
believe in God and you don't believe
that there's a fight against evil and
good then I I don't know I definitely
agree with you I mean I wouldn't I would
just say that people really need to
understand that there are evil people
out there and it's and good people are
very reluctant and they're very tolerant
to look at these evil people and be like
no they give them the benefit of the
doubt all the time like you know I mean
if you look at like this drag queen
Story Hour that's been happening States
like these people are literally dressing
like demons and being like Oh no like
I'm totally care about the children and
you look at you look at like what what
are a lot of these people pushing out
okay I was even thinking about how they
did the whole hit piece on you saying
like the women should endure right no
but I was thinking about how they did a
hit piece on me saying that women
shouldn't get divorced over chores yeah
and it's like they're pushing people
being apart they're not pushing keeping
the family together which is crazy
because what you were saying is overall
a good message I mean they might not
they might not agree with a portion of
it but it's like overall the message is
to stay together keep families together
it's better for society it's better for
children that is the message and you
know but it's like all of these channels
will find like a little little piece of
the art well you don't think you could
get divorced over chores you don't think
like what about in the abuse like
there's exceptions but the rule should
always be to stay together yeah and then
you know what's funny after that entire
situation did happen a lot and it wasn't
it wasn't married men a lot of married
women reached out to me and they're like
I I completely understand what you're
talking about and they wanted to stay no
yeah no like I I can think of situations
where or maybe there was abuse on both
sides and the couple like worked through
it and they were better for it later and
that's like kind of taboo like they'll
probably clip this and say like I'm
promoting abuse and marriages but but
the problem is we always talk about the
relationships that didn't work out
instead of talking about the couples
that worked through cheating that worked
through abuse that worked through like
the hardest times and made it through
Happy on the other side it's always like
what is the worst case scenario that
could happen and that's what they do
because they they demand Perfection from
people they think like oh well you did
not go through this perfect situation
therefore you're a bad person and the
reality is all of us everybody here
people watching at home we're all flawed
we're all broken we all have things that
are wrong with us so how are two
imperfect people with insecurities and
Brokenness and traumas gonna come
together and make something perfect and
if we want to throw God into mix the
only thing perfect is God you know so
how are we these imperfect beings have
being held to this standard of
perfection and then these most the most
imperfect people are the ones casting
the stones at us like literal sodomites
and adulterers and like drug users and
all manipulators and Liars are like well
but you're not being this perfect
standard you know what I realized These
Guys these guys don't want the game to
change because it's benefiting them so a
lot of the guys that say oh leave
whenever like that promote from women
being promiscuous that say I like old
women I like this I like that instead of
being honest with women the reason is
because they're getting laid and so if
the game if women like change their
standards and behave differently it
doesn't benefit them so they lie I agree
with you women as well sorry women as
well I feel like if you're married to
somebody and you're divorcing them it's
because most times you don't love that
person as much because when you love
someone so much you're willing to walk
through a lot of things it's like in
some situations as well people actually
let's say for some people that are
dating let's say boyfriend girlfriend
like relationship it's like a lot of
girls which he on demand but would they
leave them no they would not leave them
because they would not want them to
collect you you wouldn't want your man
to catch you cheating you wouldn't want
him to know that you're doing all of
these things but you're doing it but you
respect him enough for him not to catch
you because you don't want to leave that
person because if you love someone
you're going to go through any accident
to stay with that person it depends on
the woman but I think that because what
so if you leave your boyfriend or your
husband now what were you going to do
we're gonna go face someone else like I
don't have a problem it's that women
think marriage is about love yes when
love has nothing to do it's about
commitment commitment and like why do
you think arranged marriages have such a
high success rate in India the divorce
rate is one person one percent one
percent that's crazy yeah and it's it's
because they realize that it doesn't
matter if I love this person did you get
that stat from me the one percent India
no I got it from uh Dimitri you guys I'm
sure you might have said it I said I've
gone viral on Instagram right now for
that because yeah it is a commitment and
like another thing is this too right
this is why like when women have have a
high body count it's detrimental to them
for relationship success because you
know our brain neuroplasticity whatever
we do again and again and again is
becoming our character and our you know
default choice of action so when you're
just like oh well you know I've been I
[__] 50 dudes so like what's 51 like
this guy's not being perfect I'll just
you know go out there and find another
one get up there and find one and all
you're doing is like chipping away at
your being and giving away a piece of
your soul Purity one by one and then
you're you're not learning how to endure
you're not learning how to go through
hard Parts relationships and you're not
learning how to understand the number
one skill you need in relationships
which is conflict resolution coming
together having peace and understanding
that the biggest thing is you coming
together and unified working towards a
goal rather than just destroying it and
tearing it apart because again these
like if you look at the two right what
happens when a woman gets divorced the
probability for getting divorce the next
marriage is higher and higher and higher
right they just keep on doing this
because their legacy is failure their
legacy is giving up their legacy is like
this is what I do I just quit when
things get hard I do have it and it it
makes you not as able to attach because
think about if you drink every day
you're gonna get used to alcohol if
you're sleeping with all these people
you're gonna get used to it yeah I've
asked girls that have slept like that
admitted on shows that they slept with
50 plus 100 plus people
but you know what's crazy I asked them
how many of those men did you love no
five and it seems to be like women have
the capacity to fall in love roughly
five times and you're done and the data
sort of supports it because it's like
after around like five to eight Partners
you're kind of done no I I use the
analogy of like a Vietnam War like war
vet right like the first two three
people you kill you're like oh my God
like I see their faces at night after
you kill 20 people you're just like [__]
it all you know and that's what happens
with these chicks they're like jaded war
vets just like running through one dick
after another and that's why I say
average like woman today would be like
so Haram because again like the average
like the no the average woman today has
and this is you know the self-reported
stats that take into like older women
into account so it's probably higher but
it's like they have five to eight
partners and you know by every data that
says you have less than 25 chance of
having a happy marriage in 10 years
I do have a question and I'm going to
teach women how to be a little bit
understanding what did you mean by women
need to endure and this is me teaching
women how to actually ask a person what
they meant rather than jump into the gun
and attack it what do you mean because
when I initially heard that I thought
what but I'm gonna give you the floor
too like so what I'm just saying is that
a lot of people right now in modern
relationships
in anything my general statement at the
time was people are just weak people
give up people quit on University
degrees people quit on giving up drugs
people quit on diets people quit on
relationships people quit on their
families deadbeat dads deadbeat moms
people just keep this give up and they
constantly go down the path of police
resistance what I'm saying is
collectively everybody needs to stop
giving up they need to stop being
[__] they need to stop quitting at
the site of one conflict in a problem a
lot of people think that like success is
just this linear thing up right how long
did you do YouTube before you popped off
it's not a good a year that's not a good
but still a lot of people quit after a
couple of months yeah yeah you know what
I mean I for when I started my YouTube
channel and you you know the shorts
thing helped you out when I had my
YouTube channel from 2015 to 2019 I had
880 subscribers
four years of just polite and failure
and then finally after I figured some
things out in 2019 to present you know I
have made millions of dollars doing what
I do but I endured I went through the
thing and even now I feel like my chat
my platform is kind of like at a another
plateau and I have to push through that
and have to elevate again I could easily
get a give up I could easily throw my
hands up and be like oh well you know
I'm this I'm from a single mother
household or I'm a man and everything's
a female-centric society and
everything's against me I can sit here
and make a million excuses but at the
end day nobody cares about anything in
today's culture other than results so
you gotta enjoy to get them done so what
did you mean by women need to enjoy like
what did you mean by that sentence I
said I said in I didn't say women need
to endure I said endure you see you
didn't even you even you didn't pay
attention to the context now they're
gonna clip this and make me go viral in
a negative way again not the irrational
feminine side is coming up sorry about
that it's okay we're gonna we're gonna
do super chats I think there was only
one or two guys 500 500 kicked an album
who's willing who's winning yeah yeah
you know
everyone is such energy for you it's
like put your money where you're missing
do you know why people have energy for
me because they're not used to seeing
somebody's speak with so much ease of
confidence yeah they are that's why
we're watching Andrew Tate well no as a
woman as a woman there's not many girls
now identifies as a woman actually so
you're right oh God damn a week ago you
know you have to take that too
trolling but yeah no but you know
he's definitely I agree exactly with
what he's saying because he does not
look like a victim and because he's not
a sweetheart he doesn't get the the
treatment of somebody that should be
getting that treatment imagine if this
was a pretty blonde girl oh my gosh oh
if it was Greta in his shoes they were
she would be she's not pretty she would
be no I know but but you know I mean
even the thing with Philip Schofield
he's somebody that everybody was used to
seeing on on morning shows and he you
know all smiling and he's friends with
Holly and all of this type of stuff
that's why he was likable but he was
doing some of the most awful things and
The Grooming of young people especially
young men from all of these top
Executives or top men of power that
asked uh closetess um closeted
homosexuals that happens it's so normal
I know about so many cases I know so
many I know so many of like young people
that constantly in these circles with
big grown men that shouldn't they
they're holding secrets that could
destroy organizations like this I must
say that Andrew Tate is like a true man
of God like if you want an example of
what it means to be a man of God Andrew
Tate is one of those people because his
bravery towards truth because it's so
easy to just give in just join the
elites be powerful never have to worry
about anyone but his commitment to
people is very inspiring people that
probably don't even give a monkeys about
him and if something was to happen they
won't even like you know have a
revolution but um I must say our duty is
extremely brave for that because I don't
I would switch
I mean as women that's like well it's
like men's great it's downfall to be
honest well you know that's what they
that's what they used to do they would
send in women to sleep with the top men
to get secrets from them yeah that's
what that's what's happening right now
with China and all of our politicians
they are literally sending in female
spies to sleep with all these [__]
idiots they're just vomiting upstairs
this is why this is why the red pill is
so important so they could see stop
simping no for real because you know how
many Secrets I know about a lot of
dangerous men just because they think oh
the novel is nice she talks well I know
a lot but I'm a good woman but the king
of the red pill ended up sin pin just to
put that he didn't step he didn't he
kicked them out it's like the opposite
of sympathy yeah he didn't Sim he got
gassed he got gassed he he the only
person who defeated Andrew Tate was
Andrew Tate
um okay so I don't actually see I don't
I don't think there's any super chat so
I think we're okay
um also guys in the chat it's blessings
birthday happy birthday to you yeah we
got him cupcakes earlier but I let him
pick the food so you got would you want
pizza and wings
wings oh man okay uh put the video back
up if you don't mind blessing
what a dedicated guy working on his
birthday blessing is a [__] G man
yeah blessing you are a blessing he is
living up to that name and this is the
thing that's so amazing about it yes I
destroyed the BBC but of course I did
because I'm smarter than all of them but
why should I have to rely on my wit and
intellect to destroy
BBC with their research and their plan
plan to try and annihilate my not only
my credibility but my life they are
trying to put me back in jail these
people they're not they're not dishonest
and they don't give us
and so why should I even sit there and
entertain them I believe I can slip
every single Sucker Punch they throw at
me for the rest of human time I can sit
with any of these clowns and no matter
who they sit with with their research
team whatever garbage they come up with
I'll make a fool of all of them but why
am I even entertaining them anymore
what's the point that was the last
chance I gave mainstream media they lied
for months to get that interview with me
completely dishonest head to toe and
like you said they sit with Philip are
you okay are you okay we heard your
mum's upset that poor old lady maybe he
wants you to stop talking about it
because his mom's upset let's not talk
about it anymore because his mother's
old you're either part of the club or
you're not you have to sell your sanity
nowadays if you sell your sanity your
afforded protections that's the reality
of it because if you're a sane thinking
person you don't buy their [__] and
that's what upsets them they don't want
anybody who thinks for themselves they
need you to not they want you to believe
exactly what's on the television screen
believe in covid it's covet now it's
covered now oh Putin's invaded Ukraine
Putin's cured covid now now it's it's
insane till the next thing comes it's
absolutely asinine did any of the
questions that they sent you ahead of
time Zero by the way we didn't there was
no no okay denalva I need to pause this
for one second just to tell you that
there's some of them made an account
called denalva denalva
someone in the chat made account called
denalva de Nava Daniela oh that's cute
you know I must say guys don't give her
more attention but it's a good thing you
know what I mean when even when Jenny
did all of her videos about me I'm like
wow is that really like how much like my
presence hits people yeah I know I
actually did a video on you too
the hair you look completely different
and you're way nicer in person she's a
nice person I look like a [__] but I'm
actually really nice you look on camera
you do but you are actually a real
sweetheart what a surprise yeah I know
most people get surprised they're like
oh wow I don't mean I just like yeah
more than Elvis Pearl trying to get your
attention
whatsoever did they ask you any of the
questions that you said they were going
to ask zero they start with an attack
and it became a battle instantly did
they ask you at any point what jail was
like your mental health was like zero
how like you completely missed the mark
when everyone wants to know what was
jail like well but they don't even
have interesting about it these people
are so detached from reality because
they are genuinely detached in reality
they think that finding a video I made
eight years ago a four-hour speech I
made eight years ago and finding one
line of it without context that can be
misconstrued they think that sitting
down with me and and saying that to me
is an aha moment nobody cares because
they're taken out of context one and I
said you're taking things out of context
because I'm not taking out a context I
said you're presenting it without
context that's taking it out of context
that's what it is you're lying by
Omission I said that to her after the
camera's off and she looked at me
because she didn't understand when you
omit details when you refuse to put in
all of the details you can lie by
including one detail which may happen to
be true you could tell the truth and
miss all the details around the truth
and you are lying by Omission you're
lying by omission and you're sitting
here you're saying oh you said this a
year ago nobody cares because they know
me and they know I didn't mean it in
that way and they know it's taken out of
context and they know that it's an old
video on the internet and it's not even
an aha moment they think it is but they
just want to sit with you for an hour
attack you and attack you and attack you
wait for you to make one mistake if I
would have stuttered or made a single
mistake that's the only three minutes
they would have shown that's all they
want they want that one hour then they
take the little bit with me they cut it
down to 12 minutes they look terrible in
all of it but I've already made a single
mistake would have been the only bit
they've shown I care about fake news did
you tell them did you say I'm only doing
this if I'm able to record as well I
said I know that's what happened with
Trump as well a couple years ago I
didn't even tell him I just recorded it
okay so they didn't know you were
recording they didn't know I was
recording until afterwards and then I
said that was dishonest I'm going to
release the whole video you told them
before you released there is no contract
or agreement with BBC no nothing was
signed it was just simply a an interview
okay because I think that was very
important when you released it for
people to see what fully was said versus
and by the way you know the Phillip
Schofield the interview that they put up
the 12-minute one that just came out you
know the comments are turned off of
course they are the comments are turned
off yours are turned on this is turned
off uh and and who knows many reasons
why they would do that but go back go
back to BBC so okay they come they want
to ask the questions of you for some of
the people that maybe aren't following
the story closely but they know who you
are we're in the car we're driving and a
lot of people are asking questions we
asked the drivers like hey are you going
to Tate's Place how do you know we're
going to takes place and he says well
who State oh Andrew Tate oh tell us what
I undertake well they said okay what
kind of a guy is he he's actually really
like him I said why do things going
through what he's going through right
now oh it's because it's always because
of money okay so we're at a different
restaurant so tell us why are you going
through this why is it going everybody's
saying a similar thing about this right
but for those who don't know there's
three different camps yeah the camp that
already sees you guilty it doesn't
matter what they read so for example
this story here you know from BBC came
out just last night 10 30. Andrew Tate
choked me until I passed that UK woman
claims right this is Alice another
anonymous name just like Sophie right
but there's three camps there's those
that say well look I'm already thinking
he's guilty I don't like him anyways I
need anything to get me to think he's
guilty whatever it takes I don't have to
I don't have to do my own due diligence
I just have to hear anything then
there's a camp that's a die-hard fan
there's nothing you can do that they did
wrong you can you know in their eyes
gonna be wrong then you have the people
in the middle that are the reasonable
ones that are saying you know what let
me look at this what about this what
about that the people in the middle may
say the following question they may say
and I may have asked this question from
you last time as well they may say
Andrew okay if this guy is so innocent
how can they get you to go to the
dungeon for 92 days how can they put you
on house arrest how can they do all this
stuff if you're somebody that was born
in the U.S you lived in UK how come
somebody else isn't coming to bail you
out you got different lawyers how is it
that they can keep doing this to you if
you're not guilty what do you say to
those people yeah and once again I have
to be careful what I say because of the
court case but Romania has a law or the
law in Romania is basically if you can
prove to a judge that it might have
happened they're allowed to hold you up
to six months during the investigation
stage if I was guilty of anything I
would have been charged long ago and
we're going to talk about charges soon
because I I still believe they're going
to attempt to charge me but we're now
approaching the end of the six months
they can keep me under a form of arrest
without charge
typically in Romania when I was first
arrested
the guard said ah within two weeks
you'll have your indictment it was like
two weeks he goes yeah everyone gets
charged quickly nobody Waits six months
for a charge if they arrest you they
charge you like like every other country
right the fact they've waited six months
and gone into my entire life and
attempted to to find something shows
they don't have a case why I believe it
happened is because they didn't have a
case when they were trying to hit me
with this garbage and they thought you
know what if we put him all over the
news
if we slander his name completely if we
there was a hotline
you're a girl who's gonna hurt my
undertake call this number
so they were tempting to use the
SE to find what they wanted months go by
months go by months go by case File is
empty nothing's happening my lawyer's
saying when we can close this case File
like yeah we're just waiting for some
papers we're gonna close it we're going
to close we're going to close it around
the time I was canceled
things start appearing in the case File
they start spying on me again
very interesting that it happened around
that time
I don't know if they understood that I
didn't have I wasn't protected by the
political class of the USA I don't know
what happened
they started to build this case and they
spied on me for all of these months
spending millions of Euros spying on me
everywhere I went trying to find
evidence of a crime
eventually they get to the end of their
legal limit spy on me and they don't
have any crime they don't have anything
so in my current court case we have two
Americans who lied the ones who we have
the conversations between them saying
they're getting an Oscar for lying to
the police we have the ccdb of them
coming and going we have their Uber
records showing they can travel the
country freely we have their phone calls
with their mother where they're saying
yeah he didn't hurt me and my boyfriend
called me that we have all of it we have
all the evidence we have those two
and then there's nobody else who could
possibly even take the stand I don't
believe as as as high level as this
Matrix attack is I still don't believe a
Romanian judge is going to put me in
jail with the dossiers I've seen it it's
garbage I don't think I'm going to end
up in jail but it's just taking years of
my life damaging my influence to having
bad things to say about me keeping me
under control keeping me locked in a
house that's all they want to do they
have no interest in the truth there's no
victims there's no one to take the stand
do you know who Sophie is or Alice is or
no yeah so the BBC that's really
interesting so then the BBC says well we
found victims because the BBC have done
enough investigative journalism to
understand that the case is garbage and
they have there's no victims so they
said well we found victims
they found one called Sophie first that
was a few months ago I think I was still
in jail when Sophie appeared is that her
real name no that's her thing so they
have a girl with a fake name called
Sophie they don't show her face
they they ask me what do you think about
Sophie how can I comment on Sophie when
Sophie isn't real first for made her up
secondly I don't know who you're talking
about you're saying that nine years ago
I was emotionally controlling that is
the most subjective garbage accusation
what does that mean nine years ago I
said you shouldn't party with those guys
in the club is that what I said I don't
know what I said I don't know who she is
if she exists at all and they're saying
nine years ago you're emotionally
controlling Sophie said so who's Sophie
we're not telling you what's emotionally
controlling mean we're not telling them
what do you what comment if this person
even exists which they don't then I
destroy the BBC make it very clear to
them that Sophie doesn't exist on repeat
because she doesn't and two days later
Alice appears what's interesting about
this is that decal the federal agency
inside of Romania along with help from
International Partners have tried so
hard spending millions of Euros with
Federal level tools to find a victim so
they can put me in jail and they can't
find anyone but the BBC just pulls them
up whatever they want the BBC does where
do these people come from and I say this
every single time if anybody believes
they've been wronged male or female by
me go to the police go to the police I
encourage you to go to the police all
these people say we don't want to go to
the police
we just want to say on the news what is
that because you're not real is that why
that's pretty convenient I mean if I was
a bad person why don't you go to the
calls oh because you have no evidence
and it doesn't exist that's why are all
these accusers in the UK not even in
Romania not even Romania so Sophie and
Alice are supposedly both from the UK
and Alice's story to correct that's not
Al I said Alice it's Evie Evie or Evie
or something like that e-v-i-e it's all
made up names it's all made up yes
Evie is saying 13 years ago I choked her
or something yeah by the way when is the
six month time limit and did this come
okay and can we reference the Tweet you
just posted a couple days ago I want to
stay on the show it's commenting on Evie
and you were going to say something
about Evie uh what she said 10 so she's
claiming 10 years ago or 13 years ago
you guys had the consensual sex the
first time she comes back for the second
time around according to the story she
says she was being uh uh your hand was
on her throat strangled me she was
passed out for a minute and then she
came back and she said I did not approve
of the second time time having sex after
she was passed out so these stories
they're making you know and then she
says the guy asks a question saying how
come you didn't do any police report
back then he says well because it's not
fully rape and it's not bad because it
was consensual I kind of wanted to be
there and I didn't tell anybody about it
six years later there's way too many
things that doesn't give it credibility
for somebody to say I didn't do anything
about it then but six years later I told
my friends three or six years later yeah
and this is the thing that's scary if
you say to any red-blooded male 13 years
ago you had sex with a woman
consensually and she's now unhappy about
how that sex happened you can get any
man on Earth can get screwed to that if
this person exists at all like you said
get in line baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah there would be a lot of there would
be a lot of complaints bro listen when
have you ever heard what have you ever
met a girl and she's like I love my ex
he was a great guy it just didn't work
out
no toxic he was a narcissist he abused
me he kicked my dog you know it's just
endless endless smear and that like I
get so much Flack when I don't like just
automatically believe a girl it's crazy
if you even quite like if someone's
story just doesn't make sense like this
one girl oh my gosh she just got
divorced right and she had this whole
story about how the like the husband
left her high and dry and she went off
to us like like and she took the kid
because he was a deadbeat and then she
would say oh but I didn't trash him and
I'm like well how did you not track him
just called him a deadbeat and all I
said on social media was we should
really hear his side of the story and
Destiny all these big streamers started
coming at me bro yeah and saying that
like that I'm I just all you do is only
hear them hear the woman's side I'm like
I heard her side I watched the 45 minute
video she made about her ex-boyfriend
and I almost think we should believe
people last that do that stuff because
it's very like attention seeking yeah
because the thing is this too like that
used to be all the rage and like the 80s
and the 90s like one woman came out and
started crying and then you got these
evil [__] at home like I hate my
husband like I can [__] I could do
this too and then now they all like I
said copy pasta do you know one thing I
also realized that if and hey it wasn't
like um a celebrity if he wasn't famous
I don't think this woman would actually
come out because you know what the world
we're living right now everyone wants to
be famous everyone wants a hospital in
any way they can so it's like when you
get famous people just come up and make
up a lot of stories sometimes yeah
they're true so if because he was a
let's say he was a Debbie back then in
the day why didn't she complain but all
of a sudden now he's famous everyone
knows him on YouTube all of a sudden you
remember oh my God that helped me past
that I want to go say something to
police oh now I'm hungry he chokes me
you were dying like successful why
didn't you say anything you just left
yourself to breathe you walked the air
and then you see oh he's a famous person
and they're like because they're gonna
get something out of it it's always
gonna get paid for it they're gonna get
the Clown out they're gonna be famous I
know that maybe it might be true but
then again it's like they're taking
advantage that's what people would see
us even if it does happen it's like I'll
feel bad for them when they're like I'm
feeling like you're just taking
advantage of this man dude you're doing
it for what you're getting out of it
because if you're genuinely sad about
what happened to you you would say
something and all the Western world as
well where you can say that the Lord
favors the women in the western world
and it does favor that women outside so
if this happened like let's say like
this happened in Nigeria I feel like a
lot of women would not say nothing
because they're like people are going to
be like look at you less but this is a
Western World people just if you go say
something to the police the women are
always right so like that's what I think
first like that's what it just happens
in general it just happens in general it
happened to Pearl when she popped off
everybody from her past is like oh Pearl
is terrible to me happened to me
recently some loser that I took into my
life felt sorry for trying to lift them
up now he wants to try to like expose me
because he's a loser English teacher you
know all this stuff happens when people
rise to the top
right and you have people in your past
who feel jealous or they feel angry that
they weren't able to ride your coattails
up to fame or Glory they get entitled
they feel entitled like you were started
in the same place and then you became
successful so then it's like they get
like jealous and then it's like they had
all these issues with you but not when
you were not when you were present
that's not what you're present yeah
that's the thing it's like we're so
quick to believe people that like tell a
story online when you realize it's like
attention seeking especially people that
make like a full is one thing if it
comes up in a conversation you know like
within the age of live stream like stuff
comes up right yeah but I'm like this
girl made a 45 minute video about her
ex-husband and then she's like well I
had to I'm a public figure no you don't
you didn't you said like any any like
words that I've ever said about like an
ex-boyfriend online I have regretted
saying because I'm just like I shouldn't
have said anything even with anything
even with Crowder's wife like she was
sitting on that footage what was that
from 2021 yeah two years ago and she's
like okay now I'm spited and I'm gonna
release this out of nowhere like come on
well and it's and a lot of times it's
the same story like and that's why when
she was saying he was a deadbeat I
didn't believe it because again and and
you know people will say it's anecdotal
but like you start to notice patterns
and I start doing this divorce
documentary where I interview men that
like don't get custody to the kit of the
kids and it's so common where the woman
says he's a deadbeat when really she's
not letting them like I think it's a
myth the deadbeat dad I think it's much
more common for women to use the kids as
a tool I have a question do you feel
like Andrew take could have avoided all
of this if he would have just focused on
his wife rather than messing around with
like how many other women just question
uh I think you know because the thing is
that the cancellation came before this
if she they canceled him you know it was
that one um you know there was this one
dude that started posting stuff I forget
his name he's like this uh this gay
Jewish dude started like posting this
like you know Slide by like infographic
thing I'm like why Andrew Tate is so
misogynistic and then boom one day you
wake up Instagram Facebook Twitter
Youtube mind you are all competitors
unified together and banned him right
that just shows you how afraid they were
of his influence and it wasn't because
of him cheat you know having other women
and stuff he was like oh he's a
misogynist and blah blah it's the same
thing like back in the day when they all
got together to ban Alex Jones and he
was shouting about the frogs of being
gay and now if you look what atrazine in
the water is doing to frogs and you find
out like the frogs are becoming yeah you
feel like it would have happened
regardless even if he didn't have that
past well the thing is this I think that
humanity is trending towards truth and
we're kind of breaking through this
previous like archaic Paradigm that
we've been on which is like you know
believe the news and the government is
good and like oh yeah we gotta like you
know support the war in XYZ location I
think people are waking up and a big
thing too I think the the cough
situation really woke up a lot of people
because they're like yeah just take two
of these things and you're gonna be able
to take off the mask you're gonna be
A-Okay people took them they're like all
right Mass can come off now like oh me
how dare you how dare you does anyone
hit you and so who didn't take it
oh [__] it yeah I like these did you
take it do you know why I did uh let me
tell you
why you gotta get off the show listen to
why I did listen when a woman is in love
it's so stupid I did because
it's crazy is he still with you listen
the craziest thing is that people don't
know
if you think of the novel In Love you'll
never even recognize the person that
you're speaking to right now I'm a
sucker for love but yeah so because he
said you have to why would you not you
have to and I'm like yeah but I'm
because me I I studied International
politics because I believe that you told
me he told you so I did so I submitted
so wait a minute wait so wait let me
just let me just kind of pull back here
are you blaming a man because you took
it
I just submitted my decision to you know
he said you should let's take I'm going
to take it his family was taken I said
okay I actually have an answer to your
question historically you'd be right
that he could avoid a me too accusation
but since divorce is legal and when that
that's just essentially Shifting the
power to his wife and hoping his wife
doesn't do it you know 50 you're you're
in the church right they used to go to
church for good women but there aren't
virgins in the church and half of the
women in church believe in divorce so he
can't even go to the church and find a
good church woman and so all you're
doing is saying okay now you're giving
the power to one woman as opposed to
many do you know because women women
constantly meet two men in divorce court
they do it all the time because um the
way that they can get especially in the
UK because you get a free lawyer here if
you accuse a guy of abuse and there's
lots of incentives in different
countries to accuse men of abuse so the
same thing what it could have happened
to him just with a wife it's just hope
she doesn't but I just feel like Andrew
Tate always preached the importance of
how to recognize a good woman so don't
you think he could have used that skill
set to just find that good woman and
focus on her only because I get it like
is you're putting your like you said put
in your chances just on one many women
is better than one but now you're in a
situation
there's no such thing in my opinion
there's no such thing as a good woman I
know that sounds crazy and the reason is
because any even a good woman can get in
the wrong group of friends even a good
woman can start following the wrong
people on the line listening to the
wrong music and make a decision when
she's angry yeah even it's not that
every like 50 of women file for divorce
it doesn't mean fifty percent of women
are evil but women are a lot more easily
influenced like they're like 10 times
more likely to get divorced if their
friends get divorced it's not good women
but there's better women so my thing is
better is better there's better chances
there's better chances right again but
again a guy can't really know you can
look for signs and say okay like you do
this she's more likely to be a good
woman but a guy cannot know you know you
know damn well you can all think of one
girl that is pulling one over on a guy
and he has no idea yeah she's smiling I
see them
but yeah she yeah she's fine you know
you can all think of it I could think
Nikki tell that man tell them that is
pulling one over and you're evil too
sorry just to answer the question um pal
so what do you think do you think like
um Andrew Tate was better off messing
around with many women or just Facebook
you're just like if you were still he
wasn't saying wait wait but he wasn't
saying like hey guys get out there and
cheat on your wives like he wasn't
saying that and you're seeing that no he
wasn't like guys don't get married no he
wasn't saying he did not he was he was
exclusively saying stay away from shitty
women stay away from Trashy Women he's
on record when he was thought we was
talking about the milk boys right uh
when they were talking to him they were
asking him about like what do you want
one of the guys was saying like what do
you want like a woman who's
inexperienced sexually or a woman who
has been through a couple dudes and has
more sexual experience he's like what
the hell kind of question is and of
course I want the inexperienced woman
right he is not saying like get out
there and hang out with hoes and get out
there and hoes are the best thing he was
saying like a good pure decent woman is
worth a masculine protection from the
worthy man you see what I'm saying so so
you're saying that what if he was not
out there screwing around with girls
would he have not been canceled you're
missing the problem he wasn't canceled
because he was screwing around girls he
was canceled because he was empowering
the male youth who was extremely
disempowered at this point in history at
the most the the men right now at the
lowest point in history period right the
average man has been completely defeated
he's addicted to drugs he's Addicted to
You Know corn he's Addicted to You know
you know corn cornography PornHub all
that stuff you know he's addicted to all
these terrible things that are bad for
him and he is telling these guys stop
being fat stop being a loser stop being
addicted to this stuff stop being
addicted to video games get out there
lift weights have some discipline be a
better person right but everybody wants
to overlook that phenom terminal message
that these men are dying to hear he
didn't entertain didn't go to these
people houses and like kick down their
doors like you better subscribe me to
YouTube you little beta male no there's
a vacuum of desolate broken men who are
looking for a masculine leader and he
filled the vacuum and he was the one
with this empowering message and a lot
of these guys have turned their lives
around and that's why he got canceled
why because the elites want slaves they
want good obedient stupid slaves smart
enough to do the work but dumb enough
not to ask why am I a slave do you know
also why I agree why I'd have to say
that what she's saying to an extent is
quite true because what I found is that
a lot of these men that have the same
attitude that Andrew Tate has and even
when they speak on relationships and the
way they speak about women in general is
a reflection of the type of women that
they have dealt with and that they have
attracted because we really really
really really a lot of the things that
being said
they'll tell you that the guys will tell
you they had a red pill moment most guys
will admit yes that I dealt with these
type of women and this is what you
should look for it doesn't mean that
they can never get one over on them ever
yeah that's okay but even these red pill
men and even Andrew Tate when he was sat
here he's talking about I can choose
some days I want to have loads of
[__] and days I want to feel like I'm
loyal that's the problem because you
want to deal with [__] the things
things the world is going to change let
me tell you something the world is
really going to change the day that men
stop handling [__] and I'll tell you
why because women they seek validation
from men tirelessly that's why women
have a lot of insecurities to do with
their visuals because why that's what
attracts men when men stop entertaining
hoes women will stop being hoes no
that's wrong that's entirely wrong okay
listen listen if women collectively got
together and said we are only going to
date dudes that wear suits suits would
sell out across the [__] globe okay
men always match the females desires
that's the way it is the only reason
hookup culture exists
because women are giving away [__] so
easily
that's it
no wait wait it's supply and demand you
can shake your head all you want but you
can't shake your head at the laws of
Economics okay and when there is a
supply of easy access easy available
vagina why would guys be like well
why buy the cow when I can get the milk
for free women don't women don't reward
gentlemen that's like why this whole
movement exists is because all the guys
got together and compared notes
basically they're like okay I tried
giving her flowers I tried treating her
well and she doesn't sleep with me how
are you guys getting laid and then they
come to find out oh my God they're
having sex with the guys that treat them
like [__]
yes all the guys giving them money like
I said if men stop entertaining hoes
girls will stop being hosts trust me
women want men a lot more than men I
think I think women that's what I'm
saying well that's exactly what I'm
saying women need like the reason why
when the majority of men who are out
there having sex promiscuously right
when you're a good girl and you don't
sleep with the guy in the first date
he gets a little disappointed you know
why because the rest of them are giving
it up for free on easy on the first date
they're giving it up and so he's like
damn and some of these guys will be like
damn the problem is me you know what oh
well [__] this [__] you know she won't
give it to me easily so they're gonna go
find the next girl but you girls need to
go [__] shame the rest of your friends I
mean stop being a hoes because you're
[__] up for good girls like me yeah
that's the truth and I I agree with that
like for example I will I'll do
something right here right now I saw uh
Beyonce's uh some of Beyonce's coverage
of her freaking concert she's moving
like an absolute hoe I'm not gonna lie
that is a grown woman that brought her
child on stage and acted like absolute
Madness and she's meant to be the the
example that everybody's meant to follow
no that's terrible look at people like
Megan this style even
look at cardi B most a female artists
nowadays are not the women that you
should look up to at tall in the slide
these are just women that are being used
as like almost like glorified strippers
you know what I mean that's a problem
that I agree and I have to say for sure
and the church we call them Jezebels
that's right so going back to what I
said Godless Jezebels exactly in the
Book of Revelations it talks about like
how there will be a lot of Jezebel
spirits around and women just teaching
women how to be more promiscuous and
things like that and once again guys if
you guys are not believing in God and
seeing the madness that's happening this
world then I do not know
um I'm gonna Read Super Chat um Vinnie
in the spirit of Kevin Samuels who used
to have a Facebook group of women of
value and high value men where he'd make
relationships with an app on the way
when are you going to release a jpt
traditional dating app oh my gosh I
actually have a whole um Google form of
like men that want to get married and
um I was thinking I was thinking about
doing this I just haven't had the time
um maybe maybe in the next couple months
we'll see
um two near me um to not near me stop
speaking about the Bible when you are
not a virgin the Bible states that God
is the first man that women and children
Ephesians 5 22-33 literally States the
husband is the head of the wife
um that's why I say like 95 percent of
women today are [__] because in in
historical terms if we're gonna go you
know his history they are yeah like you
would have been in the Harem with all
the women Godless Jezebels just make
sure you're a sexy one no no
they had to you look sexy in hell when
you're burning in the Lake of Fire
I'm a kind-hearted person
um the denalva denalva de Nava as long
as didn't now oh wait that's not over
20. I'm sorry but I'll read it anyway as
long as denalva don't act ratchet she's
been good she's been acceptable don't
slip up there were two worst guests than
you guys I'm over 20 over 20 super chats
for reading um also the pizza's coming
in like a couple minutes so yeah we are
we are getting food soon blasting make
sure when we get the pizza you meet the
mic so it doesn't yeah
um okay go ahead bring up the video
I'm not going out again
it's only 43 minutes
and she's saying it was consensual I
think last night they aired it on news
night and she literally they said why
are you coming forward now and I think
this actor the person literally said
because now he's rich and famous they
literally said those words that's that's
what they said oh because now he's rich
and famous I think it's unfair that it's
it's it's it's asinine I don't
understand
genuinely how a man can protect himself
from the Western world anymore how can
you even exist anymore if this is what
they're going to hit you with as soon as
you get to a certain level of influence
there's no man on Earth who's safe from
this I said this to my judges I had a
few male judges I said they could do
this to you
they could do this to anyone they can do
it to you or you or me or any man
watching this any man watching this they
can put in the BBC nine years ago you
did something they won't tell you her
name they won't give you any chance to
defend yourself do you have no idea what
they're [__] talking about and they
will print it on repeat until you lose
your job and lose your bank and lose
your social media and then you're gonna
sit there bankrupt and depressed and
then they're just gonna move on from you
and if you don't die if you're like me a
cockroach refuses to die if you sit
around and refuse to go away they're
gonna make up a new one
crazy and it's genuinely scary and
you're not safe from it anywhere anymore
all right we'll say right now on this
podcast I encourage absolutely anybody
who believes I've harmed them male or
female to go to the police with evidence
and we'll go to court let's do it I
don't harm people if I was harming
people I wouldn't be out here as open as
I was
the biggest criminals and the biggest
gangsters the most heinous people on
Earth don't have social media
you know this do I see a guy with an
Instagram pretending he's a gangster
he's got a gangster the real gangster
hasn't got Instagram but that's the
reality of you they want to become the
most Googled man in the world if I've
been running around hurting people
it's absolutely insane and I think there
has been a shift in the Consciousness I
think especially because of covet and a
few other things people are starting to
understand that all these people do as
well I think people are starting to
understand that and the harder they try
and hurt me with these lies the less
people believe it which is scary for me
like I said earlier it's scary they keep
coming up with more garbage the bullets
keep bouncing off so now they're sitting
around going we can't convince the world
this person is a bad person
how do we get rid of him
that's the scary part
June 29th I believe correct okay you put
out a tweet recently you said the six
month time limit is running out right
there's zero evidence against me unless
they invent something against me right
and then you ask a poll you said if they
charge me with an empty bullet and it
still takes a year to beat it and allows
them to save face they're hoping that
the world will basically forget about
all this what do you think they will do
and you gave people three options option
one let me go option two charge me with
no evidence option three invent and
frame attempt the results were 38 let me
go right 35 invent and frame attempt and
option two in third place charge me with
no evidence 27 38 35 27 so basically
it's it's pretty it's pretty even so
what do you think is gonna happen the
people the 38 of people who think
they're gonna let me go I think are
extremely naive I go to sleep every
night every morning I wake up and see at
5am that's when they read your house
lost in my house three times now it's
not nice to have a bunch of men with
guns bust in your house it's not a nice
experience
so every single morning I wake up
expecting them to just turn up again
with something else and drag me back to
a prison cell who knows what they'll
just make it up but the fact they made
up this particular crime is because it's
a hit piece and it's a slander on my
reputation if they would have done the
same thing let's say for tax evasion
would anyone care no oh rich guy didn't
pay a police favor no no one cares we
have to hurt his name human trafficking
think about think of
I said this to to the judge
how does it make sense a man with no
criminal record who is financially
successful decides to begin to human
traffic at 35 years of age I have no
Financial motivation it's clearly not my
personality profile I don't need money
why have I begun to human traffic from
nowhere
it doesn't even make any sense from a
pure logical perspective there's no
motive to the crime who am I human
traffic
who is the victim there's no victims and
there's no motive and here I am a
Housewives it's insane so yeah I'm it's
genuinely intimidating I don't I don't
know what's going to happen next I
believe they're going to try they're
going to try and charge me with the
garbage they have and I think what
they're trying to do is just hang it
over my head and keep me afraid
do you think of the the idea of trying
to either silence you or make you
irrelevant is working meaning do you
think you're more relevant today than
you were on September 1st is that
strategy they're implementing uh working
no they're failing and the reason
they're failing is because God's put me
in a position where I have to leave from
the front
I I think that
in the days of old when politics used to
mean something politics I believe in
politics as long as the leader of the
country charges on his horse at the
Enemy at the front then you're allowed
to be king then I'll listen to your laws
that's politics when you send other
people's kids to die in a war and you
sit on your ass that's not politics to
me but now I'm in a position where I'm
spearheading by God's plan the rights of
basically every man on Earth they could
do this to anybody so I think any man
with a brain who's thinking is looking
at my position and going it could hit me
or my friends or my son or my dad the
same way they're hitting this guy and
that that builds a degree of affinity
among smaller audience so no they failed
they failed they made a hero out of me
which is what I'm actually scared of I'm
I am scared by the incompetence of my
enemy I'm scared by the fact that they
are failing interesting so monumentally
if they have been half successful with
the cancellation none of this would have
happened if the cancellation made me an
obscure internet personality it'd be
over if I would have just allowed them
to beat me
none of this would have happened but I
beat them and that's the problem now I'm
sitting here going okay well after I
beat you to BBC after I destroyed the
BBC Tristan gave me a high five he's
like oh you wrecked they're gonna look
so stupid I said bro we've sunk the HMS
Hood HMS Hood in World War II HMS Hood
was the British Battleship as the the
flagship of the royal Navy and the Royal
Navy was obviously renowned it has been
for hundreds of years it was the best
Battleship and it was up against German
battle Crews of the Bismarck and the
hood should have outgun the Bismarck and
it was the best German ship against the
best British ship by absolute fluke the
Bismarck on its first volley or second
volley landed a shell perfectly through
the top of the hood and blew up the ammo
magazine and like in the first shot
within minutes to destroyed the entire
HMS Hood killed like I think it was like
3 000 people two survivors you can find
a video on YouTube the hood blow into
pieces when Churchill found out the hook
was sung he said sing the Bismarck don't
care what it costs
he sent every ship every plane every sub
diverted from every other Mission
doesn't care if we lose every plane we
have don't care if we lose the RAF we
cannot lose the hood without him losing
the Bismarck Sink the Bismarck when the
Bismarck sunk the hood all of the crew
were celebrating except the captain the
captain updated his will he updated his
will and telegraphed home to his wife
and said goodbye because he knew when I
destroyed the BBC my brother was
celebrating I knew I was like Tristan no
you don't beat the British Broadcasting
Corporation to make fools of them like
this without some new [__] we set
the hood and he's like oh we'll see oh
who's this Evie Evie Evie I [__] knew
it I'm winning too well I'm scared by
the incompetence of these clowns but I
don't know what else I'm supposed to do
am I supposed to lose
I'm genuinely looking for guidance here
am I supposed to roll over and [__]
lose when they're lying about me and
slandering my name and trying to put me
back in a [__] dungeon back with the
Cockroaches all I could do is protest my
innocence but they're such idiots I make
them look so stupid and then there's
egos involved you think the you think
the you think Lucy Williamson hasn't
been called into a meeting room with
some BBC producer saying you made a fool
of us yes she has there's egos involved
big big businessmen with business
interests of ego investment and hurting
me now and I keep winning so I don't
know I'm in a very precarious scenario
do I continue to win do I do I let them
win a bit do I just roll over and shut
up what am I supposed to do I don't know
what the right move is is difficult
so you sincerely don't know what the
right move is I sincerely have decided
that the best thing I can do is stay
true to my faith and stay true to God
and tell the truth and fight
the right move for me I believe is to
fight and and fight to the end because I
think that suicide is always the wrong
option I believe you're put in a bad
position the best thing you should
possibly do is fight to the best of your
ability which is what I'm going to do
however
if I was looking at it curly logically
without any kind of ideological
motivations perhaps if I would have shut
up when they wanted me to I wouldn't be
in this scenario but that's just not who
I am
you know Alexander the Great didn't have
to keep conquering Genghis Khan didn't
need to take Vienna he could have just
chilled he kept going so I feel like
when I'm in a position where I don't
know what I'm supposed to do the best
thing I can do is just look to God and
tell the truth and just and that's what
I'm doing I want to ask you one more
question regarding human trafficking
because this is a heinous charge
allegedly I mean this is not any this is
not lightweight stuff
you famously ran a webcam business right
perfectly legal nothing wrong with that
I mean I can't tell you how many women
are doing only fans these days webcam
business how much of a reason was that a
correlation for the human trafficking
the sex trafficking the webcam business
how much did they correlate yeah well he
must be human trafficking he's running a
webcam business there's no correlation
zero correlation so they haven't charge
any of the webcam business or any of
this zero and what's crazy it's crazy
because people assume that right it's
crazy because one it's not illegal and
two you can go drive down the High
Street of Romania there's webcam Studios
on it's one of the most popular
businesses in in the country it's not
even legal and and that was a past life
you're talking about something that
happened 10 years ago it was that long
ago it was about 10 years ago yeah it
was at the very beginning of it the very
beginning of the whole idea of this that
industry my neck is an application which
allows you to take a minute to connect
with influencers from all around the
world my name is Andrew Tate and I'm
available to speak directly to you on
minute I think it's just perception I
understand I have this perception and I
think a lot of people who are also
dislike me a lot of the reason they
dislike me so much is my perception I've
had people who say I hate what you say
say what do I say and after talking to
them a while they say it's not what you
say it's how you say it of course it's
the perception of aggression the is the
perception of masculinity that they're
afraid of it's not even the words they
might like the words it's my delivery so
I understand perception can be reality
to a degree I accepted that maybe the
first month I was in jail I understand
when you have a message which is
complicated and masculinity as a whole
is a very complicated tapestry that the
best way to instill it and teach it is
to break it down to its three chord we
break it down to its core beliefs so
I've evolved Way Beyond Lamborghinis and
chicks right but masculinity as a whole
is a very complicated tapestry you need
to have the emotionality you need to
have the times you feel like crying and
you don't you need to have the times you
can be aggressive you have the times
that you can be violent to protect your
family it's very complicated and you
can't teach that especially to the Young
Generation in in in spite of the
constant propaganda they have coming in
their ears very easily so I break it
down to a very core message and the core
message is that I have Financial Freedom
so it's hard to tell me what to do and I
have sexual access because I'm respected
by women and I have a good Network
because I'm respected by men I break it
down to those core things and those core
things are what I build my that's how
you build the tapestry of masculinity
because if you don't have those three
core things you can never build the rest
of it that's the beginning of it do not
have those three things it's hard to
build the rest so anybody who doesn't
look into my message properly I mean I'm
sure these people who are after me have
never listened to me speak at like ever
ever they just look at a picture he's on
a boat there's three girls on the boat
there's no way those girls are happy
with that because my wife hates me and
there's three of them so he so he has to
go to jail and that's what's happening
this is that Baseline I truly believe
it's that Baseline but how else can I
teach my message as complicated as it is
without first breaking down and proving
you have success in the most core levels
of it right before you learn to box you
jab and you cross before you do all the
complicated stuff you do the basic stuff
so a lot of it is people looking at my
message not understanding how detailed
it is not understanding how positive it
is looking at the Baseline instincts
which I teach in which I use to
advertise my success as a whole to
people to show and say look I clearly
know what I'm talking about to a degree
because I have things that you want and
you're a man so you can't tell me you
don't want them every man wants this
every man wants one of these
and they take all this and they try to
weaponize it and use it against me and
you're right it's it's feminism as a
whole that has this idea that if a man
is a man unapologetically and he doesn't
apologize for being a man that he's a
bad person which we've discussed at
length and I've discussed a bunch of
times but it's truly the most crazy
thing about all of this is when [__]
hits the fan it's exactly the kind of
men they hate that they want every
single time every single time you can go
out to a bar in America and you can
stand there and argue with a feminist
and argue with her to the end of time
and if someone ran in there with a gun
she would say hey you you go you're the
misogynist you
just you the feminist guy who's on my
team I don't want him to go I want you
to go please we don't want Dylan
Mulvaney on the front line of course not
and and it's hypocritical and it's
hypocritical and it's done on purpose
it's purported by the Matrix it is done
to attack the Baseline masculinity of
men because they don't want men to be
masculine because when you're masculine
you say no to things I saw a really
interesting study once that was tested
it had testosterone level and it was
linked to your capability to disagree
with people the higher testosterone
level the more likely you are to
disagree because at a baseline level
back before we were more civilized than
we are today if you disagreed with
someone you had to fight him interested
you have to fight that man for you to
sit and say you are wrong there had to
be a possibility of violence if you
didn't have the capability for violence
you didn't say they're not real you
didn't say they were wrong you just
agreed with stuff right so they don't
want men who are standing up and saying
I don't believe in ex they want to
reduce to reduce our testosterone levels
to our units so that we sit and say well
I may not agree with it but what can I
really do about it is what it is and
then they have absolute control do you
think history favors that ideology or
history eventually a group of men stand
up and say yeah listen we've had enough
this is not going to be happening I I do
believe that in history it's always been
the same I believe it's always been a
select group of good men who are up
against evil and I think they've always
been outnumbered and it's always been
difficult and they've always suffered
all of them
when I was in jail they're not letters I
got from people and it was just names of
and I'm not comparing myself to these
people this is the letters I got of
Nelson Mandela Martin Luther King
Malcolm X Muhammad Ali everyone who was
unjustly imprisoned everyone's gone to
jail because when you stand up for
something they end up trying to put you
in jail when you're a good person trying
to do good the evil The Matrix as a
whole is going to try and throw you in
jail that's what they do that's the
punishment for it and history has always
been the same it's always been a small
group of outgunned people who stand up
who are to the detriment of themselves
to principle to allow Injustice and evil
to thrive and they stand up and they're
outgunned and they're outnumbered but
they're like no I have to tell the truth
if you play a video game and you're the
good guy when you get to the boss at the
end he has more life than you he has
more hit points and he moves faster and
he's a cheater He Cheats
the Bad Guy cheats
because you're good and that's how
that's how the battle's always been I
would love for the world to be another
way but I don't think it's ever been
that way I think if you find any time in
history it's always been the same story
and now I'm in the position where like I
said earlier what am I supposed to do am
I have I do I have a life path in which
I can genuinely help people and do I
have a life path in which I can
genuinely do some damage to the evil to
the world or am I just going to
disappear like a coward and let them lie
about me and do my time and shut up and
delete my Twitter account and just go
away you know you know how sometimes
like uh uh uh I've been in sales for
quite a while if a guy who doesn't have
any responsibilities any single he has a
30 000 a month but only he's going to
Vegas having a good time and then he
doesn't work as hard until he runs out
of his thirty thousand three months a
day I gotta go make the thirty thousand
again oh my God panic I got to pay my
bills I'm beyond on the phone let me buy
this watch and make 40 Grand I'm going
out again so it's very inconsistent
right and then as you're in sales longer
you're like okay the profile of somebody
that's going to be more consistent is
not a single guy it's a guy that's
married kids homeowner and all those
three are signs of what married
commitment home owner commitment
responsibility kids commitment
responsibility last time we didn't talk
about your kids at this point I think
it's public video your daughter running
to me give Daddy your kiss all this
stuff everybody knows at this point do
you when you're in in jail sometimes I I
sit there and I got books on my desk I'm
like I'm like 50 books behind and I like
to read I know you don't talk about
reading a lot but I like to I'm like I'm
50 books behind but I bet if you're in a
place where you're in jail you're forced
to think you're forced to Andrew you
don't have the phone you don't have a
computer there is no emergency podcast
go away and think you're sitting there
like okay
family kids you know what it's really
all about
those decisions decisions when you think
about your kids
does it influence you to say what are
you doing this you know why are you why
are you going through all this stuff
maybe you got to make some changes in in
your lifestyle yeah and if yes in what
areas or does it say no double down even
more because I'm fighting for them and
that's a really interesting question
I'll start by saying how thoughts in
jail are different than thoughts in the
outside world because this is actually
an observation I had
in the outside world I don't think you
carry a thought for very long that you
don't want to carry you can sit and
think about something if you want to but
if you don't want to think about
something you just get your phone down
some pumps in your head oh I don't get
fun on distract yourself or you get your
laptop or you call someone or you do
something right it's not very often in
the real good point you have a thought
you don't want in your head and you have
nothing to take it away you have no
phone you have no outside interaction
you have nowhere to go what a
perspective you're just stuck yeah
you're stuck with that
so there were times in jail where for
the first time like I have a lot of
mental control but there was the first
time ever I'm battling with my own mind
saying I don't want to think about this
and I I put another thought in the way
it kept it was on the door it was
knocking on the door all the time and
this is for weeks because there's no it
never every day is the same you never
get the inter-outside interaction and
you also what made it worse is you never
get the answer you know like the open
loop if you ever say to somebody I'm
gonna tell you something I'll tell you
later and it bothers her that's what
Jail's like because you might think of
something
doesn't matter what it is I won't say
what my thought was but I'll give you an
example let's say I thought when did
Constantinople fall what year
I can't just Google it I don't know so
it's stuck in your head right so if you
have this negative fault you don't know
the answer normally in life when you
want to know something you find out
but in jail you're done so you're like I
don't know you go this in your head and
you're like I can't get this out my head
so when you have a negative thought yeah
especially if there's an open loop to it
you need to know something or you want
to know something you can't get it out
of your mind I would sit there for hours
just meditate and trying to just keep
the door closed on negative thoughts
it's really difficult it's a really
strange experience and maybe in normal
jail in Western countries where you get
to go and interact with people you can
distract yourself but I was stuck in a
room for 93 days in one room I did not
leave that was where I was I was allowed
to go to the fridge once a day which is
a three meter walk and back that is it
you and Tristan are in the same room or
no at the beginning we weren't but then
we ended up in the same ricotta yeah
so
yeah the thought
are very pervasive and it's also
maybe never maybe never in the outside
world where I had a thought in my head
for weeks and weeks and weeks and you
just satisfy the problem you fixed the
issue in the real world in jail you
can't do that
so yeah family and kids and those are
the positive things that you do think
about
but
it's difficult because I think of
children I think of legacy
and then if you're going to think of
your legacy why are your children you
have to think of your Legacy by your
actions
and then you have to sit and by
extension go well truly truly on my
deathbed truly will I be happier if I
gave up well if I continue to tell the
truth
I'm scared of the regret of thinking you
know what I was the most famous man in
the world and every man on Earth was
listening to me and I was really making
a difference but I got scared I don't
think I can live for that I don't think
I can live as a coward I don't I feel
I'd feel like a person I just feel like
a whim and sometimes inside of men
that's all it takes for us to do the
most
stupid things there is the idea of
feeling like a coward a man will run
into a burning building to not be a
coward if the firefighter they go
there's children in there and the whole
building's on fire it's like well I
can't be a coward I'll [__] it and
you'll risk your life it's something
that's built inside of us honor and
pride it's something that should be it's
what they're trying to take away from us
but it's what used to be built inside of
men and I just feel like
I can't give up I know what I'm doing is
good I know what I'm teaching is good I
know the people don't like it but I know
I'm not teaching anything that's bad
and yeah I want my children to be happy
but I have daughters too and how do you
make sure that your daughters are secure
and have a good future well I think you
do that by building good men
how else do you do it my daughter is
mine now but she won't be mine forever
she's going to marry somebody I like the
idea of her marrying a good man with
honor and principle a man like me I
don't want to marry some idiot so they
call me a misogynist I said I'm
anti-woman I'm pro-woman the best way
you can improve the lives of women is
make men better men better at being men
because when a man is a good man he's
good for all of society including women
he's good for everyone around him when
he's good at being a man
so I feel like I'm helping them as well
by extension
and it's difficult and yeah I I I I
can't say with honesty that I strongly
considered giving up it never crossed my
mind it was there for a second do I need
to do this and after like half a second
it was again I do I don't know why I
can't it doesn't make logical sense so
kids didn't influence it one way or
another kids made me want to do it
I look up to my father as a hero and I
would hate for my sons to look up at me
and not see me as a hero because that's
how I believe you should see your dad as
a hero and I feel like and you're not a
hero without an enemy
you're not here over that fight did they
ever try to and by the way I don't see
this working effectively at all but did
they at all try to come in between you
and Tristan or you and the two girls or
the two of you and them was there any
manipulation and divisive divisiveness
going on there what about these stories
that came out that you've got cancer and
lung cancer and then you were poisoned
and these Matrix attacks yeah so they
keep planting these stories or they're
making these things up so the cancer
thing is interesting because by Romanian
law every 30 days to extend the arrest
there has to be new information they
can't extend the arrest based on the
previous information so they put
together all this garbage case and
arrested me for 30 days to keep me
another 30 days they have to find
something during that 30-day arrest
period to keep me for the second month
but of course there's nothing to find so
when I was having uh medical scans in
Dubai a scar a dark spot was identified
on my lung and I had follow-up tests
booked for February so when after the
first 30 days I called up my PA and she
said are you coming to Dubai I said Well
yeah if they let me go at the end of
these 30 days I'll come to Dubai for my
medical tests they took that
conversation and shown it and used it in
court saying I'm trying to flee the
country and trying to escape the
judicial system as motivation for the
second month's arrest and the judge
agreed and locked me in jail because I
said I would go to a medical appointment
if I was free
and they use that as proof I'm trying to
run
because they had nothing else and the
judge agreed it for some reason kept me
in jail
then everything would remain Elites so
it leaked that I had this medical thing
in Dubai I had a problem with my lungs
and then there's a hospital here and I
decided to go to the hospital here and
have it looked at because although I was
not concerned I thought you know what
although it's difficult to do procedures
in jail I have time
for once in my life
so I decided to go to the hospital here
in Romania and Romania does have some
Private health care which is actually
very high quality it's not as poor as
people think it is and I went to a
private Hospital
and I knew it wasn't cancer I knew it
wasn't I sat down the doctor and said
we're really concerned about this dark
spot in your lung I said it's not cancer
so how do you know I said that's just
not my life path
it's not my story you told him that yeah
the doctor was like okay but we have to
investigate let me investigate but it's
just not my story it's not cancer at
zero percent when BBC came did you have
guys like watching every move they were
making you had to almost put like
one-on-one right somebody's watching
everything they're doing everything you
have to do it like you can't be you have
to be overly paranoid and skeptical they
want to hear about you know Ricky Tang's
crime Lord do they want to hear more
about the crime syndicate in Hong Kong I
could tell them all about it because
Carter Lee's gonna get under control
but um yeah I I mean this is the things
this is actually really interesting
point which I'll go into before I finish
the long story so I went to the doctors
here in Romania everything leaks it
leaked out to the Press I had this mark
on my lungs I was supposed to go Dubai
they did not even going to Dubai they
said that's enough reason to hold me and
keep me in jail which is absolutely
insane all because I also had a phone
call about a medical procedure it's
crazy but they were always going to keep
me anyway and find some reason
I went there I had a bronchiocopy have
you ever had one of them
bro
I wouldn't call it painful but it's
certainly horrible so they put a camera
in your lung so it's not that it's down
your throat but it's in your lung it's
not down the throat it's into the airway
so you're trying to vomit and you're
trying to cough and you can barely do
either and they're moving this camera
around inside it's extremely unpleasant
even if it sucks I had three years ago
in Dallas for the whole allergy thing
yeah they have to knock you out it's
terrible yeah
yeah it was they gave me this uh uh they
tried to numb your throat a bit and then
they gave it to me and the doctor was
all around me it's kind of interesting
because when something is in your mouth
and you're choking you want to grab it
right so you're on a chair and you're
chained like you're like tied to the
chair so you can't move your hands so
you're like tied to the chair and you're
like this and they put this thing down
your throat this camera and you're
trying to vomit and you're trying to
cough but they can't move the camera
when you're coughing so even the guard
the armed guard who took me the police
officer the guy he was in the corner of
the room and he was like I could see on
his face he was like [__] hell and
I've I don't even want to reenact it
because it's probably so horrible to
look at but you're you're just like like
you're trying to vomit you're trying to
cough you're like your face is bright
red you can't breathe and they're like
stop golfing stop coughing stop coughing
and you have to try and stop coughing
for like two seconds so they can adjust
the camera a bit it's the worst 20
minutes of my life was horrible they
finished that and they go okay well the
good news is there's precisely zero
smoking damage on your lungs and your
lungs are perfect
but the lesion whatever it is is on the
outside of your lungs it's not on the
inside of your lungs you couldn't see
anything
so I completed that procedure went back
to jail that was a nice evening
um horrible anyone has a bronchioscope
yeah go to sleep don't stay awake
horrible
um then they said we have to find it we
have to put we have to get a biopsy from
the outside of your lungs so we have to
put a needle through your back a needle
like this long through your back through
your rib cage
to your lung a CT guided biopsy it's
called and take a piece of it and then
pull the needle back out and then do a
biopsy on the piece now they're like
this is an operation do you want to have
it while you're in jail because the
bronchioscopy wasn't much to recovered
from I had a really sore throat whatever
but this is an operation do you want to
have it while you're in jail and I was
like well why not I'm in jail I have
time I can't recover but I have time
so I went for my CT guided biopsy they
put you on your front they get they show
you the needle it's like this long and
then they they stick it in you and then
they scan you with the biopsy and they
try and see what the Mark is and they
adjust the needle and they scan it it's
like 30 minutes of them shoving this
needle and you're trying to get to the
right point
and eventually they uh did it did the
biopsy and they said uh yeah it's it's
benign some lesion on my pad from when I
had pneumonia when I was a kid or
something I said I told you I knew that
cancer wasn't my life path I knew it
wasn't but obviously rumors spread like
wildfire wildfire wild everybody in the
state especially because especially
because I smoke all the time right but
it was actually very refreshing to hear
I have zero smoking damage on my lungs
zero I was like there's zero
I mean I'll accept a little bit I'll
take a little bit but I think it's
because I train every single day I work
out every single day I train hard every
single day I think you know you burn it
off a couple cigars here and there are
not big deal it's not cigarettes I think
cigars are better than cigarettes I also
believe nicotine is a super drug so I'm
not gonna stop I think nicotine super
drug 100 what does that mean nicotine
and caffeine are what I run on
hundreds of hundreds all I run on
coffees for closers bro
you're the only one that drinks coffee
the two of us oh really by the way you
know who uh who talked about nicotine
Tucker Carlson talk about nicotine right
have you seen that when he talks about
nicotine where he starts his days off
his day off with nicotino fire 100 fire
blood
and I only eat once a day and it's funny
because people look at 215 cups of
coffee a day minimum
but you don't do drugs zero drugs you'll
do you'll have a sip of alcohol every
once in a while I used to I haven't had
alcohol in nine months I've quit but
you're running on caffeine and nicotine
it's funny because people look at my
physique when I put pictures up and
they're like What's your meal plan I'm
like bro cigars coffee coffee
cigars I eat once a day I eat once a day
one time I eat dinner only that's it
only dinner and eat so you do
intermittent fasting for every 18 hours
what yeah and 80 to 90 of my calories
are me that's it I almost have like
three steaks for dinner obviously now
how much of that is genetics how much is
that like I'm not sure if it's genetics
but that's just how I feel best I feel
best when if I if I smoke and drink
coffee all the time I feel hungry which
motivates me and I feel energetic it's
energetic hungry that's how I like to
feel when I'm working I want to be
hungry if I eat I'm just tired life's
too good if I eat I'm in my Mansion I've
just eaten she's beautiful a little bit
yeah but if I don't eat I'm like maybe I
wouldn't say angry but I like to have
that tinge of
irritableness does that make sense I
don't know maybe I sound crazy it's how
I get things done it's how I get life
done this is
three cigars and you eat once a day
that's right yeah and you train every
day I train every day and it's working
working for you it's how I feel best I
don't know if I if you wrote a book on
uh Tate's diet if that book well I had I
had well this is interesting because I
had a blood test when I was in hospital
for all these things and my testosterone
level I'm not going to pretend to be an
expert on male hormones because I'm not
I don't understand them I don't know
what measurement it's in but it's
between 9 and 27 is the testerone the
testosterone level The Marked between 9
and 27 the normal range I've never taken
a steroid in my life I don't inject
anything I don't take any pills nothing
and I was 32. I was above the normal
scale and I'm 36 years old supposed to
be going down so whatever I'm doing I'm
sticking to it what was your diet and
your regimen while in jail there was no
selfie oh I had coffee and cigarettes
don't worry bro I had those really I
spent my commissary money on coffee and
cigarettes like coffee and cigarettes
and one meal a day same so there was
commissary money yeah so we had to give
you that yeah so uh a friend of mine put
money on my account so I was a rich guy
in jail because in Romanian jail most
people haven't got money right okay I
was rich there's a limit to how much you
can buy but I was spending the maximum
so I had plenty of cigarettes coffee I
actually quit coffee but now we're
talking about coffee and then I want to
go back to the appointment earlier but
I quit coffee for the first 30 days in
jail because I've never I've never not
been caffeinated my experience of life
is Catholicism right I'm awake it's
Kathy so I'm like I don't need energy
now I'm in jail so I quit caffeine and
all coffee for 30 days to see if there's
any tangible benefits and I can confirm
to the world that there are not
syrup I did not sleep any better I did
not go to sleep any easier I did not
dream anymore nothing absolutely nothing
good happened except I was tired all day
it was garbage I was like give me my
coffee back I went back to about 15
coffee cups of coffee a day that
reaffirmed your call to have that much
coffee the last time I drank coffee was
25. we have one friend literally we have
one friend that drinks almost as much
everybody Romney loves coffee yeah
including my 11 year old son Tico him
and his mom got into an argument the
other day because she didn't want to
take him to Starbucks he said what do
you mean it's like I want some coffee
said you're not having coffee yeah at 11
years old anyways but it's working for
you it's working for your body sometimes
when you when you find a diet or a
combination that that hits your body
well you'll know it you'll feel it and
you have to know your body the best
correct I think there's no perfect diet
for everybody I agree slightly different
I agree and that's just and and I think
you are what you eat to a degree and
also depends the mental model you want
to operate under some if I want to
operate under Comfort I certainly
wouldn't eat the way I eat I do it
because I particularly want to operate
under a degree of irritability and high
energy and hunger I like feeling hungry
I don't like feeling full I like being
hungry I I love that I mean that's
that's the quality of people where you
know you can you can tell a lot from
somebody how big they think after they
make money and they have some success
when they make money that's when they
slow down that's when they get casual
the hunger goes away you'll really know
if somebody is hungry when they made
money and they're still going what is
this guy doing still going yeah you've
already made the money you've already
had the success let's transition to a
couple other stories here so all of a
sudden you put in your profile obviously
I joked about it you're the most Googled
woman on Earth you know that was based
on your Twitter profile you know Nina
Turner comes out and says if somebody
says they're a woman they're a woman not
a tough concept your response is I'm a
women right you do that and you've left
it on Twitter
tell us why because I am
you don't believe me you're a woman are
you misgendering me I have to choose
that you choose to agree with you right
my pronouns are she her
no but the level of
it's all a joke right but there's
actually a very Sinister undertone to
all of this garbage and the Sinister
undertone is that your Baseline
instincts and your Baseline senses are
how you've always perceived the world
right they have to attack them at some
level and they did I mean it's fantastic
with covet kovid I know we can talk
about it now it was amazing I used to
say to people all the time who have you
seen die
do you see a pandemic yeah on the news
no no no do you see ambulances rushing
back and forth everywhere do you see
bodies on the street do you see lines
outside of hospitals do you see a
pandemic how a pandemic would look do
you see a pandemic oh but my grandma my
friend's grandma your friend's grandma
was 96. okay so I'm all saying it's not
sad I'm saying she was 96. do you see a
pandemic no you don't but they have just
lied to you so many times that you're
ignoring your own eyes that's the final
stage of the slave mind it's the final
savior the final stage of the slave mind
is when your eyes tell you this is green
but the news told you it was blue
so it has to be blue so when they're
doing these things there's nothing to do
with caring about the mental health of
gender ideology none of this garbage
they're deliberately attacking saying
what your eyes tell you is wrong
because if they can make you start to
admit that your own eyes are wrong then
what what other defense do you have
against propaganda
if they're going to give you a lie but
your own eyes can't protect you well
then it's over isn't it so all of these
things they're doing all of these things
are a deliberate assault on the senses
and they do it by controlling the
language if if you control what someone
says over time you'll control what they
think you don't think what you don't say
it's very hard to live a life for eight
years if you're lucky and think things
and never say them ever if you think it
you're going to say it sometimes you're
going to give the idea get some feedback
on the idea build on the idea change the
idea whatever it is through discussion
if you never ever ever discuss it you're
not going to think it so they say this
is the truth ignore your eyes and you
have to say it's the truth you can't say
it's not the truth and the people are in
charge of the world they think
generationally they have time right now
it's a joke 200 years from now won't be
a joke
to introduce and that will all be
[__] standard operating protocol the
grandchildren the people who are in
charge now that that's what they want
they'll pull it off in the end slow
incremental damage they'll take they do
with nearly everything so take all your
rights away take 100 of your rights away
they'll upset you they give you 99 back
we're good again don't worry and they're
the grandchildren the people in charge
of the world get what they want in the
end they think generationally so now
we're at the beginning of it it's all a
big joke right but especially before
Elon had Twitter when you couldn't say
the truth online when you couldn't say
my I see X on the internet without going
to jail or losing your account or
getting a hate speech charge in the UK
or some garbage they're controlling what
you think
and on a long enough time frame what you
think becomes true if two we all believe
two plus two is four but with a hard
enough Scio if you can't say that if you
have to say it's five on a long enough
time frame math breaks down and
everyone's just gonna believe that two
plus two equals five that's what happens
you think we're gonna get there okay
this is why I'll say I'm sometimes it's
hard because that's conservative we
always bring up the stats and the facts
however people will manipulate like
they'll you have these leftists like
wokies that do these like studies that
makes no sense that'll say the sky is
red
you know or up is down or whatever so
sometimes I'm like studies are good if
they're done the right way but it's like
it's hard because even like the Matrix
or the woke people they've infiltrated
universities where you have these like
gender studies Professor professors
saying like men doing chores is Sexy For
example
that's a crazy thing so I I got in
trouble
um because again like I did that I had
that video where I said that like you
shouldn't get divorced over chores and
like the the left people were saying oh
you don't cite studies well and here's
our study that's the super correct study
that says that men um like women find
chores to be sex something like that I
don't remember what it was and so what I
did was I looked into their study and
like the person that did it was a gender
studies Professor yeah you haven't said
that is a lie because a man doing chores
is going to give me the ick
basically what I'm trying to say is most
women don't find that attractive at all
I don't know who lied and said that but
that's the thing oh I find it attractive
you need to do chores as much as I'm
doing chores it's just a normal one but
the whole the whole majority of women
the whole point is like I see what he's
saying it's like that they they lie to
you through the media and you can't even
say that like water is wet the sky is
Blue's four yeah and they just keep even
even during this conversation there was
stuff that you guys thought was true
that wasn't and I I didn't like you guys
were just me two years ago you know what
I mean before I really started
researching this stuff yeah you know
what it is I think people sometimes kind
of think that the West because it's the
the Victor in so many wars that the West
is is clean it's an angel they run the
psychologically Superior yeah
ideologically Superior they run the same
propaganda campaigns but much more
um intricately that people don't even
realize Hollywood massive campaign for
propaganda mainstream music campaign for
propaganda listen to the message you
listen to the visual messages that they
sent and everything is surrounding again
sex everything is surrounding uh all of
this kind of like gender women or women
being the victim do you know what I
noticed there's such a theme of like all
the stars and you see how the female
artists their lives turn out and I'm not
even talking about the cardi B's I'm
talking about the Taylor Swift's the
dummy lovados and the Camellia Cara
Camila Cabello that chick and then now
there's a new one the blonde country
artist any listen to Country I met
someone new last night you know the song
no no okay okay but but it's like it's
the same pattern where these women like
well date guy after guy after guy get
their heart broken that's all they write
about they put it on the internet and
it's like they die alone they don't have
that with anyone it goes back to what
you said about you know nowadays you can
just make up any facts you know
um recently they came come up with a
study showing that pedophilia is
actually a mental issue and people are
born pedophiles and I'm telling you I'm
literally predicting this in the future
they're going to use that what's that
Philip guy
the way they were so sensitive towards
him in the in the interview I think
that's going to be the start of this
whole pedophilia is actually a mental
state and not actually you know
something even record that's gonna
unpredictable of course and brown and BG
said it first because they're
sexualizing children everything like you
walk around you see little girls wearing
batty Riders battery is a really short
short or crop top so you see little kids
listening to what by cardi B you've seen
you see kids twerking and putting their
tongue out for videos because that's
what they're watching people do nowadays
girls are becoming more sexualized
younger and younger I work in the West
in the way and that's the problem this
ideology ideologically Superior play is
that realistically now you're you've
just gone too far the Greed for you know
you know that a lot of that stuff is
like legally banned in China
yeah and it's it may not be legally
banned in certain places in Africa
because these traditionally culturally
from the pond that it doesn't even
happen it's like what are you doing
common sense you get beat by your
neighbor if you're moving nuts anyway do
you know what I mean yeah so yeah no I
think this is a problem that definitely
we're finding in the west and I think I
mean for the fact that you have to kind
of disclose or they ask you to disclose
your sexual orientation on a job
application for me it's an absolute
mind-blowing yeah they ask so what is
your social orientation but you can put
like you don't want to say yeah but I'm
just saying for the fact that they even
are there's a girl that came on the show
that said she was indoctrinated to be
gay I believe it yeah she said she dated
a girl for two years in high school and
then realized she was straight yeah
because they talk about it too dude Bill
Maher did that huge piece when he said
like 20 of the Zoomers are now saying
they're gay but gay is the new goth like
when we had the golf kids yeah and
you're like oh you know like no there's
Billy he likes Marilyn Manson and his
dad just doesn't love him and is that
lashing out like this now these people
like oh yeah I'm trans
especially for women because it's
immediately you get like women we we
need attention to survive like we cannot
live without male attention and so and
so it's like if you you automatically if
you say you're gay you get all this
attention like that's the incentive
structure you know I've been saying this
for the longest I think this whole gay
and transgender thing is coming from a
place of wanting attention yeah of
course I think of the thing where
they're actually suffering on the inside
because it's just one attention think
about it because maybe they like how
deep is a pronoun it's not deep at all I
can call you it I can call you by your
name I can call you oi I can call you
babe the pronoun doesn't matter this is
again is it that call for attention that
any tiny little thing is a way for you
to kind of be outraged and then people
have to appease you and you know come to
your rescue came or come to you know
make sure that you're okay it's very
very much an attention driven sort of
thing and I think that it's a massive
problem that people are kind of taking
that very seriously and allowing
children to think about gender identity
and sexualization when they've never
even had sex they don't know what it
means what do you know about being gay
like who are you yeah when you know when
I was a kid like the only thing I wanted
to do was like climb trees and eat
Cheetos tell me about kissing your boy
I'll be like ew that's disgusting yeah
no I want a Super Soaker that's what I
wanted yeah do you think it's just an
attention seeking thing for just for
kids or for everyone like well yeah
everyone majority literally I feel like
is just a tendency I'll tell you my
controversial opinion I don't think
anyone's born gay no one
but Lady Gaga said you're born this way
no I don't I don't think so I think it
says I think most of the people I know a
lot of times especially the guys they
had like an older like they were
assaulted like as a kid yeah and the
other thing yeah Fascination
or a lot of times like the guys were
raised by a single mother like I think
there was something wrong at home or
maybe at school there's a theory that
like a lot of these guys are grown
without a father and so they sexualize
that love that they want for a man from
a father you know does it make sense to
you I wonder if all guys could get laid
by women like if some guys you know they
become gay in jail like if some guys do
because they can't get women so they
just and I have a theory about women
that they become gay in their like early
30s to late 20s because they can't get
the guys they used to be able to get
often after they gained weight or just
aged so it's like they're they're about
to hit 30 they're like oh [__] I'm not
as hot as I was 10 years ago I can't get
the guys I used to get and now not like
they settle for a woman because they'd
rather be with a woman than a beta
isn't it ease of access to to sex for
men turning gay oh my God you got sex on
tap because men are ready so if you go
on Grinder like I've got some friends
the stories they tell me about grinding
I'm like wow okay so it's it's mad and
then when it comes to lesbianism as well
especially nowadays it's like it's it's
something that is supposed to be so sexy
like you see girls rubbing up against
each other not only that as well there's
a lot of women that aren't in that
situation where they need companionship
so you go for another woman he's like
sisters that do naughty things together
and I think that's so confusing about
lesbians is that they will get with the
masculine women like a woman that acts
like a man why don't you just get a man
yeah I do not get they will literally
get with this full-on because I I really
think they'd rather be with a chick than
be with a like a guy they don't write
like a family like a feminine dude it's
like a lot of this explosive to us a lot
of things too I've noticing this is my
personal bias but a lot of the girls
that I've met that are like lesbians
they usually got done pretty bad by a
guy like super traumatized super really
bad breakup or heartbreak and they just
so they go to the complete opposite side
of the Spectrum which is like I'm just
only gonna date women now because I was
so damaged and traumatized by this kind
of apparently lesbian relationships are
really tough apparently they have the
highest levels of domestic violence bro
if I tell you some of the situations
that I've been in where I'm sitting
there and I'm me I'm quite a bit of a
boyish girl and I'm sitting there with a
couple and girls and I'm thinking my
Lord
this I thought we were bad but let us
get into a relationship with each other
it's even worse that the bitchiness
there's always a certain attitude where
one has to kind of try and prove that
she's the one that holds it down it's
kind of it doesn't really quite make
sense to me I'm not gonna lie no offense
girls do whatever you want if that's
what you're on fine but for me it
doesn't make sense and you know what's
even crazier what annoys me the most
that people are so obsessed with it that
every other day I have a boy or a girl
either asking me if I'm bi or Girl
moving to me and I'm like bro stay away
from me you know I know that's what they
accuse me of they're like oh she's a
lesbian like she she like and that's
like they'll call me a pick me and a
lesbian I'm like which one
call me they'll say my dad pays for
everything and then say I'm doing it for
money I'm like which one
sometimes the whole lesbian things
people actually make you start believing
that you're lesbian when you're not it's
like a lot of girls I don't want this to
sound offensive but it's like a lot of
girls just want to do something fun with
them let's say you're drunk with your
girls yeah outside and you do something
fun yeah and then someone in Seasons be
like oh my God you're a lesbian but it
just happened one time you're just
having fun for some people and then
people just go and say oh you like girls
because you've done it one time no that
does not make you gay but then it says
so much they say so much that you just
say I'm full-on lesbian do you know it's
almost like women are easily manipulated
and propagated
you just start to think in my head maybe
I like girls maybe I feel like we go
yeah I really think we could believe
anything like well I mean look at it
like look look at what China pulled off
with the whole cough situation oh yeah
you had people like when they were
trying to tell me people are trying to
tell me like you should take shot I was
just like so wait a minute you're trying
to rationalize with me that if I get
this cough there's a 99 chance and I'm
gonna be okay but if I take that shot I
saw one girl become [__] from taking
that shot that was enough for me to be
like I will I will risk getting this
cough and you have all these people
losing their mind you know what's crazy
too the number one people that were
enforcing it that you see going crazy
online were these women like how dare
you not take the shot are you a racist
are you a sexist are you homophobic they
would go down the the list of slandering
shame terms you know I've seen them I've
seen all types women all colors all
sizes like shaming people for not
getting this experimental shot that has
literally made chicks [__] you know
curious how [__] did the girl get
like it's sad like honestly I make jokes
about it but her username on Instagram
is Queen City Dom she's a beautiful girl
objectively stunning and she took it and
she like to this day is still having
seizures and like no her nervous system
is shutting down and she's having a very
very very tough time and my heart goes
out to that lady but I've seen him and
then you know they've been they were
they were censoring all this information
you know the the Bears the b-a-e-r-s the
vaccine adverse effects report
um that thing is through the roof and I
think right now
six hundred thousand people are dying
per year in America due to side effects
from that thing so if they could do that
how can they cannot convince two girls
to make out she's so easy question for
everyone I got I got so lucky with that
because no I actually I took it yeah
because of sports right you forced you
well I wanted to play in a game and I
was like I'll just take it because
everyone was fine I thought so like it
had been a year and I was like ah it's
it's worse because I was so close to the
end to not but I got lucky like nothing
happened to me you just took one what
just took one the first shot but it was
like two shots in one okay okay so I
don't know I was fine but my ex he had
like cold sweats he was I really bad
overnight and everything I think young
men are like more likely to get side
effects and my sister got blood clots
yeah my dad got blood clots was actually
a really big thing yeah mainly younger
people she she was quite bad I have a
question for everyone in here I feel
like okay so what do you think these
Elites or these Matrix are going to gain
out of crushing Society sheep the
population yeah depopulation because
we're easier to control and less numbers
because the reality is if we all
unifyingly woke up and were like
let's charge the White House they
couldn't stop us you know or let's
charge whatever the White House here is
in UK
like they couldn't stop us but
um they just want us dead they want they
want a population reduced you know
there's writings admitting to this like
this is a lot of the history of feminism
like they wanted to split up the family
like that was their goal and they said
this they wanted women to go into the
workforce so they could split up the
family it's like in their early writings
like another thing a lot of policies are
pushing towards depopulation like for
example abortion yeah did you know um
the founder of so do you know Planned
Parenthood is in the U.S yep so it's
like the number one abortion clinic in
the United States and the the founder
Margaret Sanger was a devout she was a
racist yeah and she stated um she had
the n-word project and like this was a
project and it was literally to reduce
the population of black people in the
United States and now in New York there
are more black babies aborted than born
and and it worked because
um a hundred years later the black
population has decreased by two percent
despite having more children like before
yes and like the the rate of abortion
America is really high I think the
Americans have I think the Russian
people have the number one amount of
abortions real in Russia no way I'm
pretty sure it's Russia wow Russia and
then number two is America and then
number three is China number three is
China that means China has a billion
plus people in their country and
American women are out aborting them
in America now but but it's so crazy how
nobody even like Planned Parenthood is
so like women were marching to keep
Planned Parenthood a racist organization
that literally stated that they wanted
to depopulate the black community and is
doing that because 80 of their locations
are in black neighborhoods so it's like
they're literally doing it and the crazy
thing is we'll protest to get these
staff she's taken down they'll protest
and say all these other people are
racist but they don't even talk about
like this huge organization that's
literally depopulated ignorance I have a
question for everyone because me I like
to look at two sides of everything do
you guys feel like depopulation would be
a good thing for this F or a bad thing
good thing I I don't I I'll just say
this I said this to my friend the other
day I don't think we're overpopulated as
a nation or as a as a as a community as
a as a human species I think we're
undereducated I think because this
stupid people are the ones really
ruining the planet and the elites are
just like how do we get rid of these
stupid people ah let's tricked him in
taking this kind of [__] thing
that'll kill him in five to seven years
you know
um we can't go in too much depth about
it here because we got to keep the
channel running but like
um I I just think that because here's
the thing the way things are set up
right now is absolutely eroding and
destroying the planet there's
irrefutable right and the only way you
could really stop things is either you
could stop the way Commerce is going
around the world which is not going to
happen because people are just too
greedy and the other way you can do it
is reduce the population
and I think that's what's happening I
think too personally this is full
full-blown conspiracy theory but I think
the reason why they push like the whole
LGBT thing why less reproduction they
don't have kids I said that on Twitter
one time and the lgbts community came
from my neck I literally said this is a
plan to get people to stop reproducing
and deeper and they came for my neck
like I literally had to delete it
because I was young at the time and
didn't care but yeah like going back to
the question like again like if you're
in a room and it's overly crowded and
you want to depopulate it do you think
that's fair or do you think that's like
a [__] that should never happen well
but but the thing is how do I put it
there's they've always said we are going
to be overpopulated like and they've
never been right like how who are these
people that know exactly when the Earth
is going to be over popular especially
in the US like the majority of the US is
still Farmland because people are coming
to the city I heard that all you can
literally fit the entire population of
Earth in Texas
I don't know
I heard that I don't know it is a really
big play you know if not Texas
definitely Alaska yeah but um the thing
is like with this whole population just
to be if you like pull back and look at
everything right they're championing
abortion why killing babies championing
LGBT stuff why
can't have babies right championing
dudes turning into women why
think about it it's all I like think
it's I
a hammock thing these people are satanic
it's making me feel like I believe in
God too no no I'm saying like they they
they're trying to be God yes like who
who decides when life starts and ends
God and so what what type of policies
are we seeing abortion and euthanasia
when Life Starts and and now you're
playing God I have a question for you do
you believe in God yeah no no Catholic
Oh that's I'm Catholic too um so yeah
going back to the question you mentioned
how like okay the world isn't populated
but yet they're trying to depopulate it
but why are they trying to deep up in
English it's not popular because because
they think they're God like or I mean
one I mean there's a couple theories I I
I think that one they worship the devil
and that's what the devil says to do or
two they want to play God they think
they know everything and so they think
oh at this many people like the World's
Gonna Be overpopulated but you never
like you don't know yeah Elon Musk has
been talking about we're actually set
we're trending towards deep population
and and on pop like uh we're gonna have
a population crisis sort of um very soon
because right as a as a more a country
Trends towards industrialization the
further the birth weight the birth rate
drops down that's why you're having
Germany with the low birth rate South
Korea with the low birth rate Japan with
a low birth rate because of these super
industrialized nations that are I mean
America too the only people keeping
America's birth rate rolling are the
Latinos you know the white the white
replacement rate is like below 1.2 I
think the Latino is like 2.4 or
something like that and the black one is
forget about it that's also is it really
oh wow
you know the only ones keeping America's
birth rate higher the Latinos yeah it
was so funny that you mentioned about
the Planned Parenthood is actually
Connie actually went on a whole run yeah
explaining everything that you said and
I really think the mate just got to him
because he was literally saying out
everything that Andrew Tate is saying
like he was saying these people coming
against me I don't want no parts guys
stand up like look at the truth of
what's happening and now he's gone back
to being silent again
um so God bless Kanye I just wanted to
give out yeah no they paint him as crazy
but I don't even I was just I was on the
podcast recently they were trying to get
me to say it was crazy I don't think
he's crazy I think he just knows too
much most people can't access that level
of knowledge because most people are
ignorant and then the best way for you
to kind of like deal with the ignorance
is cause a little bit of chaos and
you've got the perfect environment for
control for misinformation to guide
people to where you want them to be I
generally believe that the world is
going to get to a stage where it
literally will be survival of the
fittest and fitness will mean the
richest perhaps the most physical and
the smartest that's it if you don't fit
into those three bye bye I'm so sorry
because life's about to get difficult
there's a big theory around that like
that the elites this is we're just going
to conspiracy theories now but there's
one theory that the elites intentionally
put out this kind of propaganda for dumb
people to take the the shot whatever to
kill out the dummies and like the smarts
come out because it's very easy when you
release it so you're [__] when you
think about it
we all make mistakes when when they talk
but I'll be okay because I know that if
I fast for about 90 days I'll flush many
things out of my system do it baby do it
um I think I've thought about it but I
definitely think that what you said
about people being mostly miseducated is
a problem okay that is why like somebody
like Andrew Tate actually is a massive
threat not because of him talking bad
about people but realistically when you
think about his Edge educating people
into certain things like how do you make
money he's exposing the fact that what
you're looking at is not necessarily the
truth but it is what they call the
Matrix and how it's controlling people
is talking about the keys or the to
success or the keys to mental
development for men that make them feel
confident in themselves and they don't
have to take [__] from anybody yeah you
know so I fully understand that in
educate empowerment through education is
actually one of the most difficult one
of the most dangerous threats to the
system now because even you see whenever
a new government comes into play comes
into play especially you could see this
with the Communist governments the first
thing they do is
revolutionize the education system
that's it it's so funny that you
mentioned the dummy sorry can I see
something yeah yeah because I was
actually watching a video about this
Satanist who's a part of the elites I'm
not going to say the name but we all
know the name the
illumi you know I mean that's you could
say Illuminati it doesn't matter I don't
know if I was going to get canceled but
um he was basically saying the same
thing that you said he basically said in
our society we don't want any dummies we
don't want any idiots we want the most
talented the most genius the best actors
the best musicians the smartest people
in our team and let's eradicate all of
the dummies and push them into a
position where they can't feed they get
fat they're in a mental state they're
depressed lgbtq all of these things so I
mean think about during the lockdowns
right why were why was like liquor
stores and marijuana open but the gyms
were closed I don't know like you could
go to marijuana dispensary you can eat
ubereats you can get [__] hammered
off of Jack Daniels but you can't go to
the gym and do some push-ups you can't
go gym and then dead left do what you
got to do but you know there's more
evidence about that when we talk about
fluoride in the drinking water like
Americans just think like oh yeah every
country has fluoride in the drinking
water no it's only America and Florida
has been shown to like Drop IQ right no
way you know yeah absolutely and then on
top of that like they stopped enriching
salt with iodine because iodine was
found to like raise IQ you know what I
mean so I mean there's a lot of
different things that are just all
talking about
um the nature of our current environment
there's a book called estrogeneration
have you heard about that and it's
talking about how all of these common
products household products uh Dental
products shampoos conditioner soap all
are using being used by men that
actually raises their estrogen and drops
their testosterone
that's why men with you if you eat a lot
of shampoo you
like one guy was losing he said well he
did was stop using shampoo or any
products like that and his hairline came
back and it's so evident because you
know what like I'm obviously I'm a black
woman and
honestly I'm a black woman so I'm around
a lot of black men and I I hate to
offend black men but obviously we are
more prone to use these type of products
these shampoos these because they're
pushed into our little neighborhoods and
I hate to see this but you see the
difference between like because I work
with a lot of like Pakistani men and you
see the difference between black men and
just like other races of men black men
I'm so sorry to say this but a lot of
them have become so like slow so lazy
everything with them is just
and I think a lot of it has to do with
the products like they're putting into
these places
they put these policies in place to
break up the families but what you
notice is that rich people still get
married yeah and and rich people like
don't really I mean they get ruined like
like you know Jeff Bezos Loft lost half
but the the rich guys aren't the ones
complaining about this I mean some some
do but a lot can recover and keep moving
it's like
no it's yeah it's the average guy that's
worked for 20 years that doesn't I mean
I don't know if you guys believe in like
IQ I I don't know I think some things
are limited by IQ for sure so it's an
average the average guy who's worked for
25 years who's never gonna make a ton of
money because he's just not crazy smart
but he's a hard worker he's built
something in 20 years and now the
average chick can ruin him and he those
are the ones that kill themselves and
zero themselves out yeah and so in a way
like breaking up the family depopulates
like the lower like lower socioeconomic
status because rich I think it's like 75
of millionaires are married yeah the
majority of rich people get married five
out of six millionaires are married yeah
yeah it's it's becoming like a rich
person's game but this is this is where
the elites go wrong because I think I
think the people just ultimately believe
that the elites are have like this
Destiny of Victory upon them and I just
don't think that they understand that
information just travels so fast with
the internet like what Andrew Tate is
talking about right now has just caused
a gigantic conversation between all of
us in this room that we're all gonna
remember and then the 2000 plus people
that are watching us live right now not
to mention all the people in the replay
as well they're also going to watch this
and it's going to stimulate something in
their mind and it's going to get people
thinking and I ultimately I don't know I
maybe
foolishly optimistic for the future but
I do see the human race trending towards
truth not trending towards lives how do
I know that look at the mainstream media
mainstream media is dying yes quickly
because they've been lying to people
they've been lying to women they've been
lying to the Mad the average people for
literally generations and finally People
Like Us have a voice we have we can make
our own Studios we can make our own
shows we can make our own live streams
we come out speak and speak the truth
from things that we have noticed not
from oh the experts say you know end of
this [__] and it's really causing a
balance to be shifted towards positivity
towards people getting the you know the
the a better shot at having a better
life because if you're just going to
follow the mainstream media you know
what is it black lives matter or trans
lives matter or body positivity you
follow all that [__] you're gonna be
miserable fat and dead by the time
you're 45. you know what I mean it's so
funny because I was literally telling
her that Andrew Tate basically came
during the perfect blizzard because the
perfect the perfect stool yeah for sure
because he came in a time where people
are actually
just kind of done and tired of the time
of the lies coming from the media and
then use outlets and whatever and
actually starting to and it's not just
um the older people the whole it's the
younger people as well and I think this
younger generation who listened to
Andrew Tate I'm so happy that they are
more striving more towards truth because
now when they get older they will teach
their kids to do the same thing yeah and
we will progressed to that Society who
cares more about truth rather than lie
so he came at the perfect time because
if this was the 80s or whatever I don't
think anyone would have ever my sister
do you know what the problem is with
that let me tell you something most
people as he said are miseducated what
we are facing is actually we think that
we are that yeah it's going to be good
because we are on a different side to
what most people see we are the educated
ones really okay most people are not on
this level most people are the ones that
are watching all of this what I call
trash TV the fast food of TV the
McDonald's of TV and entertainment Okay
so realistically actually I I would like
to be optimistic I try and that's why
I'm even in this space and I'm creating
my own footprint in this space but I am
also very very very aware of the fact
that for the truth to travel as far as
what we're thinking it might do I don't
know if it's going to be as realistic
there's a lot of videos here around
there's a lot of people talking rubbish
there's a lot of people being given
platforms because people just like what
they look like and they're talking the
biggest rubbish you know what I mean so
it's a serious War out here it's a
spiritual war that people don't even re
they're not even walking waking up to
yet eventually yes they will wake up to
it but then don't forget there's Now new
problems on the table with things like
Ai and all of these technological
developments are just going to confuse
people more and cause more chaos more
problems right right I need to read
super chats for a second I think they
kind of want us to play the video again
um all right guys remember over twenty
dollars um to read a Super Chat 500
bucks
[Laughter]
it's like you think they'd come together
they don't hate me they just know that
they say that they hate that they love
you they know that they said that you're
the fast food
look I am the fast food thick and juicy
okay
um thank you baz for the super chat
um uh denalva de Nava denalva mothers
are so inhospitable men don't even want
to be around them in order to get to
their kids and call then call them dead
Beats at every turn
um the new and turn the new dude against
them uh Vinnie and the spirit I read
that one already let me just refresh it
make sure there's no more guys like the
video that's the most important metric
that YouTube uses uh we're gonna do
members only until we get to how many
likes blessing
and also let me know in the chat what
you think of the interview so far what's
your favorite part
Lex 2.5 2.5 all right guys get us to 2.5
and we'll reopen the chat
Have You Ever Seen The Experiment
there's a really interesting experiment
with monkeys and a banana and a water
spout have you ever seen this they put
five monkeys in a room and at the top of
the room there was a banana and when one
monkey tried to climb up to get the
banana they turn on the hose and splash
all the monkey's ice cold water
so the monkey will come back down and we
can get the banana and when another
monkey would go to climb up they'd
Splash all the monkeys with ice cold
water and what would happen over time is
when a monkey went to climb the Rope to
get the banana the other monkeys would
jump and pull them down and hit and
teach them a lesson don't go for that
banana if you go for that banana we get
splash of Lord
then they'd swap one of the monkeys out
now there's a new monkey in the room who
doesn't know the game the new monkey
would attempt to climb and all four
monkeys would attack the monkey
pulling back down and kick his ass he
knows if he climbs the Rope to get the
banana he gets attacked he doesn't know
he gets splashed through water if he
doesn't if he gets him out he doesn't
know the game but he knows if I try and
climb they're gonna attack me
after a certain amount of weeks they
change another monkey and another monkey
Another Monkey over time you have five
brand new monkeys who have never been
splashed with Walter ever but nobody
goes to climb the Rope because if they
do they're attacked by all the other
monkeys nobody even knows why yeah
you climb that rope we beat you up
that's just how it works that's what
they're doing on a long enough time
scale to humanity there are already x
amount of people on the planet there's
already a population X percent who knows
what it is who ignore their own eyes and
repeat what they are told you can't say
that that's not what they're doing
because they're already successful with
x amount of the population they've begun
the seed is there
two percent three percent seven percent
who knows they've already proven they
can do it now it's just a matter of not
showing up and hammering the hammering
at home make sure they repeat in schools
children are young they believe things
are impressionable hammer it to the kids
especially put it in every Disney movie
give it to the kids all day long they
grow up sooner or later long enough time
frame that's it it's generational attack
do you think that's gonna work though
because uh let me maybe unpack the
question so uh uh I'm from Glendale I
went to Glendale High School and stalloy
right so yesterday a big fight broke out
in Glendale massive it's all over the
news so the fight was over these parents
Armenian parents who were for four years
are like listen we don't mind if you're
gay but don't teach our four-year-olds
about transgender don't put these books
in finally yesterday big old brawl it's
all over the news they're fighting
Armenian parents are like we're not
gonna tolerate this this is just not
going to happen to us right then you go
to YouTube YouTube comes back and says
hey uh starting such and such all the
videos that were put up about you know
the election and you know whether it was
fake election or not we're no longer
going to give a strike or take a those
videos down they can stay up there right
this is totally fine then you see a the
Surgeon General comes out the attorney I
don't know if you saw this one here he
comes out with an article saying new
Surgeon General advisory raises alarm
about the devastating impact of the
epidemic of loneliness and isolation in
the United States this is the same guy
that was part of the camp is now saying
hey our epidemic of loneliness and
isolation has been an underappreciated
Public Health crisis that has harmed
individuals and social health our
relationship our source of healing Etc
this is the same guy that said wait a
minute lockdown you know do this do that
so the more and more arguments are
coming out against even ESG I don't know
how close you follow ESG where why are
we doing this did you see how much
Target lost 10 billion dollars did you
see how much Bud Light Lost 25 12 this
is no longer working well if you want to
like even one of the insurance companies
I work with closely it's one of our
biggest one we work with yesterday I see
their post on Instagram well because of
pride month we're doing this I I know
the people in that company but they just
raised a few hundred million dollars one
of the companies they gave the money to
was one of these bigger guys the
Vanguard BlackRock and you know State
Street so when you take money from those
guys you have to you have to have a
certain ESG score but a lot of people
are now saying this is not a proven
formula that it works stop doing it so
do you think guys like you who are maybe
in business who are maybe in church
they're saying Pope what are you doing
what are you talking about who are maybe
in the Christian church or maybe in
different denominations they're in the
military sitting back saying I didn't
sign up for this so meaning successfully
do you think these guys will be able to
manipulate their agendas down
everybody's throat or there's going to
be certain people standing up well
certainly I'd like to believe that the
tide is Shifting and we're starting to
get some degree of Victory against the
Matrix as a whole I do believe that the
public sentiment is shifting however
fight is long and it's very very
difficult because I agree with what
you're saying only a year ago I would
argue it completely and say it's
basically over I'm actually very
impressed with the back with the with
the ground we've taken back with common
sense
but these people operate so slowly it's
generational these attacks the attacks
we're suffering now were started in the
70s and 80s they take it over time and
yes it's fantastic that those parents
fought back against that school that's
fantastic but there's a whole bunch of
schools where they didn't and who knows
okay that particular book might be
removed a softer version will be
implemented next year maybe that book
will come back they have all the time in
the world all the money in the world and
they're they're insulated from these
things that's what's most scary you talk
about Vanguard and BlackRock and all
these companies what's actually scary
about it is the people who are making
these decisions are completely insulated
from the consequences of their decisions
they're in Switzerland they fly private
they don't care you think they care
about any of this crap they'll say oh do
this oh it's caused a riot
they don't live there they're nowhere
near it it had nothing to do with it
when's the last time you've even seen a
politician do these people even exist
nothing to do with where they they
operate it's actually amazing when I was
in Dubai once I think it was about three
years ago I saw the leader of Dubai
walking through the mall
I was like he's a person and he just
walks to the mall I was so impressed
imagine a western leader walking through
the mall never never never in a million
years it's just pieces of paper private
jet vanish all these people are in
charge of everything don't even live in
these communities I do believe that yes
we can win because I don't think you can
fight to the best of your ability if all
hope is lost I do believe we're winning
and taking ground back absolutely and I
believe that we're doing that by purely
telling the truth what our eyes see or
is what's real now we're doing it in the
name of God because you're saying our
meetings are strictly religious I think
God and religion is one of the best ways
you can combat these things
however the fight is never ending
because they're never ending gonna try
and Implement you talk about ESG scores
it's garbage they put together that's
not going to end it's going to get worse
and worse and worse over time
and it's kind of unfortunate and it's
kind of upsetting that we still have
this system where the people can be
unhappy with something The Peasants can
Revolt to a degree
but does it even really matter at some
point you get to a point of power where
you don't care do you think that's
hopeless do you think like we're
inevitably
it's game over we're all gonna eat the
bugs and end up in FEMA camps or no I
don't think it'll be that extreme
um yeah but I don't know but I don't
think it's going
Direction I mean I don't know maybe I'm
foolishly optimistic but I just don't
see the future of humanity being
enslaved no I don't think it's gonna go
that far because that's what he's gonna
say because you know there was a
Department of Defense report that was
leaked in 2012 and they said like she
basically the general public still has
no idea to the degree of how much the
government is manipulating the course of
Affairs you know current across planet
however they did notice that there is a
growing amount of people just not
complying you know because when you take
God out of the equation when you take
religion when you take you know order
out of the occasion you're just like
yeah whatever you could do whatever you
want you could be whatever you want
those people are going to be harder to
control because you're just like oh well
you just told me I could do whatever I
want to do so I'm just going to do
whatever I want to do and I would argue
like what you and I are doing completely
independent you know
employed people on our own right this
wasn't available 20 30 40 years ago so
he's like what Tate is saying there like
that you know in the 70s they were doing
this in the 80s they were doing this in
the 90s yeah because the number one
reason the elites beat the normal people
is because they're just more connected
and have a higher and more efficient way
of communication Beyond us but the
internet has kind of been the great
equalizer actually even with myself when
I think about it I thought this stuff
was all conspiracy theories a bit ago
even me like if you watch my old
reaction videos like I used to get
triggered by some stuff and like I did
get slowly red pilled over time but I
think like as people like we have
in innate like [__] detector and
like an ability to know truth when we
see it and even though like women can be
easily propagated like I think it takes
strong men showing us what's true and
that's why the red pill Community
honestly is so necessary yeah yeah
absolutely I mean red people listen
because I told Myron in 2019 like when
he was in my coaching group I I said
Myron I said mark my words the red pill
will go mainstream and the red pill is
so mainstream to the extent that it has
women like you that are female leaders
people like you people like Ali you know
Ali's doing more like don't be a whole
thing yeah you know you know like which
is good which is good but you even have
women now that are jumping on board with
this cause and because they also because
a lot of women reach out to me beautiful
women too like stunning women reach out
to me like innately they know like I
know what you guys are saying is the
truth and like I'm just so happy to find
a community that is like a breath of
fresh air in this psychotic world of
Lies well and that's you know what I
realized because at first when I I
started like the first time I saw Kevin
Samuel so I was a huge fan of like he's
one of my favorite OG's of all time and
you know I I called him a douchebag in
the first video I did yeah yeah that I
watched of his because I thought he was
at the time but what I realized is it's
actually like we're just so used to
simps like we are so used to men telling
us what we want to hear that nobody
tells us the truth and that it may have
like this gut reaction where we don't
like what the men are saying and maybe
we have this gut reaction where it's a
bit harsh and like you know when you
guys are saying like don't marry single
mother like you know the first time I
was like well it's a bit harsh you gotta
marry somebody it's not that but then
you know you think about it and you're
like they're right this is how men feel
this is how men think and we have never
been told what men think and the thing
that makes you guys Heroes is you're
telling us the truth in a world of of
yes in a world of lies and it might be
harsh and we might not like it but at
the end of the day if you listen long
enough you know what they're saying is
true have you ever talked to the
angriest and most bitter Red Pill Man of
them all Aaron Clary no no I think I've
seen tweets I recognize the name listen
Aaron Clary is a genius in his own right
I love Aaron Claire he's a great guy and
I hate to even give you this compliment
Aaron you dirt bag I know people are
gonna watch you
um but even he said this he said sanity
is the future of all wealth
sanity in a in a world that's growingly
insane
being sane and having common sense is
the future of all wealth yeah
um
I'm not gonna lie I definitely think
that the world
as we know it because we're talking
about only the West it's just gonna go
back to where it could where it should
be for example in the UK before
colonialism was even there the
imperialism and all of this they were
just peasants even just before the even
during the Industrial Revolution
peasants that's why you live in white
you live in and it looks like a ghetto
do you see what I mean and because this
is literally what London has been like
other than Central London in a bit of
West everything is just trash step
outside of London it's disgusting the
the society right now the society that
we know the superior ideology is about
to get the reality hitting in his face
the slap is going to come back and
people are going to realize okay it's a
really really is a dog eat dog world
this side of the world here is messed up
they've gone too far with whatever
experimentations they wanted to do we
need to go so I'm just gonna say right
now what a great time to be black and
African true agree with that too you
know it's just so much better now like
in the past you know I mean like
especially because
like you know what you were saying about
um
The Matrix or something the elites wants
us to be Dumber it's like you know when
the slavery period
um when we couldn't speak back we were
just going through like a lot of things
then they never wanted to speak back so
people will actually try to advocate for
black people ended up being murdered and
that I mean they just love people to be
Dumber so even now that the internet is
like this it's like we'll have more like
advantage to speak up and people like
being heard and things actually happen
that's why I love this generation more
like social media like everyone can see
anything if someone sells you to shut up
you can say something back but in the
past you can't see anything you're just
gonna shut up do you know what I mean
yeah yeah and that's why slaves couldn't
even read back in the day you know like
they can't read because once you start
to learn how to read you know that
that's what red pill is really it's
teaching slaves to read it's just like
men are like wait a minute yeah I have a
right I have value like oh wait man this
[__] can talk [__] to me like this not
anymore no no no no no I'm running away
do you know I just had this like red
pill moment the other day I watched this
pastor on YouTube and this is what this
message is so lost in the church because
they don't even talk about like what a
true traditional relationship is and it
was like the woman went up to her
husband or the pastor and said like when
me and my husband keep arguing and the
pastor says well why are you arguing
with your husband he's your Bot like he
was like he's your boss right you
wouldn't if if my employees arguing with
me I just fire the employee but like and
it goes and what I realized is I'm like
oh my gosh arguing with a man implies
that you guys are equal yeah and that's
what all the problems are from is like
we think that we are equal when men are
literally better at everything even
cooking and raising kids they are
literally better and it's like Until you
realize that men are literally are like
what do you call it superiors when
they're above you and when you're in a
relationship you are supposed to look at
him as your Superior you are not equals
and and the world is trying to tell us
that we're equal and I know you might
you might Flinch right I used to too but
it's like no think about it think about
it what what has what is a 50 thing up
there yesterday
what is it what is a 50 50 okay we want
we want traditional men right typically
women want men that open doors they want
men that will protect us they want men
that take up the majority of the bills
typically especially when we have a
family and have kids right so you're
saying take up all the responsibility
but you have no authority over me I want
you to be responsible for me I want
you're responsible to protect me you're
responsible to provide for me even if
you work in the long run you're going to
work less than your husband so he's
going to do more work but you have no
Authority you can't tell me what to do
we have to comp even the idea of like
well you have to I heard Michaela
Peterson say this once once she said I
was with a guy that I couldn't negotiate
with and I'm like you're not supposed to
negotiate with your husband you ask it's
the same way like the relationship with
your husband if you look back at truly
traditional relationships it's supposed
to be like a boss and an employee like
not exactly the same but the same type
of dynamic where you might go ask your
boss for your raise but you're not going
to demand it and have a [__] fit if he
doesn't give it to you yeah to be honest
I want also would like a traditional mom
because I'm a traditional person myself
I didn't grow up in the UK I grew up in
Nigeria and I was thought that a
management to take care of you that I
managed meant to do this for you do that
you're not traditional do not mean no I
am a very traditional person let me say
let me just like okay I'm a traditional
person I know myself like I want that
but it's like when I moved to the UK I
looked after myself for too much like I
was just it was just me and I had to do
a lot of things by myself like I had to
pay my own right I didn't have anybody
like I wasn't dating nobody so now that
I'm actually trying to see somebody
again I'm thinking to myself it's hard
for me to let that man do it it's just
so hard I try but when he does some
saying things I'm like I could do that
for myself I could do that for myself
but generally speaking I would like a
man to take care of me but this is okay
this is where we get into the inequal
exchange of value and the things you
don't appear like a traditional woman
you have red hair it's like you have no
no I'm seriously like two traditional
women they don't really wear a lot of
makeup they don't don't get triggered
wait don't get no don't get triggered
come on I'm not either I'm not either
it's okay okay it doesn't mean you're a
bad person but traditional women are
virgins until they're married I'm just
gonna assume you're not a virgin right
traditional version
Born Again
traditional women like wouldn't wear a
top like that
doesn't mean you're a bad person I'm not
like I'm not saying you're like a bad
and I'm I'm saying I'm not traditional
either yeah but it's like so the Met
like the women are saying I'd like a
traditional man but we're not coming to
the table with a traditional mindset
like we we don't even we we think that
we should be able to compromise in a
relationship that's not traditional
traditional is what he says goes the
traditional okay I'm thinking when
you're saying traditional I'm not
thinking in the same aspect that you're
thinking I'm not traditional but like
it's the West like we've we've done so
let's say the world is more wild right
now you can't expect to see like you
know what I mean you're going
traditional like virgin let's say that's
out of the box already right are you
saying don't dress like that don't put
on makeup let me just don't put on
makeup don't have the same house my set
of tradition is like for me saying oh
I'm gonna listen to my husband I'm gonna
cook in the house I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do that that's what I see a
traditionally because that's what I
could do right now because of what the
world is that's just I know I look like
that's how I see a traditional not like
the whole version but that's why but
that's why it's like it's traditional
when it's when it's easy traditional
like when it benefits me but so and this
is wait wait and it's not it's not to
like take any Digs at you 95 of women
are not virgins on their wedding day but
it's like either we're equals or they're
better than us yeah it's either either
we are these same or we're not and if we
if we're really saying that we are equal
here then then okay pay for half the
dates I do that actually if anyone what
you're saying this that I've actually
been with on a day I always offer do you
want me to pay like I said I look after
myself
offering versus actually buying is
different no if you're watching this
right now we've been on the day before
they could come out if you actually I
always go on a date with someone I say
can I I said I want to put in the money
I like to pay because like I would
remind you I said I looked up to myself
for so long that I always think
when was your last relationship I'm
literally even with somebody right now
okay okay and he makes you so angry no
he doesn't make me angry
do you do you split everything down the
middle everything we don't split
everything down
yes or no does he pay more yes or no no
he does okay so he pays equally yeah
because I decided to see yes or no like
for wait wait wait wait wait so so so
right now if you do do the 50 50 then
yeah which is fine there's nothing
there's nothing I'm not I'm not hating
on 50 50. I think if you want to do that
fine
we don't do 50 50.
to him sometimes because he spends on
that sits again sometimes you know what
I say let's go out I'll pay for dinner
tonight I'll pay for everything like we
don't live together so I pay my rent and
everything he goes to you and he's like
do you know what I mean I'm not saying
to him even when we spend time to go
because we've been together for like a
while so when we do spend time together
we're not literally doing do not mean
it's not like oh let's go no we're not
doing stuff like that so there's not a
lot of money being spent but like on
past the special days you can get stuff
for me and I do the same in return my
whole point is that typically the man
pays more no typical okay I don't I
don't I don't yeah I don't want that
okay okay
I'll tell you then you're you're like
jeopardized you know it's like I just
can't do it no no it's traditional women
get traditional outcomes if you're not
getting a traditional outcome it's
probably because you're not traditional
and that's the thing is like we've
allowed women to go around saying I'm a
traditional woman I'm a traditional
woman and then I say okay do you listen
to your boyfriend husband whatever no
matter what he says if you disagree it
goes and they'll say no if I asked him
do you argue with him yes uh okay what
about what about cooking what percent of
the meals do you cook oh he has to do
chores too okay uh what about are you a
virgin did you bring virginity to the
table no no but that's a real
traditional we've like brainwashed women
to think that like we are traditional
when we are not your explanation of
tradition is different from my
experience we all have our own no no
let's agree to disagree no but there's
no there's no def there's the definition
that has been there for all of time but
you know what in history it's long to be
talking about being a traditional woman
I'm not a traditional woman I am an
evolved woman not even a modern woman
I'm an evolved woman and I'll tell you
why because I've retained certain
aspects of the traditional that still
are not needed that are still relevant
to today's age and then I've got new
skills imagine imagine selling a car and
I say no are you single yes of course I
am now
Jesus Christ okay imagine you're selling
a car right and I have a hot do you know
Honda Civic is yeah yeah it's like a
typical car and I say this is a Ferrari
you can go around all the people that
buy Ferraris and say this is a Ferrari
this is Ferrari values but that doesn't
make it a Ferrari because Ferraris get
Ferrari buyers and if you're single over
the age of 25 odds are you're not
traditional because traditional women
get married young that is their number
one priority in life doesn't mean you're
a bad person it doesn't mean like take
anything away from your value well
except to men a little bit but but it
doesn't it doesn't mean you're a bad
person it just means you're not
traditional okay then let's use that
analogy and not put it into a Tesla okay
this car has got a lot of power wait
wait wait no let me tell you it is not a
Ferrari but it can go as fast as a
Ferrari and guess what it's electric so
it's even better for the environment
nowadays what would you rather you can
go for the Ferrari it's up to you these
tastes but for me I'll prefer the test
I'll give you an example but you got no
Tesla you're single yes I am single a
lot of choice no I'm for sure I was I
was in a relationship for five years
I've been single four years I'm not
ready to go into a relationship yet
because I'm starting to I'm still trying
to kind of settle my foundations now
after five years that's a long time for
me right to be in a relationship to then
go back into the world then we look at
the car specs and say what are the
outcomes for these cars well one dies
after 10 000 miles where one has a long
life and you pick the one with the long
life just because you put new paint and
a new hood on it doesn't make it a new
car yeah but this is gone this is the
thing like modern women have worse
outcomes and we can look at this a
hundred years ago 85 percent of women
were virgins on their wedding day 95 of
people were married 95 yeah today
traditional women ever again there's no
more left yes yes no there's a couple I
would say very very few because the
issue is like traditional women wouldn't
really social media makes it so tempting
for traditional women to not be
traditional that even if you get a
traditional woman she can still go on
social media and get
it all goes down because like you know
everybody thinks and in the west is so
bad right right but you know that inside
I'm talking West you're good you're good
I'll give you a Global Perspective in
Japan right 27 of all women from ages 18
to 39 years old zero percent sexual
experience all virgins 27 of the
population why because they don't have a
mainstream horde media it's like get out
there and suck some dick sister being an
empowered corporate [__] they don't
have that if you watch the commercials
in Japan if you watch commercials in
Korea if you watch Commissions in Japan
in China compared to what you see in the
states it's night and day in Japan they
have women wearing aprons dancing in the
sun celebrating that they're Housewives
and they have like the best laundry
detergent in America it's completely
different from that of course the media
all this stuff the the you know it's not
I'll take the side of saying that it's
not West women's fault in regards to all
the propaganda in the United States in
England Canada Australia all the
English-speaking Western countries it's
geared to brainwash women into thinking
you need to be masculine you need to be
a boss babe you need to be a boss [__]
you need to be this corporate girl right
and think about how stupid that is if
you're telling millions of women like
yeah you can all be CEOs how many
[__] CEO positions are there
and that's the thing they sell this to
women like I was thinking about it
everyone in my high school because I
went to um a Catholic like private high
school you were elected as a loser if
you didn't go to college yeah when women
from it's like interesting because we
have things that the culture pushes and
things that are better for your biology
and it's like you you really your
fertility starts to decline after like
well they say 90 of your eggs are gone
after 30. if you're single by 30 you
have more likely to never have children
than to have them well that's a fear
that people like to instill into people
which no one isn't necessary because
we're not talking about you no I know
but no but I'm telling you it is a fear
that people try to instill into people
because even in the world of today it is
not really I would say it's not a good
idea to have a lot of children anyway so
if you went into 13 you have one or two
then that's fine Aya's gonna take no
right the odds are so don't be scared
you've shifted from blaming men to
blaming Ai No I'm just saying the world
the world is not conducive for people to
behave in those ways anymore and that's
why
I think women should know if you're 30
and you're still single if you're in a
relationship the odds are a bit
different because you have to first you
have to find a guy that wants to marry
you right so like that's step one and we
only majority is a gigantic mountain to
climb yeah and then step two that you
want to marry back another huge hurdle
and so if you hit 30 and you're single
and you have no kids the odds are it's
you it's like you're 60 70 likely to
never have children and like like and
this isn't propaganda this isn't fear
this is just the numbers yep and then
you know the risks that happen post 35
like post 35 you know what they call the
the pregnancy after you're 35 years old
you know what this classified as yeah
what's it called uh geriatic geriatric
correct geriatric pregnancy right which
means you're an old [__] that's
pregnant
but is it possible for them to have them
and for the babies not to be [__]
and for the babies not to have
miscarriage I don't know like maybe
because I'm an African woman and I guess
like African girls maybe have some sort
of like extra fertility that's why
there's bad twins everywhere but I'm
just saying it's not the same because
our food's so messed up your mothers and
grandmothers were healthier yeah it will
not it will not be the same
yeah so I'm running and the thing is and
again going back to everything right
it's the it's it's not a bunch of men
that are 30 years old crying on Tick
Tock it's a bunch of women they're
crying I just want a baby I just want to
bake cookies I want to be like I want to
have children and bake pumpkin pie and
hang out in the sunlight you know it's
not men sitting around crying man that
complaining that they don't get laid I
mean
at a thing called in cells yeah you
sells people that don't have sex you
need to have sex to have babies so walk
one that's right right so I agree with
you on that guys want sex but we're not
they're not online crying about it of
course instead what they do what do they
do they end up bottling all up and then
eventually they jump off a bridge that's
the sad reality of things so that's why
realistically let's not sit here and
point fingers and let's just say okay
let's complain about the The Matrix wait
what did you just say you said wait men
cry about what no they don't cry about
it they bought to lay up the bridge you
know honestly
a lot of a lot of men do kill themselves
because of the way women treat them yes
I interview them all the time women will
destroy a guy's life
yeah yeah man destroys almost life we
all destroy each other's lives the times
when things don't go right that's the
thing and I don't think that there's any
need for people to be forced in
situations that are just not right
Evolution I think we should we should
force situations I think women think
things aren't right when a lot of times
they are because women weren't taught we
were not taught that you're supposed to
stick it out through thick and thin
we're taught to divorce your husband to
be happy yep when your happiness doesn't
matter like it's so stupid that like
women think we think like our happiness
like that's the other thing um about why
we don't have traditional women anymore
we really believe that our happiness is
more important than the kids when our
grandmothers our great grandmothers they
would stick it out for the kids no
matter what because they cared about the
children but it's like women today are
so selfish yeah because again because
they're because they're bombarded with
propaganda telling them but they are
hold on they're bombed they're bombarded
with propaganda all the time saying like
correct you know what girl you can do it
you don't need a man you can do this you
can do that like I have a friend she's
she's absolutely
gorgeous she is beautiful and everything
she literally looks like a model right
and she tells me at the end of her days
of her work days and she does an amazing
job she makes like 200 000 a year or
something like that and she says at the
end of every work day she comes home and
just wants to cry from all the stress
because she just hates everything
because she's like caught up in this
lifestyle where she has to continue
delivering and she just sees herself
getting older and still single doesn't
have a [__] man any suitors in the
picture you know and she has that like
existential crisis closing in on her
like man or woman like dude I'll tell
you this even at 37 right I want to have
a family like I feel my biological clock
ticking as a man like I want to have
children I don't want to sit around be
like one of these old [__] miserable
players and like you know like oh I went
up [__] the new girl tonight like dude
like you're go like you're old go home
and like [__] build a boat or
something you know
I don't want to be that guy you know and
I think a lot of people realize realize
that that that kind of window closes on
them as a man I'm lucky because I can I
can have kids in front 50. I can have
kids all the way into my 60s like Donald
Trump had Baron and he was like 56 I
think something no no Al Pacino he's
having a baby at 7.80 no he's like 83. I
think he's like 82 or 83. now
technically thing still goes inside oh
dude listen there's a world there's a
way with men
but but the thing is this right you know
you have that reality that's been pushed
on women it's unfortunate because women
have been they've been tricked into
thinking like oh you need sexual
experience they've been they've been uh
there's been Theory there have been
studies that completely debunked that
theory like the myth of sexual
experience and again you look at all of
it and you know I respect you girls here
on the panel you have to work hard you
have to go out there and you and it's a
dog eat dog world out there as a woman
now like independently you are like
expected to go out there pay your own
rent pay your own bills do all this [__]
and go out there and find a man and try
to figure out a way to keep it together
right it's hard for you girls too but I
mean if you look back at all the stuff
you were taught it was all based around
you becoming another Cog and the
consumerism wheel that's all it's based
around it's not about your Independence
you think these [__] corporations
give a [__] about you you think these
governments give a good God damn about
you they don't give a [__] about you all
they care about is pulling as much money
out of you as possible and you know if
you don't have any if you have a man
with you guess what when you're in love
you just need that person there with you
you don't need to be like oh baby I love
you and I need a [__] air maze bag or
I need to [__] go buy some Louis
Vuitton shoes like when you're in love
you can have like a [__] paperback
bag and like a pizza and you'd be like
I'm just so happy to be here with this
pizza and the person I love in the
[__] sunset or something like that
and that's what they're trying to
distract us from and again what is it
all doing pulling us apart and they're
doing it to men too yeah who's the
number one consumers of corn right Corn
Hub only fans all that stuff it's men
bleeding the men of money and then who
does the money go to it goes swim
there's a there's a thing in Japan I'll
tell you guys about this right so
there's a there's a vicious six cycle uh
in the sex worker industry right so the
salaryman goes to these women called
hostesses right you go to the hostess
club and the hostess is you pay like
twenty dollars a drink to sit there and
talk with a woman and then sometimes you
buy champagne or whatever so these
salary men who are working all day they
go to these clubs and they go to the
hostess girls and some of these
hostesses make 80 it's like a hundred
thousand dollars a month they kill it
and they don't have to have sex with
these guys it's just part of the culture
they sit there they chat they talk to
the guys up right and then the hostesses
they finish around 2 3 A.M in the
morning and where do they go they go to
The Host Club and that's where the men
prey on these hostesses and they go and
talk to these guys and they talk about
all their works at the [__] you know
they talk about all the troubles that
they had at the job to these guys and
they're like oh baby buy these drinks
buy this and they listen to all and they
kind of smoosh them and make them feel
good and those clothes open from like 3
A.M to 8 A.M so you have the salary man
passing money to the hostesses passing
the money to the host and everybody in
that whole chain is miserable and it's
all based around consumerism they would
all be happier if they went home had a
family were just like normal people but
they're all caught up in this lifestyle
and that's exactly what's happening over
here in the West too like they're
constantly telling you like you know
look think about it all the companies
are like oh you know what here's Bob and
Bob's a [__] dumb man and like here's
Bob's wife Martha and Martha really
understands Bob's an idiot because
Martha uses tide you know and then it's
like died because Martha's are great and
then we're like yeah that's right I'm
gonna buy this [__] tide my husband's
an idiot and then you know you're
poisoning the culture which with this
toxic message that's only designed to
pull more money out of you that's it and
you know that's crazy the average chick
makes like 35 000 a year like when I
when I think of like a hypergamy success
story do you know who I think of like a
modern woman's success story Candace
Owens okay that chick stuck The Landing
you know because she got married at like
30. and I love I'm a huge can to someone
I'm such a no disrespect to her but it
was like and then she did the career had
had the family did the whole thing right
and then married like a multi like super
successful super handsome guy but it's
like is the average chick gonna do that
no is the average like it's like the
average chicks makes 35 000 pounds a
year yeah like she's not making that
much money she's living paycheck to
paycheck in an apartment box
no I think I think for sure I would
agree on the fact that a lot of girls
are quite deluded I I speak from a
different perspective because of the
type of woman that I am and the things
that I've heard do you how do you expect
your life to turn out in Alba
is it just it's um Dead from the vaccine
in three years
I'm just [__] talking I'm just [__]
the way that I expect my life to turn
out the good thing is do you do you
still want I'm hold on I'm gonna just
wait and please you go on a bit like for
a while please answer like quick sort of
tell me okay
please so you said on a show you wanted
two houses yes do you still want that
yes okay where where do you expect to
find this guy that's gonna be she just
just to give you some background moldy
she uh Danelle but you deserve a condo
at best baby
she wants she wants yeah she she I think
she would pay you do pretty well and
yeah yeah okay so she'll she'll run or
buy one house he'll buy the other they
won't she wants to have separate houses
so she can have her space yeah because
this is
where do you expect to find this guy
very easily grinder do you know do you
know like especially
coming from the iPhone Community the way
that I look at life is so different I
know I need I need listen if I go to in
person okay so you expect to meet him in
person she's gonna get some day game
coaching from Troy Francis
I don't think I think you guys just
think that that I'm kind of boxed into
this Western box no I don't I'm really
not it's very different than most women
I think this is a very unique do you
want to live in two houses with your
husband in the future do you want to get
married and have two separate houses
I have an extra house just in case it
has happened for myself or not like
living different okay like you won't
have Separate Lives you know I want to
have the same life with my husband but I
also would like a house for myself close
by so if I had an argument I just go oh
God never mind I guess it's not like a
thing I want to leave with my husband
just in case it kicks me out just you
know like a backup plan how much is a
house in the UK 500k so okay do you do
so you're planning to get a million
pounds
I don't plan to I'm not saying I would
I'm just saying it's something that I
would love to have like a backup plan
because anything can happen I agree
agree but why would you pay why would
you plan for failure if you want a
successful relationship it's not
planning for failure it is planning for
failure because sweetheart you were
literally saying that I would like a
second house in case [__] goes solid in
case I have an argument something I
sleep on the couch I go tomorrow why
don't you just work on not being
argumentative
um because it's just inevitable if
you're married to somebody if you're
married to someone you're going to live
with them for the rest of your life
you're all definitely going to disagree
on something that's something we should
agree on yes you can't say it's not
going to happen you're gonna agree
disagree with you on that you are
correct time it's just but you don't
need a separate house to run away to why
not just go for a walk in the park all
right I'm gonna walk to my house isn't
it
in case the you don't work out
oh what's the difference
but but I mean like a backup chick right
well the house is different from a girl
a whole girl is a whole different thing
do you know who's sucking their teeth
I just think you guys don't understand
this you don't understand reality space
ideally how much money International
undisclosed I would like a man that is
international I do a lot of things to
your teacher aren't you you work for
Uber I teach I'm a director for a few
companies as well
the sound Bank I've got a few other ones
as well so I'm actually I'm I'm somebody
let me tell you something I'll explain
to you so that you don't have to ask
questions why would you teach if you're
directing a profit will come because my
my mission is not centered around money
my mission is centered around my purpose
and my purpose is to actually educate
the youth especially into well-being for
me what I would prefer ideally is to
have somebody that can travel a lot that
is international somebody that is quite
busy doing their own mission so that
they don't have to always be in my head
and you know having that closeness I
don't actually enjoy that close and I
think that is quite healthy for people
to have a lot of space whilst they're
being present in each other's lives if a
guy is traveling he's probably making
six figures so you're asking for a man
that's making six figures
for me to ask what do you bring to a guy
that makes six figures you won't even
live with him listen so what you're
going to give him children listen
without having to be very but you're 30
31 so maybe one two I'll tell you my
sister yeah just because your father is
a millionaire and everybody knows
doesn't mean that I don't come from
somewhere where I actually have access
to these Elite men if I'm ready to get
there that's the thing I am not I am not
a typical Western girl and I'm not a
typical immigrant if I'm demanding for a
man to be on a certain level it's not
because I'm so deluded that I'm down
here and I'm not going to be able to
reach a man on that level that's the
thing I work very hard on myself to
ensure that I am going to be the person
that can have that sort of man and I
continue to work on it now that is also
one of the reasons why I've decided to
actually work on my intellect as well so
that I can do that for a man that is
also intellectually Superior it's okay
you said you're a Millionaire right do
you yeah right well the world knows now
you know I thought you said that earlier
I text you that no you said that earlier
when you said I made a million I've made
Millions yeah yeah okay but it's like I
have a space how how high is intellect
on like the list of things you look for
I'm gonna give a [__] I don't give a
[__] no I want someone who is going to
be cooperative
who is going to understand
what I am doing with my life and then
who is going to want to march with me on
my life path not who's going to sit at
the back well why are we going this way
like well why don't we put on these
shoes or why are you driving in this
gear why are we taking this like I don't
I don't want to hear that the best girl
I ever dated in my entire life was a
girl that just blindly supported me to
the point that I was got like I was like
damn like I kind of feel guilty that
this girl is supporting me to the extent
that she is but even her she saw
something in me that I didn't see and
because of me dating this girl I was
able to make the millions of dollars
that I've generated with my business in
the masculine empowerment Network and I
have this gigantic influence on the
entire world if I because the thing is
this too right when I broke up with her
because I foolishly broke up with her
because it was a stupid decision right
when I broke up with her and because I
wanted it because I thought I could just
go find a hotter version of her and like
you know just like another girl and I
started dating this other girl and this
girl is just like always arguing always
had some [__] to say and always
stressing me out yeah as a as a man as
an entrepreneur as a guy who's a high
performing individual as a human you
have a limited amount of mental Ram
right yeah mental space that you can
give to your daily task and when a
portion of that daily mental space is
dealing with argumentative women
argumentative spouse let alone
argumentative partner you you know
you're not able to function at your
highest ability because you could be
using that space towards getting your
life purpose done getting your money
right getting your muscles right money
muscles came from we're talking about
what do you want to put it towards but
it's always a sunk cost to be taking a
portion of your mental willpower and
dealing with argumentative people
argumentative staff argument that's why
people get fired because the corporation
is like listen this [__] is not
doing what I need to do you're out of
here you're fired I'm gonna find
somebody who's gonna do what I can do
because we have got to get the show we
got to keep the ball rolling we got to
get this show on the road and keep this
thing moving forward and that's the same
thing with relationships so for me like
a woman's inch like I don't really care
you know what I'm looking for I'm
looking for a girl that is thin that is
Pleasant that wants to help me and then
wants to help nurture the situation that
I'm in who wants to give me a massage
who wants who doesn't mind cooking me
something I come home I work all day
she's like Hey listen the house is clean
it smells good there's food here your
clothes are there and when you're done
I'm gonna massage your shoulders yeah
that's what I'm like a guy like me yeah
and that's you now they've been at the
situation what was the name of the guy
in the studio
gone to another most men feel the same
way yeah no no because when you say when
you say it's guys like you that's how
most men most men want the same thing if
I wanted most men I would have not been
sitting here telling you that I'm
looking for somebody that is
intellectually Superior somebody like
Justin Wallace sat there and he said
actually as a woman also make sure that
you're well reading things like politics
and things like this so that you can
even be able to sustain a conversation
with your man Justin Waller did not say
you got to be up to date on politics
I'll cut the clip not only that Justin
Waller is my friend I don't call that
right now call them call them and find
out and then not only that let me tell
you something
hold on he no he said he wanted women
that were based that is different that's
based is okay I don't want a feminist
isn't the same base dessert that's fine
so yes I know Justin Justin's last year
like she's not up to date with these
policies
May differ a little bit like Justin was
like I don't care if my Girl Cooks I'll
get ubereats like he doesn't care about
like some guys differ slightly but the
whole point is non-argumentative and
supportive is a must intellect and
argumentative inaugumentative they're
not synonymous number one they're not I
the only reason why you ever even see me
in this light and even when me and you
spoke and you he already knows as well I
can sit here and argue and debate
because I've got a mind that can
actually pick out the points that don't
make sense but it doesn't mean that I'm
argumentative all the time this is just
for the context of the situation but
I'll tell you something I do not want to
be with somebody that wants a stupid
woman because you're more likely to be a
stupid man because you don't realize
that actually in the world if you're
going to be cooperating and being a
partnership you best both of you be on a
good level so both of you have a good
value to be able to survive I any man
that just thinks that he needs a woman
to have kids with and for her to just be
there to to just Coast with him so
that's a problem that's silly that's why
it's not I'm an involved woman that
wants an involved man maybe we're just
different types of people let's listen
evolved into what this modern mess that
women have become well no not evolve
into a modern Mastermind because those
are the women that this red pill
situation talks about I'm talking about
an involved woman that can actually
stand by her man's side and help him do
anything a woman that can actually be
able to pick up a new skill to support
her man a woman that can actually say
you know what babe these things are not
okay go out there and hustle I got I got
is on this side and that is not a stupid
woman that's exactly that's exactly what
I just described
well then you've rejected the fact that
I said I want somebody that is
intellectual because I'm smart too
that's what I mean but people hear the
word intellect coming out of a woman's
mouth and they think that's a bad thing
and it's not no no no I did not say that
I want some dumb [__] following me
around but I think you're overvaluing
what you perceive to be intellect above
other things because listen if your
theory was so good you wouldn't be
single right now no that's not why
okay why I am not in a relationship
because my relationship was toxic I was
getting hurt by somebody that was how do
you attract the same thing wait wait
wait wait wait wait so so it's because
it was toxic why do you attract toxic
men I attracted one okay but you stayed
with him for five years probably because
of daddy issues potentially okay because
my dad was very strong and powerful what
are you because your dad was powerful
very strong and powerful and with that
me having that as a realization
what am I doing to Silver yeah your
daddy issues I've already done it I've
already I analyzed everything I've
already studied myself like a therapist
not for very long I just sit down I
speak to a lot of my guy friends I've
got big brothers that speak to me and
they tell me exactly the things that
should be should and shouldn't be done
being a dumb woman is not a good thing
no one here said you should be dumb I'm
not saying that anybody said that you
just made fun of women for being dumb
and not only that it's not funny
look at there
I'm smart I get good at everything I do
I was probably top one two percent in
volleyball in the entire of all the
people that start I was really really
good I'm I'm the top I don't know 1 000
podcasts in the United States killing it
on the podcast I have one of the biggest
podcasts in the world I get good at
everything I do I I'm I sing I do music
when I'm a smart and I'm not even trying
to toot my own horn but it's like I am
smart you're killing it guys don't
really care that much it's a bonus sure
some guys find it nice but it's not a
selling point
well not for you and not for some other
people but for the men that mean country
is a great conversation for us to have
it's a great moment where I actually
realize fully well why it is important
for a woman to be at least at least the
the educated for a man that is doing
very well as your friend you should get
therapy though oh you should maybe you
should get 30 years old because you said
they're acting like you're some Superior
sort of woman these times you you really
know I say I say as I've said I am not
Superior I'm not better the reason I'm
saying for the fact that you think I
should go get therapy is a problem I
think that because of what you said you
said you pick toxic men because of you
when I attracted one denalvo wait wait
can you wait till I finish you said you
pick toxic men because of your daddy
okay you stayed with a toxic guy for
five years because of daddy issues right
okay you said the way you fixed that was
talking to your male friends I went to
therapy for a bit okay into therapy for
a little bit I I think that that you
should go to therapy to solve it to a
male therapist it's just based off of
what you said okay I'm not saying this
to attack you personally I'm not saying
I'm better don't get triggered I'm
saying this based on the information you
gave me okay and now I'll explain
something to you my sister here's why
you're wrong Pearl no no it's not why
she's wrong it's just so that she can
understand the person that she's
speaking to because a lot of the time we
sit in these situations and we take
people for face value and a lot of times
I listen to what you say yeah that's
okay that's okay it's still on the
surface because it's the same way that
people see me on this camera and they
assume that I'm the biggest [__] in
these times I'm actually really nice and
very friendly and very Smiley do you see
what I mean so people shouldn't take
things for face value let me tell you
something as the person that I am and as
the person that is as inquisitive as I
am and when to learn why I got myself
into that situation why it happened and
actually I've done a lot of things and
I've put a lot of systems around me to
make sure that I'm also not only
protected but also I'm educating myself
every single day and growing up
based on what you said you seem scared
wait wait okay
you you're saying that you want separate
houses this this is not someone that's
going into a relationship in good faith
if I were you I would go see a male
therapist that's that's it I don't you
could you can say I'm wrong you don't
have to go that's just my two cents you
don't have to I don't need to I don't
need it so that's okay I want to ask you
this to know but so then given your
perspective on things like what at I
mean you're 31 at the screen 30 30. okay
you can be 31 this year next year this
year when's your birthday December you
Sagittarius yes sir me too when's your
birthday the second seventh really
I beat you mine was first
but listen let me so run this past me
you're 30 right clearly intelligent
woman you know you have a backbone very
strong backbone
what is your mating strategy moving
forward
what do you mean how am I gonna how do I
find the men how are you gonna acquire
it what do you want first do you want do
you want children do you want family uh
I
I'd like to have two children two yeah
okay Max okay so you wanna have two
children Max and
how do you plan to acquire a man
with your given skill set
um I don't plan on acquiring a man so I
think people make a mistake of looking
for something when that something will
come I'm very much aware of the fact
that I'm building myself up to be
somebody that will attract a type of
person okay so whether I'm intelligent
whether I'm rich or poor whether I'm
sitting on these cameras whatever it is
none of this is my real life none of
this is who I am this is not even a
fraction of the entire person that I am
so I don't need to look realistically
like this it's not a joke when I tell
you that I'm single by choice there's a
lot of men around me that I believe are
fantastic men that really are interested
in being with a woman like me but I am
not interested especially not at this
point where I believe that I need to
take my time to be able to settle myself
before I go into a relationship do you
see what I mean and then not only that
through this spirit and through being in
that relationship and through
understanding things with much more
Clarity I fully understand the fact that
as human beings forget about man and
woman as human beings we're actually
much more complex than people realize
and Villa and a lot of the time we're
forcing ourselves to be in situations
that are just not conducive for our own
individual mental well-being so what if
what if like uh what if like an
attractive like successful man
was to say hey I'm interested in you
what would you do
okay like let's talk but at the same
time you said you're not looking for it
so I don't know because you because I'm
confused because you said on one hand
I want to get married I want to have two
children but at the same time you're
like but I'm not gonna look for it so
how are you gonna find something that
you're not looking for because I don't
need to look for it that's the thing I
believe in faith whatever will be will
be I don't need to try and control this
situation because the more you're
controlling the more you try usually the
more you end up in the wrong situation
because something that looks like it's
amazing may just not be so okay so on
that one I definitely disagree because I
have never seen somebody in my 37 years
of being alive who has put their entire
effort into trying to get something
literally all their effort day in and
day out and not get it well I think that
you'll find a lot of the time especially
when it comes to girls and they feel
they fall under the pressure like oh I
need to find somebody
finding the wrong because the
desperation or the pressure makes you
make the wrong decision so for me I
would much rather work on being a
healthier and happier human being so
that when the time does come I'm more
than ready do you have any evidence I I
see what you're saying like they're
saying if they look for a man they look
for relationship they're too desperate
and they end up getting in a bad
situation right but have you seen that
happen yes okay so have you also seen a
woman who says I'm not gonna be a hoe
I'm gonna buckle down I'm gonna go find
a good man and find a good man and get
married and have family and have
relationships have you seen that too
um
yeah
I think it depends on luck as well like
luck is definitely part of it for sure
because personally like I wasn't dating
for like two years I wasn't even looking
because the relationship I had before
was so strong I moved countries so I
couldn't see that person so I was
holding on to that I didn't sorry
um so like my relationship like I wasn't
looking to find somebody else when I
moved countries for the person I was
dating for like four years
um I was like I didn't want to see
anybody else I was just used to that so
like I wasn't trying I didn't just sort
of happened I met someone after like two
years it was so weird like he saw me on
Snapchat map and he was like do you want
to have dinner how I'm sorry lunch like
on Snapchat how old are you again 21
yeah okay yeah so he met me on Snapchat
you have different privileges at 21 than
you do at 30. yeah okay I'm not talking
about being 30 but I'm just saying I
like a long-term relationship I don't
like to happen no no no I'm saying like
like I'm saying that we're saying you're
younger and hotter now and 10 years I'm
trying to get married as well like now
I'm younger smart I'm working like
really hard I'm trying to like get I
just look talk to myself for so long
that I cannot I how do I put this I
don't have the opportunity to sleep I
don't have the opportunities that I can
just go mess around because if I say I
want to go pie and have fun right now
I'm gonna be on the street because
there's no one going to pay my rent my
mom is not gonna say let me send you
money do you know I mean I don't have
that privileges to mess up so it's like
I feel like I have my things sorted out
now I'm thinking like I'm gonna get a
job I'm saving money I'm gonna get a
mortgage I want to do that I want to be
married I want to find somebody and
hopefully like luckily for me like I'm
with somebody right now we're not in the
richest part of where we're supposed to
be because we're young you know I mean
we're not expecting the biggest one I'm
obviously I know that I'm pretty I
that's what I say myself you are very
pretty I can go outside right now and I
could be like I could go on Instagram my
Instagram is not that but I could see I
won that man I could go out and I try my
hardest to get like you know a guy who's
10 10 or something like that so I'm not
looking for that you're in you're in a
relationship yeah so when when would you
like to be married be personally I've
been saying I want to be married in like
when I'm 25 I wouldn't be like because I
feel like but then does he know that you
want to be married oh yeah
does he also want to be married yeah but
like people want to get married to each
other stuff like that like we say all
the time so he he wants to be married
too yeah this right now it's so weird
okay no so what's that what's that
what's the hold up
um how long have you been dating oh so
we've been dating for like two years um
like what in a month or a couple weeks
this is the hold up like if why don't
you just go because we're young like do
you know what I mean like we have
different he's he's young he's just like
you know I mean we have things so we're
working towards certain things I want a
nice drink he wants something nice as
well we're working to get that so I like
a man that I grew up with I like a man
that's good about me I don't want
something already made because it's like
I don't know that person
I'm gonna say oh because I have all of
this you can listen to me I'll tell you
this though like uh having a nice ring
is not nearly as important as having a
decent person in your life and I think
that's something because a lot of people
when you're in a relationship too I I
fell victim to this too yeah I was in
such a good relationship that I got
comfortable and I realized like oh well
if things don't work out with her I can
just go find the other perfect amazing
girl and then now I'm out here in the
streets with all these [__] hookers
everywhere and it's hard as hell to find
a decent woman out there because you
know I was completely lost in
understanding the fact that I had
something good we have right in front of
you so don't get too caught up I'll just
tell you this as a guy who's older than
you he's done a little bit more than you
don't get too caught up in the
materialism things saying I need this I
need that and just focus on what you
really really really want like when
you're about to lie when you're in your
deathbed you're not going to be like
well you know what I lived a good life
and God damn it what a nice ring I've
got on my face
and he would talk about how like these
women people would be dating for one two
years and he's like why don't you just
get married
and I I and what I realized is the point
he was getting at is like women
oftentimes want the ring in the wedding
but they don't want the marriage right
and so like they'll they'll hold off to
get married when it's like you can get a
bigger ring later
but um yeah I don't know I'm not saying
I don't want to get right now but like
I'm 21. he's like the same like he's
sweating how many kids do you want um I
want two kids because like I want to be
able to have the resources to take care
of them but like we're growing we'll
yeah I know I know him obviously yeah
but we learn a lot about it I know him
enough you know what I mean would I want
to get married to 21 no because I want
to work I want to end money I want him
to do that as well like I'm not stable
I'm just saying like a lot of times they
sell you that you need to wait to get
married and I don't really think you do
no you really I'm not selling that not
just the choice I'm saying like in the
media the corporations that's the choice
like do I want to be married no no I
want to I still want to end money I
still want to go to work I still want to
be able to why can't you earn money
while you're married because if I'm
married yeah knowing myself I'm such a
family-oriented person like I didn't
really like have siblings growing up I
grew up with my family so if I get
married I feel like I'll forget every
other thing I'll get too comfortable I
just want to be home and take care of my
kids I want to see them running around
that's right and now that's what I want
to do what do you do
um right now I'm so I work for Costco as
a brand ambassador for Costco but I
recently what about basketball what is
what is that it's a brand ambassador so
like could you say run a lot of Alexa
and it's like a how do I put an
advertise certain products for Costco
yeah I recently got a new job like as an
air hostess I don't know if this is
gonna like to fly so yeah but like you
know it's like I've gone through stuff
like a lot of that but I was like I just
have a set of plan in my head yeah but
it's like okay you're gonna be a sky
waitress
no no not a bad thing not a bad thing
but I'm just saying like wouldn't
wouldn't it be better to spend that
energy on your kids yeah but yeah I you
can you know what it sounds to me like
you're economically afraid like if you
give up the opportunity to be you know
an employee or something along those
lines that you might have no money and
you might be I wonder
I want to be financially stable it's
just a normal everybody
let's just say this if I was with
somebody if my boyfriend just happened
to be like super rich Let's just say if
he was a stable person I would be
married right now like it would not be
myself tomorrow but because if I'm
getting if I got married now and had a
kid what's what's going to happen to my
kids what are we gonna do we're just
gonna cuddle all night well I'll tell
you this you're gonna find more comfort
and love and and fulfillment in sticking
together as a couple as you both grind
to the top I like right that that is one
of the most strong emotional bonds
you'll ever build with someone right
dude I'm doing so much good work for you
and your boyfriend right now your
boyfriend's again you better follow me
on Instagram hot dude life no
like you know sticking with him and you
guys both building As you move to the
top is going to be far more of a
rewarding experience than you going into
that cold and heartless corporate world
where you're just a number on a
spreadsheet that if you don't do certain
things that you're just completely off
the charts I know I just want us to help
each other you know like we just gotta
help each other a lot because obviously
it does happen like we just get like we
do get married in the future but if we
don't we don't well at least right now
I'm happy we're stable he's nice to me
I'm with him for two years for a reason
he's not stupid no it's not like the
mandam he's not a road man he's not like
active them so I mean he's just nice
like where I come home it's something to
go back to we cook together we laugh
together we go on little walks it's not
it doesn't have to be the fanciest thing
right now but I know that we're gonna
get there because we have the same
mentality of wanting to work harder to
get something We're Young right now
we're gonna get it yes it's nice to
dream big I want a fancy thing but yeah
I don't I don't being fancy all the
money but if I'm not happy and I don't
feel comfortable lying beside the person
I'm with then it's not worth it for me
personally I don't not about every other
person out there so I'd rather be with
my little boy not my little boy sorry my
boyfriend that me being us just being
young together we don't have any faith
but we're comfortable like he can go
take me on a date I could take him on a
day we can leave accident we can have
ice creams walking on the park and
that's good enough for me because I'm
happy you know what I mean and then one
day boom we're working right now he's a
graduate now he's going to get nice job
together we don't live together right
now I live in I live in a different
place do you live at home or with
roommates um so I live like in a shelf
flat
um he lives in a different place as well
because I was brought in a way that I
could not live with a man as well like
my mom would kill me yeah yeah because I
can't do it even if I wanted to it's not
my culture I feel like when I get
married to somebody they're not moving
no there's a there's a pro to getting
married it's less money to pay if you're
sharing rent I know but like you know
what I mean I gotta well you couldn't
after you I'm waiting I'm waiting
wait wait
um I'm gonna I'm gonna Read Super Chat
so because otherwise I think we'll never
get to them
um Dr David Baker um big business is
happy to push feminism because if you
flood the workforce with women you
suppress the wage um growth due to the
oversupply of Labor
um feminists help big business
businesses profit at everyone else's
expense
um
denalva mothers get inhospitable men
don't even want to be around them in
order to get to their kids and then call
them deadbeat dad I read that one
um okay let's go back to the video
blessing
shout out to Aunt Jenny in the chat yeah
I'm Jenny I want to meet you
I'm Barbados stop making
old woman oh Jenny come back no we will
not I won't lie to you
the number is a nice name it's quite
unique
I can't play it last thing
oh we only have three hours left all
right yeah well I don't think we're
gonna get through this anymore
difficult right when you control
everything you don't care about money I
mean I'd like to actually argue we talk
about Bud Light this Melanie whatever it
is whatever yeah
yeah Dylan Mulvane sweetheart yeah
and yeah I know we've damaged their
share price Etc et cetera I would
believe
who own that company or beyond that
company I don't think
in both I
think they're losing that much sleepover
maybe they are a little bit but I'm
saying you get to degrees of power and
levels of power where you don't care
about money I'll give you a perfect
example of it
I know we keep going back to this but it
was actually a massive pivotal event in
Awakening so many people was the covid
scam
I said this multiple times in many
different countries I visited I said if
they cared about you they would have
left everything open maybe put a tax on
everything extra tax percent whatever
and Bill hospitals why didn't they do
that why'd they why did they lock you
all up because it's a mass Appliance
exercise they want you to comply they
don't give a [__] about your health they
just want you to comply they want to
test how many people comply
and people were saying yeah it's all
about money it's all about profit and I
said that's actually a very optimistic
way to look at it I think that if you
destroy the economy and lock up one of
their houses and Destroy everyone's
businesses you don't care about money
you're you're beyond money you're above
money you want power and you want
control
because once you become actually rich
you learn that the world is all just
about people
right the best things in your life for
people best things in your life for
family things make you happiest are your
friends your life experience is the best
if you have good news good assistance
good healthy listening checking
Instagram
what do you want money for
the best thing in life with friends
I want Lamborghini
I will pay him to build me a Lamborghini
it's all about people so once you get
Beyond a certain level of money
and there's a certain level of control
you want that money perhaps can't buy
buy then you think well I don't care
about the money I want the power
I want money I want them to stay in
their houses why because I said so I
don't have to they have to haha it's
funny and that said and sat with people
and said do you really think people in
charge of the world are so petty that
they would lock everyone in their houses
so they can laugh and say yeah I
actually do I think if you were born
into a wealthy family where money has
precisely zero value and you are
arrogant to the move because you're this
whoever and you believe you're God's
gift and you don't a Ferrari ain't gonna
make you happy you can throw a Ferrari
Ferrari's freeze pennies you don't care
about any of this [__] what makes you
happy is everyone respecting you and
being afraid of you
to a degree you're going to try and
influence some power and fear I think
that's what it is so I think a lot of
these companies when they're doing these
things and they're upsetting people Etc
yeah it's good that we're fighting back
but I also think part of them enjoy the
show
I think part of them genuinely enjoy the
show I think part of them go you know
what
let's do this is this is insane let's do
this oh they're fighting uh I really
believe it I I know it's a pessimistic
way to look at it but I think they
enjoyed the show apart I don't disagree
with you in in regards to that I can see
that how you know you see it in movies
or scenes where you know condescending
arrogant you know and they kind of want
to they enjoy bullying the guy that
can't help himself right hey do this hey
clean up pick this up I look at this
he'll do anything that I need him to do
right I fully believe those types of
things exist but and empires have fallen
so many times because they thought they
can get away with murder and then
eventually people said listen stop
you're not gonna do this to me anymore
we're not we're not going to take a
stand and typically when that happens
you said it earlier uh you know what is
really why what's going on in Glendale
or some of these other cities that
people are protesting why is there an
organization called gays against
groomers gays against groomers what what
do you what are you doing man I just
wanted to be given leave me alone I'm
not trying to be you know grooming kids
that's not my job I just want to be gay
leave me alone we've made so much
progress these guys I'm not that guy I'm
not this person right so I think the
part that
they fear the most if you read Communist
Manifesto there's a book written by uh
Cleon skousen I think he was like a
former CIA agent for like 15 years he
wrote a book called The Naked communist
one of the things he talks about how
getting rid of God well they're
succeeding in that area but not fully
yet you know getting rid of the family
nucleus well we already know what is the
purpose of this lgbtq movement what is
the purpose of this transgender what is
the purpose of let me get this straight
this person cannot buy a gun at 13. this
person cannot go in the military at 13.
this person cannot vote at 18. this
person cannot own a car at 13 but they
can transition the most the most
important decision of their lives you're
okay with yes now that doesn't make
sense to me that doesn't make sense to
me I think you said something at the
beginning the the concept of being
tolerant you know what yeah it's okay we
can't have gays oh it's okay we can have
this so uh listen man uh-uh you've
crossed the line I think Faith Family
Kids values principles they fear the
hell out of absolutely and I think that
Community is rising up no you're totally
right but you made a really interesting
point there about Empires falling and
this is where I kind of feel like we're
entering a new stage of the world
because it's never really done before
because typically when Empires fell the
world was far more polarized if the
empire fell there was nowhere for the
corrupt dictators of set Empire to go
the Empire's Fallen where I say let's
say England fell you can't it's very
hard to get Exile in France you could do
it a little bit but let's say America
fell today let's say it completely
collapsed and it fell the people who
archetyped that downfall do you think
they beat America
do you think they'd be sitting there
waiting to get scooped up do you know
who they are
can you recognize them what's their name
even if you could do you think they're
in America or do you think they're
skiing is so sad
this globalism the whole point of
globalism is that they don't care when
Empires fall when you globalize the
world then you have a chess board I lost
the knife it doesn't matter but Bishop
sack the queen who cares there's so many
things I want to say that I don't want
to die but there's truth this can be
proven and shown even with this current
proxy war
Europe and all the gas prices and the
inflation rate in Europe has gone to the
Moon to fund this proxy war in Ukraine
why is this happen because America's in
charge of everything and America has
decided that Europe has to Bear the
brunt of the [__] for its proxy war
you're going to have higher gas prices
you're going to have inflation you're
going to have massive unrest you're
going to deal with it all right and
we're going to sit over here and
insulate ourselves because we have the
global Reserve currency and the war is
going to happen over there and
everyone's going to die and we're in
charge
so now we have this globalism how can an
Empire fall when you have basically two
camps there's two teams now there's two
sides left so it's it's a it's I agree
with you completely my Empire's falling
but I'm saying if the empires fell in
days of old the Kings would be strung up
but now when the Empire Falls nobody
knows this it doesn't matter we don't
know who the king's song we don't know
who's in charge we don't know where they
are they're not going to be anywhere
near the trouble that's for [__] sure
there's gonna be somewhere else oops oh
well and do they really care
do do the people in charge of the world
care if America's crime rate goes up one
thousand percent would they lose sleep I
actually think they do partially because
think about it so I'm with Andrew
Schultz and I'm taking your position
with him yeah okay you know what Andrew
Schultz is good guy and he says you know
part of me that gives me Comfort is no
one these guys are so obsessed with
their money he may be wrong so we can
debate this they're so obsessed with
their money that there's no way they're
going to let America fall because if
America Falls everything else Falls so
they're going to go just as much as they
can to control but not enough to get the
machine to break because they're so in
love with money and power they don't
want to give that up well I hope that's
true I would love for that to be true
but my argument is that these people are
already so deeply entrenched they print
the money
go print the new money I don't care they
cared about money covered wouldn't have
happened they closed the entire economy
I don't think they care about money I
think they can I think they control the
world to a level where you want to eat
do you want war
like I don't think they give a [__]
about money they'll print the new money
they'll change the name of it and print
the new one at a certain level of power
I think they're so above and beyond all
of our concepts of how the world works
and they don't have any interest in any
of it I don't think they give a [__] I
think if you were to go to these people
whoever they are and say we're going to
take your money away they would just
laugh at you you think you can take my
money you think you understand money you
think you're going to damage the stock
marketing I give a [__] about share
price
I think there's a level beyond all of
this and they're the ones who truly are
running things and they truly have no
influence and in fact the harder they
damage the economy and the more damage
they do to money the more people are
dependent on governments to eat that's
where communism comes from right the
more poor we get the more you need the
government just so you have food in your
mouth how can you resist the government
if they feed you
you can't
so yeah like and I sound pessimistic and
I'm not pessimistic and I do believe the
answer to all of these things is free
thinking and truth and God and Community
standing up for themselves and changing
the general consensus I do believe that
because to a degree
although we talk about people who run
the world to a degree We Run the World
because
our tolerance level is what runs the
world there's more of us than them so to
a degree you say who's in charge of the
world well I like to say what we are
because it's all about we're the Abu
we're the abused wife in this
relationship how much crap are we gonna
put up with
reset the limit
they're going to come at us with
everything they can right we set the
limit but the problem is they try very
very hard to one increase our limit to
the max which is tolerance and two to
divide us to the point where we don't
ever unite long enough I love what
happened in Glendale what you just told
me about that should be happening in
every single School Across America all
of them oh they would love it if you
retweet the video for them and give more
exposure you know it's when you're
saying this I'm reading a book right now
Robert Moses I don't know if you know
who he is or not power broker it's a guy
it would be very interesting guy for you
to study this is the guy that built New
York okay and he came up and uh uh hate
it uh uh complicated person
misunderstood uh the more they would
push him back the more he stood up the
more they would say no this is not fair
what you're doing the more he would even
say I'm gonna go more even more extreme
and so if in New York you mentioned the
name Robert Moses there's going to be a
camp that's going to say scumbag racist
white supremacists all this stuff and
and there's a side that's going to say
this guy built a bridge this guy did
this this guy did that he he he would
make it so hard for a certain Community
go to the nicer Community he would put
the car you know the bridge so low that
trucks couldn't go through because he
didn't want the bad people to go into
this like he was that sharp and one time
in the book they talk about how Robert
Moses he says look the one thing about
Robert Moses he could give you [__]
about money he could give a [__] it was
all about his influence over so I agree
there are certain people that don't care
about money they're more driven by
control influence all of that the part
that uh you know we're talking about the
movie Fury Vinnie and you give me this
whole thing about Fury the scene where
Shia LaBeouf is reading out of the Bible
and he's crying while he's reading this
and then right if you want to text me
what's with the and then afterwards you
see uh Brad Pitt quotes exactly what
scripture it was but they never showed
how much Faith he had and the whole
point was I'm ready to die and we know
we're here this is going to be happening
we're in the attack there's no I think
the people
there's a part about Trump uh how to
grow on Whitney Webb I don't know if you
know who Whitney Webb is we had Iran
okay yeah and we start talking about
different things and I've been having a
lot of weird guests on lately
and making a comparison between the
Kennedy family and Trump
pisses a lot of people off but those two
families forget the fact that one's a
Democrat one's a republican they were
both anti-establishments they were both
anti-military industrial complex they
were both anti-cia anti-fbi anti-all of
this stuff right we saw what happened
with Kennedy we saw what happened with
Reagan we saw what happened with Lincoln
all these guys were anti-establishment
guys we saw what happened with Trump the
part about Trump that
you know
made the other side uncomfortable is
okay we can kill the guy
that's been the strategy for a long time
you can't really do it today
as much because they fear one thing that
they're the most jealous and envy you
know what that is they don't want they
do not want to build a martyr yes they
fear building a martyr because that's
the ultimate height that they want to
get they do not want to build a martyr
right
so okay we're going to humiliate the
crap out of you we can embarrass the
crap out of you we're going to publicly
try to do this we're going to come in
between you and your kids you know we're
going to go get your daughter to be more
LGBT we're going to get her to be on
this side and we're going to pin this
that's the strategy we're going to put
the break into our family apart right
and he still stands up there yeah and to
them it's like what the hell do we need
to do freedom is you know just sit down
and be quiet not willing to do it that's
right do you think again going back to
it
more of those types of men and women who
are misunderstood and complicated
stories they they're not perfect far
from it more of those guys are the ones
that are saying yeah it's just not going
to happen on my watch man and that's
what we need and the the by the very
nature of being the kind of person who's
principled enough to risk his own
personal
situation in life if you have principles
that strong you're going to be disliked
by some people you're never going to
have a person who is principled enough
to take risk to his public detriment for
the good of what he believes in who's
liked by everybody that that's a logic
fail right because he has principles
which are hard lines and people exist
across the entire Spectrum so there's
many people exist outside of those lines
that's what I liked about Trump he's not
perfect of course not but he says what
he means he means what he says I
actually disagree with him on many
things but he says what he means he
means what he says and that's what
they're afraid of they're afraid of a
man who says what he means and means
what he says because he can't be bought
because he's principled he can't be
bought even now me if they're a company
with 100 million dollars and say We'll
sponsor you with this company is 100
million dollars you just have to shut up
I'd say no but anyway I don't want the
money I don't need money there's nothing
else to buy I bought everything I don't
need it I buy principles worth more so
and that's what they're afraid of
they're afraid of principles and it goes
back to the original point they're
trying to remove all of our morality all
of our Baseline understanding of things
my neck is an application which allows
you to take a minute to connect with
influencers from all around the world my
name is Andrew Tate and I'm available to
speak directly to you on minute that's
that's how they inject you with the
slave mind that's exactly it is and
you're right history has always been
that way and now it's under conscious
assault
I've never said this before I've never
even thought this before this is a brand
new thought for me but I would like to
think in times of old in history perhaps
everybody was the same everybody was
principled everybody had parameters but
they were different parameters perhaps
there were competing ideas but I think
in the modern world it's not so much
competing parameters it's just people
who believe in things people don't
believe in anything besides what they're
[__] told that changes every day do
you have the empty brains the the slave
minds and the people who actually stand
up for something
but the slave Minds you can't say well
they believe in a different ideology
because they don't they believe in what
they're told to believe in on that
particular day it changes they don't
have any true core belief they just
repeat
I talk about the Matrix all the time
people say why did you choose that
terminology and I chose that terminology
because it's perfectly accurate in
describing exactly what is happening The
Matrix is a computer program which is
designed to control your mind so that
your body can be used to power the
machines that's exactly what happens
when they make you watch the news to
control your minds you continue to use
your body to work some garbage job and
suffer from inflation and power the
machines machines being soulless people
who are in charge of the world but
there's also a million other different
ways you can compare the Matrix to the
real world and the Matrix they say
anybody can become an agent at any time
if their mind is not unplugged they
become an agent if their mind is not
free they turn into an agent you see
that in real life mention kova to an NPC
mention Trump to an NPC you can sit and
have a perfectly cordial normal
conversation with somebody for an hour
and be fine and you can mention one of
the particular subjects which they are
programmed to Hate by The Matrix itself
and they will turn into an agent in real
time and you will see them now start to
genuinely emotionally dislike you as a
person they were your friend for an hour
now they hate you they don't turn into
an agent Kobe was perfect I would sit
with people we'd all be friends until I
mentioned the code's garbage
now they're an agent agent what do you
mean Kobe's garbage my friend's grandma
was 99 she got sick
okay sorry
it doesn't change my view and they
change
and and the Matrix is actually a perfect
absolute explanation of what's happening
and and Morpheus says it if your mind's
not free you can be one of them and
that's what's happening and this is why
we have we don't have competing sets of
parameters which you're trying to argue
about which is the best way to run the
world we have people with parameters who
believe in family and love and God and
tradition and taking care of yourself
and taking care of others there's people
with moral standard and there's people
with none zero empty vessels agents who
are programmed on any given day of
whether what they're supposed to care
about these people can't tell me they
care about things that's what's most
annoying about my position because it's
absolutely an hourly weaponized virtue
they use against me the people who hate
me hate me because one I I truly believe
and I know this is arrogant to say but I
feel like I have to say it there's huge
there's definitely a massive jealousy
implement
if I wasn't so tall and rich and good
looking it wouldn't be happening they
don't [__] like me they don't like me
because I remind them of the chocolate
school that took their girl that's part
of it right they don't like me
personally so they can't they try it
it's true so they try and find an attack
vector and what happens when you have
somebody who's monumentally successful
across all Realms of human endeavor the
only way you can attack them is by
calling them a bad person they call them
can't call me stupid they can't call me
ugly can't call me broke can't call me
weak can't
bad person how do you call someone a bad
person you weaponize virtue none of the
people none who are pretending to give a
[__] about women
and that I'm bad to protect women have
any interest in protecting women none of
these people think I better become
physically strong so protect women none
of them even believe in protecting a
woman in a physical scenario one of them
even believe in protecting their family
of any oh God
wait none of them don't eat any
Charities that involve women nothing
they're just taking the virtue and
weaponizing it and attacking me with it
me as a person who donates 25 million a
year to charity to feed both male and
female children me as a person who
believes I have a responsibility to be
physically capable so that any woman I'm
walking down the street with is safe I
do more for women than any of these
clowns and this is the crazy thing it's
always the people that do are doing
nothing
it's like even when I got in trouble for
the you know you know what kind of
contracts they accuse me of given
it was all these people that had zero
contracts
that did nothing and it's always the
people that do nothing I think I'm
oldies muted um but it's always the
people that do nothing
the most that are doing something but
it's like well why don't you go do what
we do yeah yeah no it's true because
because that's this like what valueless
people do I talked about earlier in a
live stream I was doing today it's
people who cannot provide value what
they do instinctively is tear others
down exactly you know you're either in
this life either somebody who adds value
or you're someone that destroys value
and these people they've like and the
majority of people are
that the type of people that can't add
value that's why they watch these fake
news reaction channels right because
those guys are losers and what do these
losers do they attract a loser audience
and then they create this loser [__]
system that's going on and like you know
every time I got I got attacked by you
know a a blue-haired feminist recently
and uh his entire Army attacked me it
was so funny everybody was like insult
to me I would click on their profile
photo it would be some fat loser or some
ugly whale or something like you know
some soy looking dude earlier do like a
million piercings in his face like
criticizing me and I'm just like wow
this is hilarious because the thing is
this too the good will always be
outnumbered by the evil right and the
smart will always be outnumbered by the
stupid but because we're smart because
we're good we have an advantage over
them you know their own stupidity works
against them but it's that's they I
think part of it too is like a certain
hatred for themselves because they know
that they can't provide value so they
try to tear us down you know what I mean
because look at us so we have all the
resources in the world to go out and
tear people down but we don't even our
platform is not built upon tearing
people down it's a it's built upon
lifting people up but they want to take
like one little spot of our imperfection
human existence and try to tear down our
entire message but be like oh look at
this one little thing you did
incorrectly therefore everything you've
said is incorrect no and and that's the
thing it's like a lot of these guys have
been on the internet for a minute where
they could have reinvested into
organizations they could have reinvested
into people they could have built
something big and none of them did it
where where it's like a lot of them have
been successful for a long time and it's
I was thinking as a guy I'm like
Imagine The Pinnacle of your existence
the Legacy you've brought to the world
is a drama Channel dude it's such a
loser done even like the guys that
stream like 10 hours a day and I'm not
talking with real people just like
online 10 hours a day for without doing
anything else for years it's like what
does that do to your I know I go a bit
too crazy even doing the shows like if I
don't leave here enough I'm like I go a
little bit nuts yeah yeah I'm like I
can't imagine doing that for years and
years and years what that would do and
you can like you can like see the
negativity like build on them even like
I mean you know like I I used to not
always be the biggest fan of my red and
then I came around and realized like
they're doing such good things for men
oh yeah and you can see like they get
better and better and all of their
critics and detractors like they get
into better shape their critics and
detractors get get fatter they get like
more like down like they have crazy
weird relations you know that's why
Martin's so bulletproof in these debates
because it's just like literally like
years of like putting hoes in their
place like no [__] this is why you're
wrong and here's he's like you know he
could you could wake Marin up out of a
drunken stupor and have him like debate
five feminists at once and he'd knock
them all out you know no he's gotten so
good he's really good the sauce cast
like um or the thing they did at sauce
he was amazing that was like one of his
best debate performances ever mine's a
beast man he's seriously like you know
as a guy who
like practices what he preaches I mean a
lot of people behind the scenes don't
really understand how disciplined and
like by the book Byron really is and
he's just so bulletproof in all he says
because he has everything that backs it
up and sure like is everything he said
a hundred percent solution for every
woman on the planet no there are certain
situations where he's not correct but at
the same time you know for the majority
of the situations he is correct and
that's what he's trying to do we're not
trying to be perfect we're trying to
give a large enough solution to help as
many people as possible with a generic
advice you know what I mean yeah and
that's that's the thing they'll like it
really irritates me because they'll like
dig into you guys and be like oh there's
this one example of when he sipped or
there's this this one time where they
dated a single mother like or what like
whatever whatever they're like gotcha
moment is yeah but it's it's just like
okay is what they're saying true I don't
even care I don't even care if like
they're the biggest simp on the planet I
just want to know like is what he is
saying correct you know and that's funny
Destiny is so dumb like I he played
right into my hand because I asked him
what are his thoughts about money
muscles game frame completely agreed
with me not a single rebuttal nothing
along those lines agreed with everything
I said what is that the muscle it's just
it's the thing that I tell guys you
gotta make money make muscles learn game
and hold frame as is the core four
things a man should be working on which
is basically make money learn how to
make money learn how to manage your
money learn how to invest money don't be
a guy that's in your 30s or even late
20s when your money is still a problem
for you make muscles which is basically
don't be fat take care of your physical
fitness that's the most important thing
you have on this planet learn game
understand what is attractive to women
what is unattractive how to attract
women bring them into your life how to
know which a good woman is versus what a
bad woman is so you have sexual access
so you're not like sexually starved
because a lot of these guys sell their
dignity just to get some [__] and then
frame is about your self-esteem
boundaries your perspective on life what
you want in life what you don't want and
enforcing those boundaries and what I
mean by enforcing them is basically
identifying people who do not agree with
with your life statement who do not
agree with your boundaries and simply
removing them from your life and never
letting them back in and I say focus on
those core things money muscles game
frame and the detractors to this day
have nothing to say absolutely nothing
to go against that to be fair money is
not necessarily super important but
being able to manage it brings stability
yeah that's good I agree with you but
think about this too like when the check
comes everybody looks at the man
everybody looks at the dad you know when
even before if us if us for we're gonna
go out to dinner right me you and then
blessing right
um I'll definitely look at you you made
a million a month so well no no I'm just
talking about the people and we're
ordering when they order yes the staff
is going to look at one of us and be
like all right man who's paying up you
know they're not like hey ladies like
you're you're the best yeah you know
even though Pearl's balling and you're
the [__] director of 900 companies
you know what I mean you know they're
gonna ask them they're gonna look at the
men because the onus is on men
traditionally speaking and even today
you know when women are looking for a
guy you know these high value women
they're looking for guy that got their
[__] together because they don't want to
pay either it's just how it's part of
being a man and then you know the also
in addition to that all people are
pretty [__] with money all people are
pretty sure so it's a skill you should
absolutely work on mastering so you can
be above average individual but again
like when they try to attack our message
they can't they say like Pearl's a
grifter or Pearl's this or Pearl's hat
but a lot of people who hate on Pearl in
the Internet space reality is they're
just jealous because Pearl built a
[__] Empire in like a like what less
than two years as is two years now a
year and a half right a year and a half
year and a half crushing the game right
doing it with a smile on her face not a
bitter bone in her body and they're just
jealous a lot of these people are
massively jealous
and so that's what they do they try to
attack Pearl as an individual say oh
you're grifter you're not married you're
this you're that whatever trash excuse
because that's all those excuses are
they are not valid they're not trash and
they can't attack the bulletproof
positions that she has taken of course
you know what everything she's saying is
backed up with hard science when these
other [__] want to be like oh
well you should destroy a relationship
over Choice really really chores like
are you are you are you [__] infant
everybody already said he's like you're
such a child and I'm
he's like he'll they'll be like oh
you've never had a real relationship and
then do a hit piece on my ex-boyfriend
I'm like which one is it yeah I just
want to know choose your Insanity you
know he's calling you a child and he's
34 years old dying his hair blue
and then alternative
he failed really
yeah it's like it's like abandoning your
son for a [__]
it was Sunday I could go chase his [__]
across [__] Europe you know what I
mean so when you're looking at all these
things
I didn't know that happened yeah yeah
he's a kid he's a kid
um but United divorced her left and all
just so he can go run his gay [__]
fantasy across Europe with his yellow
two four so the reality is uh like
they're trying to like paint us as bad
people then when we live a better life
we live a more pure and clean life and
we're better role models for society
than they are you know what I mean and
they and then they do what liberals do
they just do like this hyper
manipulative
explanation that you have to like sit
down and like really dig into the
details like you know you really doesn't
work out this way because if this person
is you know black lives matter supporter
and they're then they hate Trump and
then they're transgender and then this
and this and this and like this like
crazy hyper Nuance example they give you
is supposed to refute all of the
positive work that you've done do you
know what they did to me um this pissed
me off because this was so
intellectually dishonest so I did um I
did a show with Destiny right and on the
show he you know it's crazy I was like
we were so nice to him we took him out
to dinner
I was the same way I was nice as [__] to
the guy but it was like a week later I
see him on stream talking so much [__]
about me I'm like oh wow I was like
Jesus which you know it's like one thing
if you've never met but I was like I was
actually really nice to him but you know
what whatever but snake but it was crazy
because we were on um the the couch and
he corrected me because I said that like
women are fatter than men and then he
corrected me that said that and he said
they weren't but then I went back
because I was like wow that doesn't seem
right
but what happened is they include the
fat not just the obese stats so it makes
men look fatter but it's like if a guy's
jacked that still goes into like the um
BMI correct BMI just isn't a really good
way to measure it and when I looked at
things that are supposed to be more
accurate I forgot what it's called but
it's like hit to waste ratio men versus
women and obesity stats because that's a
bit like you you're more obese women
than they're obese men right and so Ava
and preach did this whole video calling
me off of course they did they called me
a liar and they called me two on the
chores one uh because I they I they gave
one study that said the opposite of what
I said but it was funny because their
study was it was um started they they
criticized me for using one study then
they used one study and theirs was by a
woman who she she majored in like gender
studies or something so it's like very
obvious her agendas yeah the chores one
and then it was funny for the
yeah for the obese one they said I was a
liar and the crazy thing was I corrected
it in the comments I gave them the link
and they then they um they like edited
their comments so they weren't calling
me a liar anymore like with these grown
ass they're so old they're like they
look like 40 I don't know how old they
are but they look like they're like
they're like in their late yeah so
here's the thing right if they're so
Superior they're so smart and their way
of living is so
above what we're calling for right why
is society trending towards their filthy
way of living and everybody's [__]
miserable yeah and we're and we're
straying away from traditional stuff and
everybody was happier before and and
Society was way more functioning way
more stable way more healthier I mean
you got so many people are afflicted
with mental health disease nowadays it
is absolutely
detrimental to the Western population
and it's because we've been straying
away from the values that built this
great nation the way it is and we keep
on doing it and it keeps on getting
worse but they're just like no let's
just like let's keep going down this
path you know we just need more
diversity we need more inclusion we need
more all these Buzz Words which are
really just eroding away at the
foundation of society while China and
Russia laugh at us as they keep it
traditional over there yeah India too
like the people are sleeping on India
and China I mean dude those are the
future Global powers of course well and
it's like what are women really happy
without children no we're not and it's
funny like I never thought about not
going to college but that's the opposite
of like
um because you know they always they
never really talk about like the white
community's problem you know they never
even look at us as a community but I was
like
but I was like it's really common for
like white women it's like we'll go to
college
um and it's like we're very like
achievement oriented and that's you know
it's not a bad thing but it's like I
didn't realize that when you go to
college
um it's like an inverse relationship to
having children
and I I didn't realize that yep yeah it
makes sense absolutely because think
about it right you know the thing is the
when you look again at female happiness
in the United States of America
every single year they set new lows like
literally since like I think they
started documenting it in the 70s and
every year women are becoming less and
less and less happy as they all got
tricked into being consumerism slaves
right and then they just don't they're
they're being bombarded like I said it's
it sucks for women because you know you
have the media you have the government
you have social media you have movies
you have mainstream music you have video
games all the time you go girl get out
there and be a boss babe get out there
being CEO guess what you all you all
can't be CEOs but you know what you all
could be you all could be a mother
those mother positions are not running
out anytime soon same thing with wives
you have a better chance to have a wife
and mother life than you do have to be
CEO and they just think you're going to
be CEO and like yeah I'm CEO and I work
four hours a week and like this is great
dude like how many hours a week do you
work Pearl I don't know a lot like more
than 40 right probably yeah I mean it's
it's hard because
it's like do you count tweeting you know
yeah I mean no but yeah but you're on
the clock like you're you're working I
mean your tweet from the moment you
[__] wake up yeah I'm a tweeter you
know a big Tweeter but that's the thing
like and you know when I when I
graduated
um College
um I really just decided I was like you
know I I see the like party lifestyle
and I was just like I just don't want to
go down that path and I made like a
conscious effort to like stop drinking
and like not really go out and just like
stay away from that lifestyle and it
it's interesting because a lot of my
friends I went to school with they're
like overweight you know they're in
these like
crazy relation you know and it's just
like
it and me I'm like thinner than I was
when I graduated you know so it's it's
just like you can go down the path of
just doing whatever you want but it the
grass isn't always greener on the other
side no the grass is greener where you
water it yeah you know 100 so I mean
again going back to these people I mean
really these people are just the Bottom
Feeders of society and they're making
this low hanging fruit content which is
just basically like if you look at all
these people they they they're just
continuously just [__] on one person
to the other person that's all they do
yeah their legacy is tearing people down
and honestly if the joke is on them
because that that [__] with you as an
individual if you're gonna be that kind
of person go around tearing people down
tearing people down eventually it's
going to catch up with you you can't go
through life just souring a bunch of
humans and expecting great triumphant
success the majority of people who have
exceeded to succeed at high levels they
have done this through cooperating
working together Building Bridges
building alliances not tearing other
people down not making your life's work
to cause people emotional harm emotional
stress and financial troubles it's a
reflection of how they feel inside
because like you said absolutely they'll
be hating on you because they're not
capable of doing all the things that
you're doing it happens all the time I
mean I may not have my channel yet by
the way I'm building I've got my master
plan but I already feel it just from
just being exposed to this Channel and a
lot of people some of the things that
people message me or they write on the
comments I laugh because I'm like what
crosses someone's mind to even kind of
get to a stage of speaking like this of
saying certain things of of very
purposely misunderstanding the message
that's being put out there it's just I
guess like everyone's sheep and the
world is right now experiencing like
Mass anxiety I would say from you know
the cough period to war to so many
things that making people feel scared
and then all of these idiots that
throwing oil in the fire to make the
situation seem worse by creating a lot
of
um issues between people or because it's
a problem when people start to clock on
I mean even MLD when the stuff was like
when you know it was going on with you I
didn't even watch it because I was just
like you know I saw like little Clips
here I like call Pearl apologize I don't
know if I'll be bringing some drama into
your life he's like what are you talking
about I know I was like I was like I
mean like I knew there was something
like I saw I did see the indoor one but
I just didn't care because I'm just like
that people will start to clock on
because they go on these like hit peace
campaigns
yeah and they did it to me too they did
it to Myron but like people like people
just people with lives stop watching
because they just don't have time they
don't want their walk the one they don't
want to watch their drama it was insane
for me to watch it because like when I
when when uh when you know the yellow
teeth woman put out that [__] first
hit piece on me right I just watched and
I was like this pathetic [__] doing and
then I used to like I see like people
start picking up on it and start you
know seeing this gigantic lie okay start
to catch momentum and I was just
watching this like in complete all I was
like holy [__] this thing is like it was
like me watching covet happened all over
again no sorry I said the word but you
know it's me like watching the whole
thing happen all over again and just to
see how desperate these people are it's
it's always this they always do lies and
manipulation for clicks and Views to
gets money which is like the backbone of
evil that's just so [__] evil
empathetic and you know what's funny you
know it's funny it's like okay they'll
insult us first or like poke this is
what I realized what Advent preached do
is like they'll poke Bears first like
they'll do it first then we do it back
and they're like look you're doing what
you said you wouldn't do where it's like
you started it and it's like usually
people don't even respond until it's
like the fourth fifth sixth seventh or
eighth like that's what I did yeah like
it's like we won't respond and then if
we ever respond then it's we're the Bad
Guys yeah and you know that's exactly
what's happening with Andrew Tate you
know
poor guy's been going through it for
like literally like 14 months you know
what I mean right and that's why this
whole situation reviewing the video
today can kind of just be a very
sobering lesson for the audience that no
matter what you know
you got to endure
yeah so tune in guys tune in tomorrow
show on
you know
[Music]
do you endure in a marriage some would
say everything I would say pretty much
everything some would say nothing like
the left are critics and detractor some
would say chores are too much leave your
family screw your children and if you
think that you know Screw the kids they
don't matter you deserve to not have to
pick up after somebody get divorced your
mental well-being is more important than
everybody like what you said put your
kid at every statistical disadvantage
that could possibly happening because
there's dishes in the dishwasher
you know but let me know what you guys
think in the comments we'll probably
react to part two I'm sorry we we had
too many people and I think we needed to
maybe do less next time just so we could
watch more of the video but let me know
what you guys think in the comments like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel and I'll talk to you next
time